There's this thing that exists,
this,
this multi-headed snake,
and it's got this infinity problem.
It's everywhere.
That's that little circle down there,
and the problem is,
well,
what do you do with it?
You cut off one head,
seven more,
grow.
That's the eternal problem of life and
the problem is they're there.
There is the category of problems in
life and it ain't going anywhere.
And so the question is can you deal with
the whole category at the same time?
That's the thing.
That's how to be in the world is to deal
with that category all at the same time
and so how did,
how did human beings,
what did they come up with as a
solution?
And that's so cool too,
because the solution they come up with
not only was the heroism that allows you
to approach what you're terrified by and
what you find that offensive and to
learn from it,
but also the idea of sacrifice and that
was played out by cultures everywhere,
including human sacrifice.
And you think what the hell was up with
those crazy bastard so long ago?
They were sacrificing to the gods all
the time,
but kind of clueless behavior was that
burned something and please God burned
something valuable and pleased.
God.
It's like,
what was with that?
What were they thinking?
Well,
they weren't stupid.
Those people,
if they were stupid,
we wouldn't be here.
They were not stupid,
and believe me,
they lived under a lot harsher
conditions than we do.
So those were some tough people,
man.
You know,
back then you'd last about 15 minutes.
So you don't want to be thinking of your
ancestors as stupid,
like there's no real evidence that we're
much different cognitively than we were
150,000 years ago.
So anyways,
sacrifice.
What does that mean?
Sacrifice?
Well,
it's a discovery man.
It's the discovery of the future.
It's like the future is actually the
place where there is threat and it's
always going to be there.
So what do you do?
You make sacrifices in the present so
that the future is better,
right?
Everyone does that.
That's what you're doing right now.
That's what you're doing here.
That's what your parents are doing when
they pay money to send you to
university,
they think you can bargain with reality.
It's amazing.
You can bargain with reality.
You can force stole gratification now
and it'll pay off at a place in time
that doesn't even exist yet.
It's like,
who wouldn't believe that?
It's like that's a miracle that that
occurs and it's not like people just
figured that out overnight.
We were champs for Christ's sake.
Like how are we going to come up with an
idea like that?
While it's like,
well,
we thought about it for 7 million years
and you know,
we got to the point where we could kind
of act it out,
but we didn't know what we were doing,
but it was a emerge is like a dream.
It was so the terror of the future is a
dream and his solution to the terror,
the dream of the terror of the future is
another dream and it comes out in
mythology and in fantasy and in drama
where you act out the sacrifice and then
it's a step on the way to full
understanding.
So we can say sacrifice now instead of
doing it,
you know,
although we still do it,
it's just not conquer like it used to
be.
We do abstractly and we all have faith
that it will work,
you know,
and we also set up our society so that
it'll work.
And one thing about,
you know,
I'm not a fan of moral relativism for a
variety of reasons,
partly because I think it's an,
it's an extreme form of cowardice.
But anyways,
apart from that,
no,
no.
There's minimal ways that you can set up
a society that will work and so one of
them is that this society has to be set
up so that your sacrifices will pay off
or you won't work,
and then the society will die.
And so it has to make promises.
People have to make promises to one
another.
And that's what money is.
Money is a promise that your sacrifice
will pay off in the future.
That's what money is.
And so if the society is stable,
you can store up your work right now.
You can sacrifice your impulses and you
can work and you can store up credit for
the future and then you can make the
future a better place,
but society has to be stable enough to
allow for that.
Hyperinflation will do you in.
So the promise that's implicit in the
currency is the promise that what you're
doing now will pay off in the future,
and if people don't have that promise,
then what?
We know what they do because in any
gangs,
for example,
and say gangs in North America,
the time horizon of the gang members
shrinks rapidly because they don't
really expect to be alive.
Pat Much past 21.
And so they get really impulsive and
violent and like,
why the hell not that's.
That's what you do when,
when the future doesn't matter,
when it's not real you,
you default back to living in the moment
and you take what you can get right now
and no wonder because you don't know if
you're gonna,
be around in a,
in a year and you get whatever you can.
Well you can bloody well get it and
that's like anarchy that state.
And so you don't want to live in,
some people like to live in that state
because they're really wired for that,
you know?
And so they're,
they're much more comfortable in those
conditions.
They're,
they're kind of like warrior types,
I would say in some sense.
But you know,
for most people,
that's just where that stress will just
do,
you know,
the stress of a life like that.
So
I've said that some people will tell you
that the purpose of life is to be happy
and those people are idiots and was a
bit of a rough statement.
But I what I meant by that.
It was actually inspired by a statement
by Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn who was the
great critic of the Soviet prison
system.
And he commented that happiness is
something that's done in by the first
harsh blow that reality deals you.
And,
and,
and I believe this to be the case.
There are many circumstances in life
where happiness is not only the wrong
response,
but also where the expectation of
happiness as a response,
we'll put you,
the person attempting to be happy in
absolutely the wrong psychological
state,
to be prepared for what must be done.
People are built so to speak,
to experience a very wide range of
motivational and emotional states that
only bear a tenuous relationship to one
another,
and the reason for that is that the
environment that human beings inhabit is
so complex that are adaptation depends
on a variety of very finally
differentiated responses and so there is
a time to be compassionate and there's a
time to be aggressive,
massive,
and there's a time to be in pain and
there's a time to be anxious and there's
a time to be joyous and a time to be
satisfied,
and the healthy and well adapted person
has a very wide range of finally
differentiated responses which cannot be
boiled down to a single dimension.
Say happiness versus unhappiness.
A life is not that simple.
If it was,
we'd only have one emotional system
making happiness.
The focal point of your life trivializes
your experiences because in order to
regard anything as truly important,
you also have to regard it's loss as
truly meaningful,
and that means that to open yourself up
to experiences of deep meaning also
simultaneously means that you have to
open yourself up to the possibility of
deep hurt and sore.
It's something strange that I've
observed with my students is that when I
state the proposition tubing clearly
that life is suffering and that the
purpose of life is not happiness.
They actually experienced that as a
great relief and the reason I believe
that they experienced in this great
relief is they already know it.
You know,
even if they wouldn't necessarily
articulate that their experience has
taught them that life is complex and
tragic and difficult.
And the problem with the public
portrayal of the ideal state of
humanness as happiness is that it makes
all of these people.
These young people feel ashamed of their
own suffering.
They feel that if they're suffering and
if they find their life tragic in its
essence,
that that means that there's something
wrong with them and instantly that makes
it impossible for them to communicate
anything real about their own tragedy
and so it appears to me that the price
we paid for being in suffering and then
the issue there,
and I believe that this is what the
greater religious traditions of the
world have been attempting to elucidate
is that the purpose of life given that
is to identify and and follow a motive
being that makes life justifiable even
given the radical necessity of
suffering.
If you're constantly in a state of
placidity satisfaction and happiness,
then nothing is going to affect you
deeply enough.
Not your own suffering and the suffering
of other people,
not injustice,
not not the horrors of the world.
Nothing is going to affect you deeply
enough so that you'll become deep and
life without depth is by definition
shallow and meaningless,
and there's a problem that's associated
with that because life is tragic and
because life involves suffering.
If your philosophy is shallow and
meaningless,
when you suffer,
you will become resentful and hostile
and self critical and then you'll become
cruel and destructive,
and so not only is there a necessity for
your own mental health to forthrightly
confront the deepest questions of life,
but if you don't,
then you remained a danger to yourself
and maybe more importantly to others,
you know,
as an adolescent,
you also shed childhood potential to
become the limited but specialized and
potentially useful thing that you will
become.
And so you might say,
well,
is it worth it?
Is it worth shedding that potential?
And Peter Pan's answer to that is,
well,
no,
he wants to remain in Neverland as a
magical boy forever,
and he's King of the lost boys,
which I would say is not a very.
That's not much of a dominance
hierarchy,
right?
It's like you're,
you're the king king of the King of the
losers,
so to speak.
People who can't get their act together
and mature.
Now,
and you notice in Peter Pan that Peter
Pan doesn't grow up.
He doesn't establish a relationship with
Wendy who's actually real.
He has to settle for Tinkerbell who you
know is a ferry and they don't exist and
so she's really in some sense of figure
of his imagination because he won't
mature,
he can't have an actual relationship
with a genuine person.
So he has to satisfy himself with while
it's something like a pornographic
fantasy actually.
So seriously it is.
It is like that.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's a toned down a lot in the movie
version obviously,
but still that's what's underlying it.
Now you might say,
well why doesn't Peter Pan want to grow
up?
And the answer is the only figure of
authority that's around for him as his
captain Hook and he doesn't like Captain
Hook.
And that's because captain hook is a
tyrant.
He's brutal,
you know,
and he's also a coward because he's,
he's lost a hand already to a crocodile
with a clock in its stomach.
That's chaos and time,
you know,
that's the dragon that lives underneath
everything.
It's like the basset lisc can Harry
Potter and that Damn Crocodile's already
got a piece of him,
which is exactly the case.
Like that crocodile has got a piece of
me,
you know,
I'm older than 50 and so time is already
God,
its grip on me and you know,
part of the problem of being adult is
that you also have to take the fact that
your finite and limited into account and
if you're terrified by that,
which people tend to be,
then it can easily turn you into a
tyrant because you're afraid of
everything or disgusted by everything
and you have to ramp up the amount you
control it.
And so Peter Pan looks at Captain
Norcott,
he thinks there's no damn way.
That's what I want to end up as.
So he's got a bad role model.
I've been telling people online in
various ways in the lectures the patient
start fixing the world.
Bye.
Cleaning up the room and I want it to
just elaborate on that a little bit
before I get back to the lecture itself.
So I'd say it's become this Internet
weird Internet meme,
you know,
and,
and it's a joke and good.
It's a jewel.
I'm really happy about the fact that so
much of this has got like the leaving of
humor and it's really important because
that's what stops things from
degenerating into into conflict humor
and I was thinking about this idea of
cleaning up your room in relationship to
the mustard seed idea and you see the
thing about cleaning up your room.
This is also something I learned from
Carl young and his studies on alchemy
because for young,
when the alchemist was attempting to
make the philosopher's stone,
he was not only engaged in the
transformation of the material world,
but he was engaged in a process of self
transformation that occurred at the same
time as the,
as the chemical Trent,
as the chemical transformation.
So it was a psychological work in some
sense.
Let's say you want to sort out your room
and beautified because the beauty is
also important and let's say that all
you have is just a little room like
you're not rich or you're poor and you
don't have any power.
That's another thing,
but you've got your damn room and you've
got this space right in front of you.
You know that,
that that's a part of the cosmos that
you can come to grips with and you might
think,
well,
what's there in front of you right in
front of you?
And the answer to that is it depends on
how open your eyes art.
That's the proper answer because you
could say,
w William Blake said this,
for example,
eldest Huxley made comments that were
very similar that in a transcendent
state,
you can see infinity in the finite and
you might say,
well,
you can say,
and you can see infinity in what you
have within your grasp.
If you look and you could save,
maybe that's the case with your room and
so you want to clean up your room.
Well,
okay,
how do you do that?
Exactly?
Well,
a room,
his room is a place to sleep and so if
you set your room up properly,
then you figure out how to sleep and
when you should sleep and how you should
sleep and then you figure out when you
should wake up and then you figure out,
well what clothes you should wear
because they have to be arranged
properly in your dresser and then you
have to have some place to put your
clothes and you're going to have some
clothes.
You have to figure out what you're going
to wear those clothes to do.
Right,
and then that means you have to figure
out what you're going to do and then
your room has to serve that purpose
because otherwise it isn't set up
properly.
And if it doesn't set up,
if it doesn't serve your purposes,
you will be unhappy and not happy in the
room.
Because the way that we perceive the
world is as a place to move from point a
to point B in.
And then if the place that we're in
facilitates that movement,
then we're happy to be there.
And if the place that we're in serves as
an obstacle to that movement,
then we're unhappy to be there.
And so what it means to set up your room
is that you have to have somewhere to go
that's worthwhile,
or you can set up your room and your
room has to be set up to facilitate
that.
And then the next thing is,
well,
maybe you have to make it beautiful,
but that's not easy,
right?
That means you have to have some taste
and that doesn't mean you have to have
money.
It doesn't,
because you can be garish with money and
you can be tasteful with nothing.
All you need is taste and taste beats
money when it comes to beautifying
things.
Not that money is trivial because it's
not.
But taste is crucial and people who are
very artistically oriented can make
beautiful things out of virtually
nothing.
And not only that,
the literature suggests that if you're
going to make beautiful things,
putting real constraints on,
on what you allow yourself to do,
facilitates creativity instead of
interfering with it.
Because let's say you have to make
something out of nothing,
right?
Which I suppose would be a Godly Act,
You have to make something out of
nothing.
You have to be creative in order to do
that,
and so then to beautify your room means
that you also have to develop your
capacity to be creative and so then you
can make your room shine,
but then what will happen is that if
your family isn't together,
they will interfere with that.
You will interfere with that because you
won't have the discipline to do it
properly,
but then when you start building this,
this,
this little microcosm of perfection with
what you have at hand and it'll evoke
all the pathologies of everyone in your
household.
The wonder what the hell you're up to in
there and they won't necessarily be
happy because if you're.
If they're in a lowly place,
let's say and so are you and you're
trying to move out of that,
then the higher you move out of that,
the more the place they're in looks bad
and you might say,
well,
what they should do is celebrate your
victory over chaos and evil,
but that isn't what will happen.
What will happen instead is that they
will attempt to pull you back down.
They'll attempt to.
I mean obviously all families don't do
that,
but,
but all families do that to some degree
and some families do almost nothing but
that.
And so what that means is that if you're
going to organize your room,
then you're going to have to confront
the devils in your house and that's
often.
That's often a terrifying thing because
some of those devils have have lineages
that go back many,
many,
many generations and God only knows what
you have to struggle with in order to
overcome that.
And so and then and so to sort yourself
out into fix up your room is a
nontrivial matter.
You know,
and you can do that.
You'll learn by doing that and then
maybe you'll learn enough by doing that
so that you can fix up your family a
little bit.
And then having done that,
you'll have enough character so that
when you try to operate in the world at
your job or maybe in the broader social
spheres,
that you'll be a force for good instead
of harm.
Because you will have learned some
humility by noting just how difficult it
was to put your damn room together well
and yourself for that matter,
and so you'll proceed cautiously with
your eyes open towards the good.
I talked to people very frequently whose
families have them with too much
protection and they know it themselves
and that means they're deprived of
necessity.
You know,
one of the things that you see in the
United States,
for example,
is that
the children are first generation
immigrants often do better than the than
the than their children.
And the reason for that is that the
children are first generation
immigrants,
have necessity driving them and you
don't know how much you need necessity
to drive you because maybe you're not
very disciplined.
And if an a catastrophe doesn't
immediately befall you.
If you don't act forthrightly today,
then maybe you'll never act
forthrightly,
right?
Because the gap between your foolishness
and the punishment is,
is lengthened by your unearned wealth.
And so you never grow up and learn and
you have to get yourself away from your
dependency in order to allow necessity
to drive you forward.
And that's to become independent and to
become mature.
And I think part of what's happening in
our culture is that the,
the,
the force that's attacking the
forthright movement forward of young men
in particular is afraid of the power of
man because it's confused about the
distinction between power and authority
and competence.
Like I know a man who's who has
authority and competence has power as a
byproduct,
but the authority and competence is
everything.
And,
and,
and people who can't understand that
fail to make the distinction between
power and authority of competence and
they're afraid of power and so they
destroy authority and competence.
And that's a terrible thing because we
need authority and competence.
What else is going to,
what else is going to allow us to
prevail in the long run?
And so you get away from your country
and you get away from your kin and from
your father's house,
right?
And you go out there and you establish
yourself in the world.
It's a call to adventure.
That's what this,
the first lines in the Abrahamic story
is a call to adventure.
So great unto a land that I will show
you.
Well,
you know,
what does that mean?
You know,
one of the things that
I've been struck very hard by a number
of writers,
Carl Young,
obviously among them,
I mean he,
he wrote things like Nicha that if you
understand them,
they just break you into pieces you
know,
and one of the things that you and
understood in the psychoanalysts
understand,
it's one of the most terrifying elements
of psychoanalytic thinking is very
tightly aligned with religious thinking,
which is that you are not the master of
your own house.
There are spirits that dwelling within
you,
meaning you have a will and you can
exercise a certain amount of conscious
control over your being,
but there are all sorts of things that
occur within you that seemed to be
beyond your capacity to control your
dreams.
For example.
That's a really good example of your
impulses.
For example,
you might,
you might think of those as so foreign
from you that they're not even.
You don't even want them to be part of,
but,
but more subtly even.
How about what you're interested in?
What compels you like where does that
come from?
Exactly?
Because you can't,
you can't conjure it up of your own
accord,
you know,
so if you're a student and you're taking
difficult course,
you might say to yourself,
well,
I need to sit down and study for three
hours,
but then you sit down and that is what
happens.
Your attention goes everywhere and you
might say,
well,
whose attention is it?
Then?
If it goes everywhere because you say
it's your attention,
it's like,
well,
if it's your attention,
maybe you'd be able to control it,
but you can't.
And so then you might think,
well jen and just exactly what the hell
is controlling it.
And you might say,
well,
it's random.
It's better not be random.
I can tell you that that's,
that happens to some degree in
schizophrenia.
There's an element of randomness in
that.
It's not random.
It's driven by the action of phenomena
that I think are best considered as
something like subpersonalities or
they'll even.
That's only a partial description.
You can't make yourself interested in
something.
Interest manifests itself in grips you.
That's a whole different thing.
And so what is it that's gripping you
and how do you conceptualize that?
Is that a divine power?
Well,
it's divine as far as your concerned
because it grips you and you can't do
anything about it.
And so there's a calling in you towards
what you're compelled by and what you're
interested in,
and sometimes that might be very dark
and sometimes not,
but you're compelled forward by your
interest.
And so
and so the idea that what moves you away
from your country and your father's
house and the comforts of your childhood
home is,
is something that's beyond you and that
you listened to in Harken to.
That's exactly right.
And you can say,
well,
I don't want to call it that God.
It's like it doesn't matter what you
call it.
Exactly.
It doesn't matter to what it is,
what it's called.
It still is.
And if you don't listen to it,
that's the other thing.
If you don't listen to it,
and I've been a clinician and talked to
enough people now as old as I am to know
this.
Absolutely.
If you do not listen to that thing that
beckons you forward,
you will pay for it like you cannot
possibly imagine.
You'll have everything that's terrible
about life in your life and nothing
about it that's good and worse.
You'll know that it was your fault and
that you squandered what you could have
had.
So this is not only a calling forth,
but a warning unto a land that I will
show thee and that's it.
That I will show the that and you don't
want to be too concrete about this.
You know,
there's all sorts of new territories
that you can inhabit.
If you abstract and conceptual
territories of Gilda University and you
study biology or you study physics or,
or any discipline,
you're in a territory,
right?
You're in the territory that all of the
scholars have established and then as
you master the discipline,
you move out beyond the established
territory,
into the unknown.
And that's a new right.
Maybe it's even a land of your enemies
for that matter,
but it's a new land to the frontier is
always in front of you.
And so you know,
when they earth was less inhabited than
it is now,
the frontier was the psychological
frontier and the geographical frontier
was the same thing and now they've
separated to some degree because there's
not so much geographical frontier,
but there's the frontier is a place that
never disappears and the land that's
beyond the land that you know is always
there.
And it's always where you should go.
And all of that packed into these four
phrases so
well.
So when I've been thinking about
narrative,
you look at the world through a story,
you can't,
you can't help it.
And this story is what gives value to
the world or or the stories.
What you extract from the value of the
world.
You can look at it either way,
you're somewhere and it's not good
enough,
right?
That's the eternal human predicament.
Wherever you are,
isn't good enough.
And to some degree that's actually a
good thing because if it was good
enough,
well there's nothing for you to do.
So it's actually maybe a good thing that
it's insufficient.
And that might be why sometimes having
less is is better than having more.
And I don't want to be a pollyanna about
that.
I mean,
I know that there's deprivation that can
reach to the point where it's no where
it's completely counterproductive,
but it isn't always the case that
starting with little is you.
If you start with little,
you start with more possibility.
It's something like that.
So you moved from always from what's
unbearable about the present to some
better future.
Right?
And if you don't have that,
then you have no,
you have nothing but threat and negative
emotion.
You have no positive emotion because the
positive emotion is generated in the
conception of the better future.
And then the evidence that you generate
yourself,
that you're moving towards it.
That's where the positive and fulfilling
meaning of life comes.
So you want to set up this structure
properly.
It's very,
very important.
And so what it means is that you want to
be going somewhere that's good enough so
that the going is worth the while and
you can ask yourself that.
And that's partly what we tried to build
into the future authoring program,
which is,
well,
we know what's wrong with life.
It's rife with suffering and
insufficiency and deception and evil.
It's all of that obviously.
Okay.
What would make the journey worthwhile?
Well,
you can ask yourself that.
It's like,
alright,
right.
In order to bear up under this load,
what is it that I would need to be
striving to attain?
And if you ask yourself that,
that's to knock and the door will open.
That's what that means.
If you ask yourself that,
then you will find an answer and you'll
think you'll shrink away from it.
You'll think,
well,
there's no way I could do that.
It's like,
well,
you don't know what you could do.
You don't know what's possible and
you're not as much as you could be,
and so god only knows what you could,
what you could do and have and give if
you sacrificed everything to it.
And that's the reason that Abraham is
constantly making sacrifices.
It's archaic,
right?
He's burning up like baby,
but like,
well,
they're alive.
You know that's something and they're
valuable and that's something it's you
have to admit,
even if you think about it as a modern
person,
that the act of sacrificing something
might have some dramatic compulsion to
it,
you know,
to go out into a flock and to take
something that's new board and to cut
its throat into bleed it into burn.
It might be a way of indicating to
yourself that you're actually serious
about something and it isn't so obvious
that we have rituals of seriousness like
that now and so it's not so obvious that
we're actually serious about anything
and so maybe that's not such a good
thing and so maybe we shouldn't be
thinking that these people were so
archaic and primitive and superstitious.
It's possible that they knew something
that we don't.
It's certainly in the abrahamic stories.
One of the things that maintains
Abraham's covenant with God is his
continual willingness to sacrifice it.
It's so that sacrificial issue is so
important because you are not committed
to something unless you're willing to
sacrifice for it.
Commitment and sacrifice are the same
thing and I think its borders on
miraculous that those concepts are
embedded into this narrative at the
level of dramatic action.
You know,
instead of abstract explanation,
people are acting this out and the
fundamental conception is so profound
that it's really quite.
It's quite inspiring and it's
breathtaking.
Really,
when you understand what message is
trying to be conveyed,
you have to make sacrifices and what do
you have to sacrifice.
You have to sacrifice that which is most
valuable to you currently that stopping
you and God only knows what that is.
It's certainly the worst of you.
It's certainly that and god only knows
to what degree you're in love with the
worst of you so
well,
so you moved from the unbearable
president to the ideal future and and
you can't help that.
You have to live in a structure like
that.
That's your house.
That's another way of thinking about it
and if you want to get your house in
order and if you want it to be a place
that you can live properly,
then you have to plan the future.
That is perfect.
And then I think,
well,
what does that mean?
It means it's good for you.
Right?
And one of the things that I,
I'm,
I do all the time with my clinical and
consulting clients is trying to figure
out what would be good for them,
but we do more than that.
We try to think,
okay,
well what,
how can we set this up so it's really
good for you?
And that all the consequences of that
are things that are good for other
people.
And so because people are often also
timid about trying to get something
that's good for themselves because they
feel that it's selfish or that they
don't deserve it.
So we set it up so that.
Well look,
we're going to set it up so that it's
plainly obvious that this will not harm
the structure of the universe for you to
have what you need and to do it in a way
that's of benefit to other people.
There's no downside,
right?
So let's say you have oriented yourself
but not perfectly because you're full of
and errors.
So then what do you do?
Because you have to fix those errors.
But you still have to be oriented.
This is why I started getting interested
to get interested in the phenomenon of
meaning as a,
as a phenomenological experience to
experience something as meaningful.
It's not exactly obvious what that means
to experience something as meaningful.
I think that you can,
you can approach it obliquely,
you know,
like if I said,
watch yourself for two weeks and notice
when you're doing something that you
regard as meaningful,
I could say,
well here,
here's some,
here's some markers.
You lose a sense of time.
You lose a sense of vulnerability.
You're deeply engaged in it.
It seems,
it seems worth the effort,
right?
You forget yourself while you're doing
it.
Maybe you forget your existential
concerns while you're doing it.
You're not
ruminating or obsessing about the
meaning of your life.
Right?
So,
so there's markers for,
it's like the flow states that chicks at
my highly described.
Um,
and then you can experience it.
You experienced it under a certain sort
of ritualistic conditions.
You might experience it when you go see
a great movie,
you might experience it when you listen
to music.
I think music is a very,
very standard pathway for people to have
that kind of experience because
virtually everyone gets intimations of
mute of meaning from music and I think
music music is hierarchically structured
patterns that are representative of
being laying itself out properly.
It's something like that,
so it's an abstract representation of
proper being and so we can.
We can grapple with the phenomena of
music and we can.
We can bark or phenomenon meaning we can
box it in a little bit and start to
conceptualize it.
W
we can start to conceptualize it perhaps
as the manifestation of a deep instinct
and so I would say well meaning is what
manifests itself when you are,
when you've oriented yourself properly
and when you've optimized the flow of
information between you and you,
between you and chaos.
That might be the right way of thinking
about it because literally you think
about a piece of music because you want
it to be predictable,
but you don't want it to be perfectly
predictable.
You want it to be predictable with some
interesting variations and predictable
with some variations that make sense and
maybe you can conceptualize that as
something like this.
It's like it's predictable at this order
of of stability,
but it's varying down here from time to
time and so you've got stable stability
there,
but variability there and you can handle
that so you want
an overarching structure stability with
some internal variability and maybe
that's the way that you update yourself
without falling apart,
and then I would say you can find the
pathway to the optimal rate of update by
relying on your sense of meaning.
That's what it's for.
What it tells you is that you're.
You're wandering you're way through the
world between the catastrophes of chaos
in the catastrophes of order and now and
then you swing into the proper locale.
You're,
you're where you should be,
and what happens is you get engaged by
that.
You get meaningfully engaged by that and
it's fragile.
It'll move on you,
right?
Because it's very difficult to exist at
that point constantly.
Your bad habits,
all sorts of things,
your situation.
There's all sorts of things that are
going to interfere with that,
but that doesn't mean that that isn't
where you should be,
and so then you might say,
well,
that's where you should strive to be all
the time,
and then the question might be,
well,
what would it be like if you were there
all the time and I think that's where
intimations of paradise come from being
when words think it was words.
Wordsworth talked about intimations of
immortality and childhood.
People tend to romanticize their
childhood because of the sense of
intense engagement that goes along with
being a child and it's one of the
wonderful things about being around
children.
Actually.
It's,
it's,
it's why they pay you for their care and
the way that children pay you for their
care is that they turn normal things
into magic again when you're around them
because you've seen it 100 times before.
And so when you see it,
you don't see it.
You see what you already know.
But when a child sees that they don't
because they don't know,
they see it.
And then when you watch them see it,
you see it too.
And so it's just,
it's tremendous fun leading a small
child around to do things that you've
done before because they're so,
you know,
they're like this,
they're like all the time and you know,
maybe that's too much.
Then they cry and they get upset and all
of that,
but a good part of the time it's just
wild eyed wonder and then you can see
the world through their eyes and it's
payment.
And so that's that sense of being
engaged.
Like that is something that people love
about children and rightly so,
but it's also a marker to the proper way
of being.
You know,
there there's a dictum in the.
This is a union idea that there's no
difference between the archetype of the
wise old man in the archetype of the
child.
They're the same thing because the wise
old man is the person who found what he
had in childhood but lost.
Right?
It's a.
that's a very powerful moment.
Tif is that the purpose of maturation is
to return to this state of childhood as
a mature being,
not to stay in the state of childhood,
that's Peter Pan,
but to make the sacrifices necessary for
maturation and then return so well.
How do you do that?
Well,
you do that in part by noticing what it
is that's meaningful for you to engage
in.
I would say it's your nervous system
reporting to you,
right hemisphere and left hemisphere
balanced.
The balance between chaos and order
produces an output that says you are in
the right place.
It's a perception.
The meaning is a perception of being in
the right place.
It's the genuine thing.
However,
because it can be pathologized.
That's the thing and that's why I think
there's a call to virtue in most great
religious traditions.
If you're going to rely on your sense of
meaning to Orient you,
you have to play a straight game because
otherwise you warp and twist the inputs
and then the mechanism won't function
properly.
You know?
It's like if you.
If you were only.
If you're,
if you blinded yourself to half the
world,
you can't use your perception story at
yourself properly because the half of
the world that you ignoring is going to
pop up at you unexpectedly and take you
down,
and so if your relationship with the
world isn't pristine,
honest,
primarily,
then you can't rely on your own internal
orienting mechanisms and then you either
fall into chaos which is an absolute
catastrophe or you have to rely on some
kind of external authority and that
makes you prone to possession by
tyrannical etiologies,
for example,
which give you that sense of meaning
that you should in fact have as a
consequence of your own action.
What should you be aiming for in your
life?
I can.
I can tell you that roughly speaking,
if you're looking for something that
will give your life meaning,
that's,
that's.
That's actually quite straightforward as
far as I'm thinking in detail.
This is where the nihilists happened so
wrong that it's almost unbelievable as
far as I'm concerned.
Fundamentally,
they're just escaping from
responsibility anyways.
Even though they are perfectly rational
arguments for their nihilism.
Everything's meaningless.
It's like,
no.
First of all,
no pain.
It's not meaningless.
You never going to meet anyone who will
tell you that their pain is meaningless
so we can forego the whole meeting was
right off the bat.
There may be no positive because yes,
we can have a discussion about that,
but south the negative meaning exists
and everyone knows even someone who's in
Archicad,
nihilistic to the core drug,
a spike through their hand,
they're going to act like that has
meaning and since I'm not an existential
and look at how people are instead of
what they say and they'll act out the
idea that that has meaning very,
very rapid,
so we'll just go with that.
Now you might say,
well,
there's all sorts of,
but that's not the kind of meaning that
I believe doesn't exist.
I believe that only positive meaning
doesn't exist,
which is a little on the negative side,
I would say at the beginning,
but I can understand it.
People have.
People can have pretty dreadful lights,
you know,
and you can easily get yourself into a
situation where it seems like there's
nothing at all to your life.
Accept suffering.
And that's what happens to people who
become suicidal,
for example,
and it's no joke and they have the
reasons.
Now you know sometimes those people have
been hurt in ways that are absolutely
unimaginable and so when they see a
horizon that's full of nothing but
suffering,
you can't just wave that away,
but I would say
the first thing we might hypothesize is
that pain is an unalterable fact of
meeting and certainly seems to be
negative,
but one of the things you might want to
try to orient yourself in relationship
to is the reduction of human suffering.
Now,
because I think that's you know the
answer,
what you do about a child who's
suffering in a concentration camp is it
who the hell is going to care the
billion ears,
right?
That's not the right answer.
And if it's not the right answer in that
situation that perhaps it's not the
right answer at all and the right answer
to who the hell is going to care anyways
in a million years is why the world
would you frame in state that
idiotically mean anybody,
anybody?
This has kind of a trick of the
imagination in some sense of anybody
who's quick witted can come up with a
frame of reference that makes anything
that makes almost anything,
lack meaning within that frame of
reference.
What all that means to me is that you
pick the stupid frequent reference,
right?
Why should you?
Except without doubt,
the consequence of your stupid
algorithm.
Who's going to care in a million years?
Yeah,
God,
really,
you got to be able to do better than
that.
If that's what you're going to wipe
meaning.
Well,
so what do you want for meaning?
All right,
reduce suffering.
That'd be a good one.
You could devote your life to that and I
would say start locally and,
and,
and I think this is the alternative to
rightly nationalism and which is too
much order and left wing the chaos,
which is too much chaos.
We don't want to go down that rabbit
hole again,
either of it.
So what's the alternative?
I thought about this for a very long
time.
It took me decades to come to this
conclusion.
The conclusion is just that you
straightened yourself out and you do
that humbling.
Here's this idea that the new testament,
which I get quite a kick out of,
that you're not supposed to pray in
public and a little more complicated
than that.
Actually.
You're not supposed to frame the problem
until you sorta out the dispute that you
have with your brother.
For example.
I really like that idea because what it
means is that you shouldn't make a
public display of your virtue until
you've straightened up your damn life,
and this is one of the things I really
liked about protests and I really don't
like the fact that university students
are taught by their pathway and
professors.
That the way that you change your world.
Thank you.
You don't change the world by going and
waving signs that people that you've
defined as more equal than,
but first of all probability that
they're more useful than you is actually
quite low
because he up may be you're in the same
damn boat and if you've divided the
world up conveniently so that you can
identify the innocence and the and the
dam or the oppressor and the oppressed,
and you think that if you're in the
positive category,
then the probability that you're part of
the solution and not part of the problem
is zero.
So it's just not that easy.
Know I'm the most profound people that
don't have you said the same thing over
and over.
It's like the line between good and evil
runs down the middle of every human
heart and the first thing that you're
supposed to do is win that battle on
your own territory,
and that's no bloody joke.
That's a difficult thing to do because
it means that you have to recognize
that.
Recognize yourself as a of gravy and
that is what you are and that's a
terrible thing for me to learn.
You know,
when you look at the 20th century and
you think,
well,
who brought on the horrors of the
cognitive systems and the horrors of the
Nazi system is the answer is people just
like you.
That's the answer.
If you don't understand that and you
think that answer is wrong,
then you're not very wise and the and
it's not surprising because the price
that you paid for wisdom,
this is radical disillusion,
disillusion lip and the confrontation
with England and no one wants that.
Really.
It's a terrible thing to confront and
that's because human beings are terrible
creatures.
Now.
I think we're also absolutely remarkable
creatures and wonderful creatures.
We have an unlimited capacity for
brutality and evil and every one of us
carries it,
and so what you do is you try to sort
that out in your own life and you start.
I haven't gotten to talk to me just a
while back about about his life.
Haven't been going very well.
He decided to put himself together and
he started doing this little ritual
thing,
which I thought was quite cool.
He was kind of an isolated guy,
very overweight guy.
When I talk to him,
he lost about 130 pounds,
which was quite impressive for this part
of the putting himself together,
but he started doing it by bill.
He had a bunch of labels leftover from
his childhood and the first thing he
did,
because he was feeling very nihilistic
and hopeless,
he,
he found that he got a little bit of
satisfaction out of building little
things,
other labels,
you know,
and I thought,
well that was pretty interesting.
And so he built a bunch of these things
and then he said,
well,
I got a bunch of these things built.
Then I had to figure out how to organize
them in the room angry.
I thought that's cool because he started
higher resolution at the level of
detail.
You know,
what it was building something that was
trivial.
He knew that he was just playing the
game,
but then as soon as he had a collection
of those,
then you have to sort out the space that
he was going to organize them in many
figured out under sort of the room that
they were going to be.
So we started organizing and beautifying
the room and at the same time he
modified his diet and he was putting
himself together.
That's the right thing to do.
That's the right thing to do is that
there is,
there are responsibilities that are
awaiting you,
right that are in your own grass and you
know what they are.
And this is also something that no one
can preach to you about.
It's something you have to decide for
yourself and you can do it quite
straightforwardly.
It's something that I do on a regular
basis.
You sit down the anything or in the
morning and ask yourself like you're
asking someone that you want the answer
from like really genuinely needed to
have the chicken.
Not telling yourself none of that.
You're asking yourself,
right?
There's a bunch of things about my life
that are in an order that aren't
together and I know it and they're
making me suffer and they're making me
less than I am.
And there's some of those things that
are staring me right at the face and I
know what they are.
And there are some of those that I can
put in order today with a little bit of
work so that when I wake up tomorrow,
the domain of my experience,
which is basically being itself,
that the main,
my experience will be more pristine and
better put together than it is today.
And you asked yourself that,
you will find that right away.
You know what they are finding things
that come up,
Bang,
and they'll all be things that aren't
very heroic.
They're kind of trivial and that you
knew the voiding you've been avoiding
me.
Those are little dragons of chaos.
They space and you know they're just
little.
That's good because you're not much of a
hero warrior.
And so maybe a little tiny dragons are
all the ones that you've been put up.
You know,
you sort those things out and they will.
First of all,
they will order.
You're in an order that being around you
in a more pristine and productive way.
I think you just a little bit more
focused in together.
And what that'll mean is that the next
thing you can do is ask yourself the
same question and the end of the
problems that will emerge will be
slightly larger and more complex,
and then you can try to put those in
order and that will make everything
around you more pristine and benefit
together and it'll make you a little bit
stronger and more clear habit.
And then another set of problems will
emerge that's a little bit larger.
If you continue to do that,
you know you'll sort yourself out,
you clean up your room and you put your
house in order and then you could start
to work in the community and by that
time you'll actually have some power and
some and some self confidence and some
competence and some cream cheese and
you'll be much more,
much less likely to stupidly hit
something complicated with a stick and
say that you fixed it,
but you have to start low.
You have to be Carl Jung said,
very an interesting one,
interesting phrases.
He says that the reason that monitor
people can't see this because they won't
look low enough.
I really liked that.
I mean,
he's an extraordinarily wise person.
What he meant by that was something like
what I'm telling you is that the secret
to your existence is right in front of
you and it manifests itself as all those
things you know you should do,
but you're avoiding because one of the
things you might ask yourself as a
curse,
you're useless and weak and miserable
and cruel than all of those horrible
things,
but partly that's because you're also
not what you could be in.
Part of the reason for that is that what
you know you shouldn't be doing.
So you might ask yourself,
because this is a very interesting game.
If you started doing the things that you
know you should do,
this is a discussion with your own
conscious.
If you started doing those things that
you know you should do and you did that
diligently,
what beheld would you be like in 10
years?
Now?
That's an exciting game.
That's an interesting game and if you
play that,
we will find that you're hell a lot more
than you were and that's something at
least you might not hit the pinnacles
that you're going to be a lot more than
you are,
and then if you're not and miserable or
direction in sovereign digital,
sound,
pitying and all those things,
you're going to be a lot less resentful.
You're going to be a lot less broom.
You're going to be a lot less cruel to
yourself and to other people.
Well,
that's a pretty good start.
You know?
Even if you're not a positive force for
good in the world,
if you just were wretched horrible,
that would be a good additional
contribution.
No,
you.
I would say too,
there's a corridor that goes along with
that
and I,
and this is so,
so you could look at it this way.
This is something that I tried to
explain.
I didn't video on a couple of videos
which I've been fascinated by because
it's a very good relation and cultural.
How architects manifest themselves and
how people understand the earth.
Even if they don't know,
they understand them because it gives a
very interesting movie and think about
it,
don't you?
You might ask.
Well,
with modern people,
think about people going to church.
They think,
how can people believe those foolish,
those superstitions.
Fair enough.
Well,
what the hell do you think you're doing
when you were moving?
What are you doing here?
Here you are.
You're family.
You probably haven't seen Nokia lately,
but whatever
you're an adult,
you bring your five year old to seem to
know you're just as interest as he is
and think about what you're doing.
First of all,
you know those are drawings.
They're not real creatures.
There draws second pot wouldn't pop up.
Who actually happens to wander around
who is being guided to life.
Quite cricket was highest goal is to for
recent snow onto and understand and
somehow that makes a fairy tournament to
something that's real.
It's like that's strange people.
The fact that you're doing that is very
peculiar and it says something about
what people are like means that we
understand the things that we don't
normally understand and so it's.
It's a very interesting movie.
I can tell you what it's fundamental
presupposition is I'll just guide you
through it very,
very rapidly.
So the beginning of the movie,
Japan,
who's,
uh,
the archetype of the good father,
by the way,
which is an archetype that we forgot
about us because our culture isn't just
a tyrannical patriarchy as you can tell
by the fact that farm and comfortable
and we're not tearing each other to
shreds at the moment,
which is what you do in a state of
absolute chaos,
right?
It's made him on.
You're freezing and starving,
right?
And that is what one have.
We have a piece and it's rare and it's
amazing that we have,
we shouldn't take it for granted because
it's not the normal order of things.
The normal order of things is
destructive chaos.
And if you're fortunate enough to live
somewhere that's peaceful,
productive,
you should thank your lucky stars every
second of your life.
And if you don't do that,
all that means is that you don't know
anything about history and you know
nothing about human beings because
things can get out smoothly,
monster.
And it happens all the time and there's
always a fraction of the population who
thinks that's how they like things to be
and perhaps there's a fraction of you
have.
It's like that too.
And I wouldn't nurture that fragment
pharmacy you unless you want to go.
We're equal taking.
Anyways,
back to
thank you,
and then you can tell that he's got a
warm house and it's full of toys and
it's full of music boxes and the
goldfish.
He takes care of them and so it's a good
guy.
It makes this pop and then he puts us on
the puppet and that's the final act and
the public can have its capacity to
speak.
And that's what you want.
If you're a good father because you want
to take your son and turn them into
someone who can speak right,
who can speak his soul and soldier
battle,
puts a smile on his son space and says,
wouldn't it be wonderful if he could be
a good boy sweater?
Yeah.
Wouldn't it be wonderful,
right?
Because that's what you're doing.
You're a good father.
You think,
wouldn't it be possible that this puppet
could actually become something genuine
and independent with its own voice?
While he says that sounds likely it goes
off to bed and then the star appears up
in the window and the wishes on the scar
and you think,
what does that mean?
What does it mean to wish on a star?
It's like,
well,
the star is that light that gets into
the darkness,
right,
and it's something transcendent.
You go show up into the night sky and
it's.
It's odd inspiring whether you're
religious or not.
You're looking into the incident while
you make a relationship with the
infinite.
By wishing on a star,
you raise your eyes above the horizon
and point at the light that shines in
the darkness
and you say,
I wish more than anything else that my
son can become a real person.
So that's what you do.
If you're a good for the water may come
into a slave.
You don't want to be a tyrant.
You don't want them to be a puppet.
You want them to be something as strong
and independent.
Also,
Pinocchio goes out into the world.
He faces all these different moral
problems.
He's armed with his conscience.
It turns up to the other bug,
right?
Well,
why?
it's because things bug you.
You know you're conscious bugs you and
the reason that the conscience is
jimminy cricket is because that's the
same initials as Jesus Christ and
Jimminy cricket is southern US slime for
Jesus Christ and no doubt the other
mangers thought that was very comical.
I'm not telling you that that is a very
strange representation of Christ.
That's for sure.
It would make it into a cricketer and he
is also rather error prone in the movie
because the movie doesn't have besides
the affordable Christian structure.
But part of the reason this took me a
long time to figure out too is that you
have to have a dialogue with your
conscience,
but it has to be a dog because it's
actually not 100 percent right.
It has to be something that you build by
having a discussion with it across time.
And that's actually where Pinocchio,
junior cricket,
as the movie progresses,
both the puppet and the conscience get
wiser by begging themselves against the
world.
And the pop and house to resist the
temptation of Isi,
fame and celebrity.
That's the first temptation,
right?
Because he's asked to be an actor,
which is an easy way to be celebrities
like the Kardashians,
right?
It's it's status without responsibility
or or competence and so that that exists
and the traffic and then he's,
he's.
He learns that lying is a very bad idea,
right?
That's what he's knows.
Grocery has to get that sort of know.
And then he said he's asked to present
himself as a victim of circumstances.
That's what the Fox and the coyotes and
when he decides that he's too ill to go
back to school,
they take them to pleasure.
It varies trained to be a jackass that
works for slavers into soul lines.
Right?
Not Bad for animation,
I could say.
And then at the end of it,
the leaky tries to go back home because
he's terribly lost in these half.
Jack asked because the people that
pleasure island have told him,
taught him to do nothing but break,
which I can't help it
offers or what would you.
What would you say is,
is an appalling parallel to what's
happening to educate people who are
being educated in modern universities,
which are increasingly play houses where
you're taught to break in the listen,
I can't listen to the protesters.
It just,
it just.
It's just painful.
It's this constant repetition of a soul.
Nonsense thank loudly chanted is because
the protesters,
they're trying to convince themselves
even more desperately than they're
trying to convince them.
So anyways,
Pinocchio goes back home and half
jackass in half again and trust to find
his father.
There's no going home right now.
Once you're an adult,
it's your young adult.
You don't get to go back because there
isn't anyone there that can tell you
what to do anymore,
and so they go as far as fair and finds
out that he has to go to the bottom of
chaos itself to rescue his father and
that's what we have to do,
right?
Because our civilization is in a state
of crisis now is predicted long ago by
people like Dj.
And partly what you're trying to do with
you go to university is to go to the
heart of therapist right to the place
that terrifies you the most,
and to find your values,
your culture really has,
and that's what it means to go down to
the bottom of the desk to the thing that
terrifies you the most integrative
before your father to very little story.
The Egyptians were telling that story
for a thousand years ago.
It's one of the oldest stories of
mankind,
and so that's what you have to do.
You and the United Yourself with your
culture so that you're more than just a
weakened symbol minded individual,
right?
You dedicate yourself to the study of
what's great about the past and you
incorporate it so that there can be
something to you and then you bring your
father back up to the surface so that
the culture can see and live in yet,
and then that makes you into a real
individual.
Well,
that's the movie.
we watch it were captivated by it.
Now it's time to understand.
It takes time to understand that in an
articulated and conscious map because
it's too late for us to be unconscious
anymore.
And so we have stella and shrimp,
this,
we have the chaos of the left and the
left says,
well we need to tear down structures
because they own press.
So like obviously instructors who
oppressed because something's good at
the top of the structure and also good
at the bottom.
So if you have any values dropped,
it's going to privilege some things and
exclude others,
but if you scrap structures and there's
nothing to live for,
so we can't do that.
That's just chaos.
And then the radical right says back to
the nation and it's like really?
You know,
we went back to the nation a couple of
times so it doesn't really look that
great.
And part of the reason for that is that
the purpose of the nation isn't the
nation.
The purpose of the nation is to produce
citizens who transcend Emma juvenate,
the nation.
And so the nation should be probably
properly subordinated to the individual,
right to the divine individually for
that map.
And that's what we figured out in the
West.
Now it is that we only figured that out
in the west,
but so far we've been fortunate enough
to put it into a reasonable practice in
our political institutions and thank God
for that.
At least it's worked somewhere and we'd
be completely foolish to give that up
because look at what it's provided us
with.
Its remarkable for free,
as free as we can,
but that doesn't mean that we're happy
because freedom and happiness are not
the same thing at all.
But we did figure out what the state
should be subordinate to the wisdom of
the individual,
to the site and the wisdom of the
individual that puts a heavy
responsibility on everyone.
That mean to you have to be the
individual who can see at speed.
That's your job.
And if you do that,
the thing that's so cool about that is
you know you need a meaning in your life
that enables you to bear the suffering
of their life without becoming
corrupted.
That's the basic rule and you have to
build yourself into something that you
can actually respect so that you can see
yourself bearing not terrible
existential burger properly and then you
don't lose hope and you don't use
meaning because you can see that you're
strong enough to stand up underneath
that Burger and then there's something
about you that you can respect and then
maybe other people can respect that will
help bring suffering in the world to an
end and that will help people develop
fully as individuals and that will
enable us to avoid the dehumanizing
rigid.
A I'll uniformity of the nationalistic
lack and appalling devouring chaos of
the radical left.
How about no
the individual
that's the secret to the world and
you're all individuals.
You're all the secret to the world and
then all you have to do
to discover that is picked up
responsibility.
Stop listening to people who keep
burdening you with rights.
How many Goddamn rights deal?
Why you need some responsibility?
So pick it up,
open your eyes and learn how to make
yourself articulate,
and that made the world one sentence of
a series of health than it already
descended into the 20th century.
You've think detailed what you think
students shouldn't do in these examples
of like protests and these examples of
certain types of activist tactics.
What advice would you have for students?
How can students make the changes that
they want to make?
Particularly?
Do you have any advice for students
here?
Yeah.
Read great books.
Really,
man,
you've got this four year period that
has been carved out of your lives by
society.
They given you an identity,
like a high quality identity and freedom
at the same time and you're not going to
get that again in your life.
You've got a.
you've got a respectable identity,
university student and complete freedom
associated with that or as near as
you're ever going to get and you've got
these unbelievable libraries that are
full of the writings of people who are,
who are intelligent and articulate
beyond comprehension and you know,
and and you can go there and you can
learn all this and you might think,
well,
why should you learn it while you learn
it to get a job?
Or you learn it to get good grades or
you learn it to get a degree and that's
all nonsense.
It's nonsense.
The reason that you come to university
to be educated is because there is
nothing more powerful than someone who
is articulate and who can think and
speak.
It's power and power of the best,
sort of its authority and influence and
respectability and competence.
And so you come to university to craft
your highest skill and your highest
skill is to be found in articulated
speech.
And if you're,
if you're,
if you're a master at formulating your
arguments,
you win everything and better than that,
when you win everything,
everyone around you wins too.
Because to transform yourself into,
let's consider,
consider your transformation into
something approximating the logos.
It means you shine a light on the whole
world.
Well,
there's nothing more exciting to do than
that.
There's nothing better you can possibly
do.
And to think that you're going to
university to be trained to have a job,
it's like great.
That's a hell of a lot better than being
unemployed and covered with cheeto dust
while you're snacking away in front of
your video game in the basement,
but it's not.
It's not a.
and I don't have anything against video
games by the way,
but it's hardly a triumphant call to,
to being in the world.
And that's what universities should be
calling forth.
It's like God,
you people,
you as you know I,
I know what Harvard students are like.
I taught here for five years.
You people are spectacular.
You're spectacular.
You're,
you're,
you're all capable of being world
beaters.
You transform yourself into something
that's articulated and sensible and
grounded in history and knowledgeable
and wise man,
you can do anything you want and
hopefully anything you want for good
because if you have any sense,
everything you want to do would be for
the good because there's nothing more
compelling or meaningful or or useful in
combating the tragedy of life than to
than to struggle with all your soul on
behalf of the good and the university
hasn't forgotten that.
It's why everyone's bailing out of the
humanities and they should.
The humanities are corrupt and they're
corrupt because they're not telling the
students this.
It's so bloody obvious.
So like learn to think,
learn to speak,
let to read.
It makes you a super power and the
individual superpower you have it under.
I don't understand why that isn't just
told to students.
It's not that hard to understand and
everyone wants to hear it.
It's like,
really?
I could do that.
I can do that.
It's like,
yeah,
really you could do that,
and the whole society around you is
labored for really thousands of years to
provide every single one of you with
this spectacular opportunity that you
have while your undergraduates and
graduate students here.
Man,
they're just.
Everyone's just praying that you would
come here and manifest everything that
you could manifest and that's what you
should be doing.
Instead of waving placards and
complaining about how you're oppressed
for God's sake,
you see these Yale students complaining
about their oppression.
It's just,
it just leaves me aghast and it's like,
well,
we're against the ruling class.
It's like,
no,
no.
Your baby ruling class members.
You're young.
Thank you.
The only reason you're not rich just
because you're young,
you know that's the best.
Really.
That's the.
If you look at the one percent,
even the dreaded one percent,
you know,
most of those people are old.
Why?
Well,
when you progress through life,
if you're reasonably successful,
you trade in your promising youth for
your wealthy old age,
but you're still bloody old.
Were you,
when you trade it,
would you trade your youth for that?
Like if you factor age out of the
economic equation,
things look a lot different.
Well,
of course older people have more money.
If they have any sense they'd been
collecting it for their whole life.
Is that somehow unfair?
It's not unfair unless you want to want
to be poverty stricken when you're 70
and you and you don't want to be
poverished strict poverty stricken when
you're 70.
So I just don't understand what's
happened to the universities.
I can't believe that you're not told
when you come the first day,
look,
man,
you are,
you're here on a heroic mission.
You're going to take your capacity to
articulate yourself to levels that are
undreamed of you're going to come out of
here unstoppable.
You're going to be able to do anything
you want.
It's like,
that's what you're here for.
Instead,
you're taught that,
well,
you know the world's a pretty oppressive
place and you're probably the bottom of
the victim pile.
And,
and,
and there's,
there's virtually nothing you can do
about it except,
you know,
deconstruct the patriarchy.
And it's so neat and so pathetic that
the university should be embarrassed
that that's what they're peddling to
students.
I'm embarrassed by it.
You know,
I've,
I've gone on public record telling
parents what do you well,
send your boys to trade school because
at least they'll learn something useful
and that's a terrible thing for someone
like me to say because I do believe that
the are being articulated and educated
in the highest possible manner is
there's nothing that's better for you
and for society.
And why or why have the university's
forgotten this?
Well,
that's postmodern neo Marxism for you.
You know that.
Then the philosophy of intense
resentment and oppression and group
identity and god,
it's just pathetic.
Dr Susan.
I think a lot of students here would
agree with you that one of the main
purposes of education and college,
particularly at Harvard,
is to develop their sense of
articulation,
their ability to read,
their ability to create a critically
think.
But then what comes after,
particularly at Harvard,
there's a big discussion on what is a
good life,
what does it mean to use those skills
that we get here?
And then we graduate.
What do we do from there,
I stopped unnecessary suffering.
That's what you do.
You know that that's your calling.
It's like you say,
well,
what do you do after you graduate?
Well,
if you graduate,
articulated and powerful,
there will be people giving you so many
opportunities.
You won't even be able to keep up with
them.
You know,
and I've worked with very,
very competent people in many different
domains in my life.
Hyper competent people.
And I can tell you some very interesting
things about hyper competent people.
The first thing is they are not selfish
and they're not greedy and one of the
great pleasures in their lives is to
find people who have the capacity to
also be hyper competent and to open
doors for them as rapidly as they can
possibly be opened.
They delight in that because there is.
There's nothing there.
There's very few things that are more
intrinsically meaningful.
If you're an accomplished person,
then to find young people who have the
possibility of being accomplished and
say,
hey look,
here's an opportunity for you.
It's like,
go out there,
man,
kill it.
And then they go out there and kill it.
You think right on,
man,
here's another opportunity to go ahead.
Go there near that to new think.
No,
no.
They're all hurting their wealth and
they're not going to share it with
anyone.
It's like that's absolute complete
rubbish.
So you don't even have to worry about
what you're going to do after you
graduate from here.
If you,
if you turn yourself into half of what
you could be,
because people will be dying to offer
you every opportunity that you can
possibly make use of.
So it's,
it's,
it's a moot point.
The,
the,
the world is always desperately short of
people who can think and speak and,
and you think,
well,
I won't be made use of.
Well first of all,
you can't say that if you're at.
If you're at Harvard for God's sake,
I mean people already figured out who
you are.
They've already figured it out and
they're offering you the world on a,
on a golden platter.
It take it,
it's yours.
Take it.
So like,
great man.
Pull yourself together and deserve.
That would be great.
And that's what everyone wants.
It's what your parents want.
It's also what you want.
You know it.
It's what you want.
It's what men.
It's what women want from men.
It's what men want from women.
It's like for you to be who you could
be,
and then the highest faculty of the
human being is articulated speech.
It's the divine faculty and there is
nothing more powerful than that.
There was nothing that's even in the
same league,
and so if you.
If you don't have faith in that than
your,
then your priorities are misplaced and I
can't even understand why you wouldn't
have faith in that being,
say,
Harvard students because look where it's
got you already know you're already
sitting on top of the world,
so make deserve it.
Make use of it,
right?
Go out there and fix things up.
That's what you need to do.
There's lots of things that need to be
fixed up and what do you want to do is
burden yourself with so much
responsibility that you can barely stand
and then you'll get stronger trying to
lift it up and you'll be.
Won't be asking what should I be doing
with my life or what's the meaning of
life or any of that.
It will be self evident and self evident
at minimum you can say there's more
suffering in the world than there should
be and I could probably do something
about that and you can do something
about that,
so go do something about it and then
there'll be less suffering in the world
and then when you're 80 you can look
back on your life and say,
well,
you know,
there's less suffering in the world than
there would have been had.
I know it existed and and you don't have
to even have a sense of,
of ultimate destiny or even any sort of
theistic belief to regard that as a
positive good.
Like I think it goes beyond the mere
pragmatic utility of addressing the
world's ails because I think we do live
in a,
in a world that has a transcendent
reality as well as the reality that we
can detect,
but even independently of fat,
it doesn't matter.
It's like.
I mean,
this is part of the reason I like people
like Bill Gates is a great example,
man.
That guy is.
He's after five major diseases at the
same time.
Right?
He's trying to wipe out polio.
He's trying to wipe out
malaria.
Yeah,
exactly.
He's trying to wipe out malaria.
It's like,
well,
what should you do with your life?
Well,
you know,
take a look at Bill Gates and see if you
could do something like that.
That would be good.
So.
So Dr Peterson,
you talked about this idea of ending
unnecessary suffering and this idea of
committing one's life to that at a
minimum.
That's the minimum thing that you could
do.
A lot of students,
I think accept that premise and view
what they're doing as trying to
eliminate or reduce unnecessary
suffering and they see activism or other
forms of direct service as fulfilling
that goal.
Do you simply disagree with the content
of what they think the tactic that they
are using to end unnecessary suffering
or do you think that their motives or
their intentions are not even the same
as yours?
Arts to public?
You know,
there's this,
there's this old saying from the,
from the new testament about not praying
in public,
right,
and now idea is that if you're going to
commune for the higher good,
you should do it in private because
otherwise you're warping your ethic in
some sense by demonstrating how virtuous
you virtuous you are to the world.
It's like,
you know,
you go out there with a stick and a sign
on it that says I'm against poverty.
It's like,
yeah,
no kidding.
That's really like for poverty,
poverty,
so it's,
it's,
it's an abdication of responsibility
with the mask of social virtue and you
want to solve difficult problems.
You've figured out how to get along with
your brother,
the one you've been fighting with for
five years or see if you can staple your
family back together.
See if you can stop fighting with your
girlfriend and have a relationship that
lasts for more than two weeks.
You know,
it's like there are things that you
should be doing in the confines of your
own life that are private and humble.
That would,
would,
that would constitute genuine
accomplishments.
And those are the things that you should
attend to and no one's going to come
along and say,
hey,
you know,
good job,
you're,
you're changing the world because it's
private,
but it's real and people don't do that.
And so no,
I don't,
I don't trust the activist.
I don't trust the activist ethos at all.
I think it,
I think everything about it is,
is superficial and,
and trendy and,
and too easy.
And,
and the externalizes the blame,
the evil is always elsewhere,
which is a dreadful mistake to make
because the evil isn't elsewhere.
That's,
that's the thing that you understand
when you're wise is the evil is not
elsewhere.
It's you because you're not everything
you could be.
And so,
you know,
you should work on that before going in
telling someone else that maybe they're
not who they should be.
So I think it's,
you know,
so I don't buy it.
It's too easy.
It's far too easy and it's too public
and it's too self congratulatory.
And then there's the murderous,
like Marxist element,
which I'm always often inclined to
mention.
So certainly I think you've identified
certain causes where the public element
or the self congratulatory time to do
good could be harmful,
but do you think there are cases,
for instance,
I'm thinking of policy influencing
policy being a policymaker.
It seems like something like that public
policy could be used to eliminate some
unnecessary suffering but would involve
a more public domain,
something where you are trying to
attract followers,
trying to attract praise from other
people.
Look,
look,
if you,
if you've established yourself in the
world as a credible human being and
people are asking you to enter public
service because of your accomplishments,
then it's time to do it right?
But before that it's a little on the
premature side and if you're just
setting your for self forward as an
Avatar of an idea of an ideology,
then there's nothing to you except I
think of it as the chattering of various
forms of demons.
It's like you're not helpful and if you.
If you look,
you want to think,
okay,
are you fit to lead?
Let's,
let's put it that way.
Okay.
First of all,
do you know where you're going?
Because that's actually one of the
hallmarks of a leader.
Leader knows where he's going and maybe
other people are also interested in
going that way,
but the leaders I've met have carved
themselves out a personal vision,
right?
It's not some.
It's not some cookie cutter ideological
solution to the ills of the planet.
They've done a detailed analysis,
right?
They know what they're talking about and
they're usually people.
They've had a successful relationship,
they've had a successful family,
they have a couple of degrees.
They've established a business like
they've made themselves credible in five
or six dimensions.
Well then maybe you know enough about
the world to dare to mess with its
internal mechanisms,
and if you.
If you don't have that kind of in depth,
then you should just.
You shouldn't.
You should know more work on the
economic systems of Western
civilization.
Then you should try to adjust the
electronic systems of your automobile
because the latter is far less complex
than the former.
So of course there's utility in policy
formulation and in,
in government service and in all of
those sorts of things.
But you have to.
You have to have transformed yourself at
least to some degree,
into someone who's actually competent
before you should even dare to do such
things.
You think,
well,
I have read some marks and now I know
how to change the world.
That's a very bad idea because the
probability that you're going to take
something complex that doesn't work too
badly and fix it with your idiotic
intervention is zero.
So
hmm.
Well put
the chaos is hiding in what's irrelevant
and so,
and that's very interesting observation
because since the chaos is virtually
infinite,
it's a real questions.
Where the hell do you put it while you
put it in what you ignore and you can
ignore it as long as it isn't actively
interfering with your movement forward,
you can assume that it's that it doesn't
matter that it doesn't matter that it
doesn't matter.
Same thing.
All right,
so here's the kicker.
There's one more class of things that
you can run into along the way and this
is where the chaos breaks through.
So let's say
you're moving from point a to point b
and something that you don't expect
occurs and it gets in the way.
So let's say that you're living with
someone and maybe you kind of like them,
you're not married so you don't like
them that much because otherwise you'd
ask them to marry you.
But anyways.
Um,
and so had quarter view is looking for
something better in three quarters view
is half satisfied,
something like that.
And then a person because we're
ambivalent about such things.
And then the person you discover or the
person announces that they've been
having an affair.
Okay.
So then how are you supposed to respond
emotionally to that?
Well,
the part of you that wasn't all that
committed to the relationship is kind of
exhilarated by that.
And then the three quarters of you
that's half satisfied is hurt and,
and you're going to exploit that part
for sure in the ensuing discussions and
not mention the,
oh,
that's kind of exciting that you've
betrayed me that way.
So,
so,
but the point is,
is that you,
that's a whole.
Now what's happened is a whole has you
have this structure that you're walking
on ice,
like the thin ice that you're skating on
and now there's a hole in it and the
whole.
We don't even know how deep the hole is,
but you know there's a hole there and so
now you're anxious.
It.
Oh,
they'll maybe also a little bit excited
because God only knows what's down
there,
but but you don't know what to do with
that whole because it could spread very
badly on you.
It could be that you know the whole
relationship was a facade and that all
your relationships have been facades,
facades,
and that the reason that is is because
you're so damn shallow that it's
impossible for you to have a
relationship that isn't just a facade
and that's partly because you don't pay
any attention to other people.
And it's also partly because you're
malevolent and selfish.
So that's a nasty thing to discover.
Or maybe that's the sort of person that
you're attracting.
Which would make sense actually if
that's the sort of person that you are.
And so.
So there are certain things that you can
encounter that basically unglue you,
and what happens is that those moments
of being unglued travel up that entire
hierarchy of presuppositions.
It's like because the one of the logical
conclusions to being betrayed in a
relationship is that you are,
that you're truly a bad person.
Now another
equally logical conclusion is that the
person that you're with is really a bad
person.
And another logical conclusion is all
people are truly bad people.
You know,
I mean in,
in,
in macro ways that in microwaves you
can't trust anyone.
You can't trust women.
You can't trust men.
You can't trust human beings.
You can't trust yourself.
The whole place is a catastrophe.
It's a nightmare.
Well then you can fall through into
chaos.
Now the way your body responds to that,
when something or maybe you know you're
supposed to be getting a promotion at
work,
that's good.
You're all chipper about the promotion
at work and you walk into your boss's
office because he or she wants to see
you and they say,
well,
you know,
we've reviewed your performance over the
last few years and your performance has
been somewhere between mediocre and
decent and we're downsizing and see
later.
That's not a raise or a promotion,
that's for sure.
That's a whole that you fall into and
the question is,
well,
what do you make of that?
Right.
How do you frame that?
How do you take that emergent chaos and
make habitable order out of.
You don't know.
Is the whole capitalist system rotten to
the core?
I mean,
that's a convenient explanation under
those circumstances,
that's for sure.
Where you're working for a psychopathic
son of a bitch.
Did you make the wrong choice in
university and was that your father's
fault because you never did what you
wanted or was it your fault for not
standing up to them or is it a dying
industry or is maybe this is a wake up
call that you should go do something
else that you've been waiting to.
Do you know that you've actually wanted
to do your whole life and that's why
you're doing such a miserable job at
your current occupation because you're
bitter and resentful about the fact that
you never did what you want.
You don't know.
It's all of those things at once and
that's very stressful because all of
those things at once is too many things
and that's the reemergence of chaos.
That's the flood.
That's the return to the beginning of
the cosmos.
That's another way that it's been
represented.
Mythologically stayed.
You voyage all the way back to the
beginning of the cosmos when there's
nothing but undifferentiated chaos and
that's what you're confronting and maybe
it's too much for you and often it is.
I mean that that can really.
That can be traumatizing.
It can hurt your brain.
You know,
it's just too much for you to bear,
but it doesn't matter.
You're stuck with it.
And so how do you respond to that?
Well,
some of it is catastrophic,
negative emotion.
You freeze and that's protective and
maybe you don't even want to move.
You don't want to bloody well get out of
bed for a week and that's because your
body is reacting as if the bedroom floor
is covered with snakes and the best
thing for you to do is just not move,
just freeze.
Not a pleasant situation to be in
because it's your aroused,
very,
very physiologically demanding,
and there's zero about it that's
productive except maybe the snakes won't
see you,
but they've already seen you,
so that isn't helping very well.
So you've got all this undifferentiated
nadir,
negative emotion,
anxiety,
fear,
hurt,
anger,
guilt,
shame,
emotional pain,
the whole plethora of catastrophes.
And then maybe on the other side lurking
down there is,
thank God I'm done with that job.
I just bloody well hated.
I dragged myself off to work every day
and there's a little part of my soul
that so goddamn happy.
I finally got fired that I can hardly
stand it.
You know,
and maybe you don't even admit that to
yourself because well,
that would mean that all that time you
spent at the job was just sunk costs.
You're deluding yourself the whole time
on.
It is an interesting thing to consider
those sometimes if you're in the
unpleasant circumstance of having to
fire someone,
you know,
sometimes firing someone is the best
thing that can happen to them,
which doesn't mean that you should go
out and like enjoy it.
Although I have met very disagreeable
people who actually enjoyed firing
people and I'll tell you a story about
that at some point because it's quite
interesting,
but you know,
sometimes if someone's just limping
along in their job and doing it as
miserably in wretchedly as they possibly
can imagine,
the best thing you can do to them for
them is to say,
you know,
you're failing at this and,
and that doesn't necessarily mean that
you would have to be failing at
absolutely everything else in the entire
world.
So maybe you should just accept the dam
failure and go off and try something
new.
And I mean that's terrifying for people
and I know they hate it and all that,
but,
but sometimes it's better than the
alternative,
which is just slow torturous death.
No,
the idea of dream analysis,
I suppose it's one of Freud's perhaps
Freud's major contribution to modern
western thought.
The idea was there was something to
dreams and I suppose what I did is said,
hey look,
isn't it strange we have this whole
other form of thought that we engage in
at night it and it speaks in the
language that we don't really understand
and so what the hell is that?
And you can say many modern people
do dreams are of no significance or even
that they're random processes,
which is an absurd proposition obviously
because they're by Terrell,
whatever they are,
they're obviously not random.
So.
So Freud's idea was that there was some
something in dreams that was
informative,
so that's his.
Now he had a method for describe for
extracting out from the dream what dream
purported to represent and he outlined
that in great detail in the
interpretation of dreams and if you want
to read one book by Freud,
I would highly recommend that when it's
a very long book and it's very detailed,
but for a desert extraordinarily
comprehensive analysis of the way that
dreams work.
Now he made the because because he had
brought a theoretical framework to bear,
even on his investigation into dream
structure,
he concluded that dreams were
essentially wish fulfillments,
and that's where young and Freud
disagreed.
He also believed that the primary
motivating factor of human beings with
sexual,
and now that's a tougher one to toss
aside because even if you're a
Darwinian,
rather than afraid,
Ian,
you're going to obviously support the
proposition that sexual motivation among
any living creature is going to be one
of the highest order motivations because
otherwise creatures don't reproduce and
and prevail over the long run.
So the question is,
is that is that the ultimate source of
motivation?
And in some sense the answer to that has
to be yes.
Well,
Freud wanted to make that in some ways
the sole source of motivation,
and I'm oversimplifying and I hate to do
that in relationship to Freud because he
was not as simple minded character
young.
How to dream once,
if I remember correctly,
that Freud and jung were excavating a
basement.
And so freud had outlined in Freud had
already discovered the basement,
let's say.
So that would be the unconscious
structure of the psyche and young broke
through into another basement that was a
multi chambered place.
So many,
many,
many rooms and I suppose what drove
young and freud apart was the
proposition that there was a hell of a
lot more going down,
going on down there.
Then had already met the eye and they
broke on the idea that the sexual
impulse was primary,
roughly speaking,
they broke when you wrote a book called
symbols of transformation,
which is actually.
There's,
there's three books that I know of that
are sort of like maps of meaning.
One is symbols of transformation.
One is a book by Eric Norman called the
origins and history of consciousness.
And the third and the third one,
while his maps of meaning,
they're the same book.
They're just like,
they're trying to solve the same problem
from three different directions.
They're all attempts to address the same
problem.
And so symbols of transformation was a
book that you wrote about the fantasies
of schizophrenia,
a American woman,
and he was.
He was trying to relate her fantasies to
these old mythological ideas and young's
idea.
Essentially,
and this is an idea that was shared by
people like piaget,
so we
were not going to say that you and Freud
just pulled this idea out of the air,
was that the the birthplace of myth,
mythology and literature for that matter
was the dream that that they share
structural,
they share,
they share what mode of information
presentation and it's a relatively
radical hypothesis,
but,
but given that they both,
they both represent
hm
dreams,
dreams and mythological representations
share and essentially narrative
structure and they use their literary
like you know,
I mean it's not so unreasonable to
notice that a dream at night is like the
movie that you play in your head and
it's not unreasonable to note as well
that the dreams that you have at night
bear a relationship to the daydreams
that you have during the day.
It's a form of cognition.
It seems like an involuntary form of
cognition though.
And that's a very strange thing.
So young thought about the dream as
nature,
speaking of its own accord,
roughly speaking.
And so his idea was,
well,
when you,
when you sleep,
you dream,
but the dream happens to you.
It's not something that you create the
way that you don't even think about
creating it,
because I might say,
well,
what are you thinking about?
And you'll say,
I'm thinking about whatever it is,
and you'll take credit in some sense for
thinking that because it seems like a
voluntary activity,
but what happens at night is that you
think,
but you think involuntarily and so what
young would say is that means that
something is thinking in you
and that's a perfectly reasonable way of
looking at it and this is one of the
things that's uncanny about the cycle
analysts as they were willing to take
their observations to their logical
conclusion.
There are things that think in you.
What are those things and what are they
thinking and why are they thinking it?
Now,
if you do dream analysis,
and this is a tricky thing because who's
to say if your damn analysis is correct?
Right?
It's very difficult to understand that
if you.
If you do dream analysis with someone,
you generally have them lay out their
dream and then you ask them when they're
going through their dream of second
time,
they lay out their dream and you can
kind of get a picture of it,
and then they lay out their dream a
second time and as they go through it,
every time they mentioned a detail or a
character,
you ask them what that reminds them of
and the hypothesis is that the dream is
presenting an image or an idea that's
associated with a network of ideas and
then if you can expand on the network of
ideas as you go through the dream,
you can elaborate on the dream.
You can expand it upwards and you can
start to see what it might be attempting
to put forward.
Now.
Freud's idea was that the dream knew
what it was doing,
but that its content was being
suppressed and oppressed by an internal
sensor.
The dream had to be
sneaky about what it was saying because
it was going to deliver a message that
the person didn't want to hear.
That that was tied up with his idea of
repression,
but that's not young's idea.
See,
young's idea was different.
He said,
no,
no.
The dream is trying to tell you what is
trying to tell you as clear as it can.
That's just the best it can do,
and so you could think of the dream,
and this is I believe,
the right way to think about it.
The dream is the birthplace of thought.
The same way that artists are the
birthplace of culture.
It's exactly the same process.
It's that your mind is groping outward
to try to comprehend what it has not yet
comprehended and it does that first by
trying to map it on to image and it's
doing that in the dream and it's
somewhat incoherent and and,
and well,
let's stick with coherent because it's
not yet a full fledge thought.
It's the birthplace of thought.
It's a fantasy about what might be,
and then if you can grip the fantasy and
share it with other people,
then maybe they can elaborate upon it
and bring it into being with more
clarity than it would be if it merely
existed.
As the precursor of a thought in your
imagination,
do you know if you take people and I've
told you this and you expose them
voluntarily to things that they are
avoiding and are afraid of,
you know,
that they know they need to overcome in
order to meet their goals,
their self defined goals.
If you can teach people to stand up in
the face of the things they're afraid
of,
they get stronger and you don't know
what the upper limits to that are
because you might ask yourself like if
for 10 years if you didn't avoid doing
what you knew you needed to do by the
depth,
by your own definitions,
right?
Within the value structure that you've
created,
to the degree that you've done that,
what would you be like?
Well,
you know,
there are remarkable people who come
into the world from time to time and
there are people who do find out over
decades long periods what they could be
like if they were who they were.
If they said if they spoke their being
forward and they get stronger and
stronger and stronger and we don't know
the limits to that.
We do not know the limits to that,
and so you could say,
well,
in part perhaps the reason that you're
suffering unbearably can be left at your
feet because you're not everything you
could be and you know it,
and of course that's a terrible thing to
admit and it's a terrible thing to
consider,
but there's real promise in it,
right?
Because it means that
perhaps there's another way that you
could look at the world and the number
another way that you could act in the
world.
So what it would reflect back to you
would be much better than what it
reflects back to you now.
And then the second part of that is,
well,
imagine that many people did that
because we've done a lot as human
beings.
We've done a lot of remarkable things
and I told you already,
I think before that today,
for example,
about 250,000 people will be lifted out
of abject poverty and about 300,000
people attached to the electrical power
grid.
We're making.
People were lifting people out of
collectively at a faster rate that's
ever occurred in the history of
humankind by a huge margin and that's
been going on unbelievably quickly since
the year 2000.
The UN employee plan to have poverty
between 2000 and 2015 and it was
accomplished by 2013.
So there's inequality developing in many
places and you hear lots of political
agitation about that.
But overall the tide is lifting everyone
up and now it's a great thing.
We have no idea how fast we can multiply
that if people got their act together
and really aimed at it.
Because,
you know,
my,
my experience is with people that were
probably running at about 51 percent of
our capacity.
Something mean you can think about this
yourselves.
I often ask undergraduates how many
hours a day you waste or how many hours
a week you waste.
The classic answer is something like
four to six hours a day,
you know,
inefficient studying,
uh,
watching things on youtube that not only
do you not want to watch,
that you don't even care about that make
you feel horrible about watching.
After you're done,
that's probably four hours right there.
Now you think,
well that's 20,
25 hours a week.
It's 100 hours a month.
That's two and a half full work weeks.
It's half a year of work weeks per year.
And if your time is worth $20 an hour,
which is a radical underestimate.
It's probably more like 50.
If you think about it in terms of
deferred wages,
if you're wasting 20 hours a week,
you're wasting $50,000 a year and you
are doing that right now and it's
because you're young wasting $50,000 a
year as a way bigger catastrophe then it
would be for me to waste it because I'm
not going to last nearly as long.
And so if your life isn't everything,
it could be.
You could ask yourself,
well,
what would happen if you just stopped
wasting the opportunities that are in
front of you?
You be who knows how much more
efficient,
10 times more efficient,
20 times more efficient.
That's the prieto distribution.
You have no idea how efficient,
efficient people get.
It's completely.
It's off the charts
well,
and if we all got our act together
collectively and stopped making things
worse because that's another thing
people do all the time.
Not only do they not do what they should
to make things better,
they actively attempt to make things
worse because they're spiteful or
resentful or arrogant or deceitful or or
homicidal or genocidal or all of those
things all bundled together in an
absolutely pathological package.
If people stopped really,
really trying just to make things worse,
we have no idea how much better they
would get just because of that.
So there's this weird dynamic that's
part of the existential system of ideas
between human vulnerability,
social judgment,
both of which are are,
are,
are major causes of suffering and the
failure of individuals to adopt the
responsibility that they know they
should adopt.
And that's the thing that's interesting
too,
is that like one of the,
another thing I've asked often asked my
undergraduate classes,
you know,
there's this idea that people have that
people have a conscience
and you know what the conscience is.
It's,
it's this feeling or voice you have in
your head just before you do something
that you know,
is stupid,
telling you that probably you shouldn't
do that stupid thing.
You don't have to listen to it strangely
enough,
but you go ahead and do it anyways.
And then of course exactly what the
conscience told you was going to happen
inevitably happens so that you feel even
stupider about it than you would if it
happened by accident.
Because,
you know,
I knew this was going to happen,
I got a warning it was going to happen
and I went and did it anyways.
And the funny thing too is that that
conscience operates within people and we
really don't understand what the hell
that is.
So you might say,
well,
what would happen if you abided by your
conscience for five years or for 10
years?
What sort of position might you be in?
What sort of family might you have?
What sort of relationship might you be
able to forge and you can be bloody sure
that a relationship that's forged on the
basis of who you actually are is going
to be a lot stronger and more welcome
than one that's forged on the basis of
who you aren't.
Now,
of course,
that means that the person you're with
has to deal with the full force of you
in all your ability and your
catastrophe,
and that's a very,
very difficult thing to negotiate,
but if you do negotiate it well,
at least you,
you have something,
you have somewhere solid to stand and
you have somewhere to live.
You have a real life and it's a great
basis upon which to bring children into
the world,
for example,
because you can have an actual
relationship with them instead of
torturing them half to death,
which is what happens in a tremendous,
a tremendously large minority of cases.
Well,
it's more than that too because,
and this is what I'll close with and
this is why I wanted to introduce social
knutson's readings to you.
You see,
because it isn't merely that your fate
depends on whether or not you get your
act together and to what degree you
decide that you're going to live out
your own genuine being.
It isn't only your fate,
it's the fate of everyone that you're
networked with and so you know,
you think,
well,
there's 9 billion,
7 billion people in the world.
We're going to peak at about 9 billion
by the way,
and then it'll decline rapidly,
but 7 billion people in the world and
who are you?
You're just one little dust mote among
that 7 billion,
and so it really doesn't matter what you
do or don't do,
but that's simply not the case.
It's the wrong model because you're at
the center of a network.
You're a node in a network.
Of course that's even more true now that
we have social media.
You'll,
you'll know a thousand people at least
over the course of your life and they'll
know a thousand people each and that
puts you one person away from a million
and two persons away from a billion,
and so that's how you're connected and
the things you do.
They're like dropping a stone in a pond.
The ripples move outward and they effect
things in ways that you can't fully
comprehend and it means that the things
that you do and that you don't do are
far more important than you think,
and so if you act that way,
of course,
the terror of realizing that is that it
actually starts to matter what you do
and you might say,
well,
that's better than living a meaningless
existence.
It's better for it to matter,
but I mean if you really asked yourself,
would you be so sure if you had the
choice?
I can live with no responsibility
whatsoever.
The price I pay is that nothing matters
or I can reverse it and everything
matters,
but I have to take the responsibility
that's associated with that.
It's not so obvious to me that people
would take the meaningful path.
No.
When you say,
well,
nihilists suffer dreadfully because
there's no meaning in their life and
they still suffer.
Yeah,
but the advantages,
they have no responsibility.
So that's the payoff and I actually
think that's the motivation.
Say,
well,
I can't help being nihilistic.
All my belief systems have collapsed.
It's like,
yeah,
maybe.
Maybe you've just allowed them to
collapse because it's a hell of a lot
easier than acting them out and the
price you pay is a meaningless
suffering,
but you can always whining about that
and people will feel sorry for you and
you have the option of taking the
pathway of the martyr so that's a pretty
good deal.
All things considered,
especially when the when the alternative
is to bear your burden properly and to
live forthrightly in the world.
Well,
what SOS units and figured out in so
many people in the 20th century,
it's not just him,
even though he's the best example,
is that if you live a pathological life,
you pathologize your society and if
enough people do that,
then it's held really,
really,
and you can read the Gulag archipelago.
If you have the fortitude to do that and
you'll see exactly what hell is like and
then you can decide if that's a place
you'd like to visit or even more
importantly,
if it's a light.
If it's a place you'd like to visit and
take all your family and friends because
that's what happened in the 20th
century.
Okay,
so now I'll read you the story of the
Buddha,
the father of Prince Gautama,
the Buddha savior of the Orient,
determined to protect his son from
desperate knowledge and tragic awareness
built for him and enclosed pavilion,
a walled garden of earthly delights.
Okay,
so the story goes that an angel visited
Buddhist father and said that he's going
to have a son and the son is either
going to become the greatest ruler that
the world has ever seen or a spiritual
leader and the father being a practical
man thought where there's no bloody way.
I want my son to be some like wandering
spiritual leader.
I want him to be the greatest king that
the world has ever seen.
Okay?
And so the father decides,
how am I going to get my son to be the
greatest ruler the world has ever seen?
I better get them to fall in love with
the world because then he's not going to
go traipsing after some sort of pathway.
Did spiritual knowledge.
He's going to stick to practical tasks,
right?
That's something that a father should do
to some degree is orient you in the
world.
Right?
And maybe shouldn't subvert your
spiritual development to any great
degree,
but there's a practical element to this
and and so anyways,
that's how it works.
And so that's what happens.
The father bill is this of perfection
and he eliminates from it everything
that's a reminder of the suffering
that's associated with life.
So the only thing that's allowed,
the only creatures that are allowed to
be in there,
the only people that are allowed to be
in there are healthy,
young,
and happy people.
So the Buddha grows up surrounded by
nothing but the positive elements of
life.
Well,
you think,
well,
what does that mean?
While it's akin to the paradise idea,
obviously walled enclosure of paradise
where there's no death,
but there's more to it than that too.
It's also in some sense what a good
father would do.
What do you do with your young children?
Well,
you don't expose them to death and decay
at every step of the way.
Right?
To you.
You build a protected world for them
like a wall enclosure,
and you only keep what's healthy and
life giving inside of it,
and you don't expose them to things that
they can't tolerate.
You know,
maybe you don't take a three year old to
a funeral.
Now maybe you do,
but maybe you don't.
There's things that you don't expect
them to be able to cope with.
You regulate what they're allowed to
watch.
You're not going to show them the tech
Texas chainsaw massacre when they're
four years old.
Right,
so so you're staving off knowledge of
mortality and death,
and so he's just being a good father in
many ways here.
All signs of decay and degeneration
where thus kept hidden from the prince,
immersed in the immediate pleasures of
the census in physical love and dance
and music and beauty and pleasure.
Gautama grew to maturity,
protected absolutely from the
limitations of mortal being.
However,
he grew curious,
despite his father's most particular
attention and will and resolve to leave
his seductive prison.
Well,
it's that curiosity element.
It's the same thing that lurks in the
Adam and Eve story.
It's like God tells Adam and Eve,
see that tree over there.
Don't be bothered with it.
Well,
you know what's going to happen with
human beings,
especially if there's a snake associated
with it.
They're going to be over there right
away.
Check in that place out,
and that's exactly what happens with the
Buddha.
It's like he's raised to be healthy and
what is.
What's the consequence of that is that
the fact that he's healthy makes them
look for what's beyond the protected
confines of the thing that made him
healthy.
It's like what's like even in the Japan
story,
you know where Japan Paints on
Pinocchio,
his mouth,
and he's ready to go.
He puts them outside the next day and
Pinocchio is ready to run away with all
the kids.
Right?
So the consequence of raising a child in
a healthy way is that the child is going
to be curious enough to go out there and
look for some trouble and we actually
know that because there is followup
studies of teenagers,
you imagine that there's teenagers who
never break any rules and then there's
teenagers who break all the rules.
Okay?
These teenagers don't do very well.
Introverted,
depressed,
anxious,
depressed.
Sorry,
I said that twice.
These ones are antisocial.
The ones in the middle,
that's what you want.
You want your damn teenager to get out
of the paradisical confines of your
house and to go cause some trouble and
to investigate.
Maybe you don't want to know about it
anymore than you have to.
You don't want them to be breaking rules
all the time and you don't want them to
be so timid into press that they can't
make a move on their own and never make
a mistake.
So the paradoxical thing here,
and it sort of echoed are,
this is why I like these two stories
back to back is like if you give people
what they want,
then the first thing they're going to do
is try to get beyond it.
And Dostoevsky says the same thing and
notes from underground.
He says,
if you gave people everything they
wanted,
pure utopia.
So he says,
so that they're sitting in a pool of
bliss with nothing but bubbles of
happiness coming up from the surface and
all they have to do is eat cake.
And busy themselves with the
continuation of the species.
Dusty said Dostoyevsky's observation is
the first thing that people would do is
find something to smash that with.
Just so that something interesting and
perverse could happen.
It's like,
well,
yes,
we're,
we're creatures that are designed to
encounter the unknown.
We want to keep moving beyond what we
have.
Even if we have what we have is what we
want.
And maybe that's partly because we're
oriented towards the future.
We think,
well this is great,
but it's not good enough.
It's great,
There's always something more that
drives us forward.
While.
So that's what happens with the Buddha.
He gets curious.
He sees the walls,
he thinks there's walls,
there's probably something outside of
those walls.
So then he goes to his father
and he says,
I'm,
I want to go outside,
what's outside?
And his father says,
no,
you don't want to go outside.
And Buddha says,
yeah,
well I really do want to go outside.
And his father knows that unless he lets
him go outside,
he's going to climb over the walls.
And so the father decides he's gonna.
Let them go inside,
please go fix everything out there
first.
So he goes outside.
It's like the Chinese preparing for the
Olympics,
you know when they sprayed the grass
with with with green paint,
got rid of all the homeless people is
the same thing.
So he goes outside the city and he tells
everyone,
all right,
old people,
sick people dying.
People hit the road.
We don't want to see it for awhile.
Clean all this out.
We want the attractive people around the
sides of the roads like waving palm
fronds and all of that and so when my
son comes out,
he's going to see nothing but what's
good and so we get that all arranged it.
He lets his son go outside.
Now his son goes outside in this little
chariot thing and he has someone with
him now,
unbeknownst to his father,
that person that's with them as an
emissary of the gods.
And so in a perverse way,
he plays the same role as the serpent in
the story of Adam and eve,
and the gods have already arranged so
that the father's a carer is going to be
insufficient and it's the snake in the
garden idea.
It's like no matter how much care you
take to make things perfect,
some of the some of what what you're
excluding is going to come back in.
So anyways,
Buddha goes outside and he's in his
chariot and preparations were made to
guild is chosen route to cover the
adventurous path with flowers and to
display for his admiration and
preoccupation,
the fairest women of the kingdom.
The print set out with full retinue in
the shield and comfort of a chaperone
chariot.
And delighted in the Panorama previously
prepared for him.
The gods,
however,
decided to disrupt these most carefully
laid plans and sent an aged man to
hobble in full view alongside the road.
The princess fascinated gaze fell upon
the ancient interloper.
Compelled by curiosity.
He asked his attendant,
what is that creature stumbling,
shabby bent and broken beside my retinue
and the attendant answered that is a man
like other men who was born in infant
became a child,
a youth,
a husband,
a father,
a father of fathers.
He has become old subject to destruction
of his beauty,
his will,
and the possibilities of life like other
men,
you say,
hesitantly inquired the prints.
That means this will happen to me,
and the attendant answered inevitably
with the passage of time.
Well,
that's the end of that party.
The world collapses in on Buddha and
paying he hightails at home.
Well,
what does that mean?
that's what children do.
Roughly speaking is there around their
mother.
There are.
They've got security there.
They go out into the unknown,
they encounter something that's just a
little bit too much for them.
Bang,
they come home,
they get old,
padded,
back into shape and hugged,
didn't taken care of.
Hugging children and patting is actually
analgesic.
It actually reduces pate.
Unsurprisingly,
that's what you do with someone who's
grieving,
right?
So you hug them because grief is paid
so,
so they,
you know,
you pat them and they get rid of their
pain.
They get rid of their anxiety,
you calm them down and what happens?
Well,
the next day they want to go out again.
that's exactly what happens to the
Buddha.
So he's all shorted out by his encounter
with death,
which is very little different than what
happens to Adam and eve runs back
recoveries for six months.
He has posttraumatic stress disorder.
He runs home and he recovers for six
months,
right
in time.
His anxiety lessened his curiosity,
grinny.
He ventured outside again.
This time that God sent a sick man
interview this creature,
he asked his attendance,
shaking and palsy,
horribly afflicted,
unbearable to behold,
a source of pity and contempt.
What is he?
And the attendant answered that's a man
like other men
was born whole,
but who became ill and sick,
unable to cope,
a burden to himself and others suffering
and incurable like other men,
you say,
inquired the prince.
This could happen to me and the
attendant answers,
no man is exempt from the ravages of
disease.
Once again,
the world collapsed and Gautama returned
to his home,
but the delights of his previous life
were ashes in his mouth and he ventured
forth a third time,
the gods in their mercy sent him a dead
man in funeral procession.
This creature,
he asked his attendant laying so still
appearing,
so fearsome,
surrounded by grief and by Soro last and
for Lauren.
What is he?
And the attendant answered that is a man
like other men,
born of woman,
beloved in hated.
Who is once you.
Who once was you,
and now as the earth like other men you
say acquired prince,
then this could happen to me.
This is your and said the attendant and
the end of all men.
Well,
that's the end of childhood,
right?
There's no going back after that.
It's like Pinocchio goes back.
There's no one home anymore.
It's there's nothing that your father
can do to protect you from knowledge of
death.
There is no returning to the childhood
unconsciousness because you're.
You now know,
and there's no going backwards.
Suicide.
That's going backwards.
That's how you replace your emergent
self consciousness with the old blissful
unconsciousness,
and that's exactly what suicidal people
wish that are going to destroy their
painful selfconsciousness and make it
all go away.
The world collabs to final time and
Gautama asked to be returned home,
but the attendant had orders from the
prince's father and took them instead to
a festival of women.
Oh,
curing.
Near occurring nearby in a grove in the
woods.
The prince was met by a beautiful
assemblage who offered themselves freely
to him without restraint in song,
dance and play in the spirit of sensual
love,
but Gautama could think only of death
and the inevitable decomposition of
beauty and took no pleasure in the
display.
Well,
so you see the parallels between one
story and the other.
They're the same.
They have the same underlying structure,
initial paradise,
partly childhood,
partly unconsciousness.
The emergence of knowledge of mortality
into that and the demolition of the of
the paradise.
This is the same story that we've been
talking about all along.
Ordered state collapse into chaos.
While the rest of the story is the
return,
like in the Bible,
Bible is actually set up that way,
it's collapse into history and then
a movement upward.
The question is,
what's the movement upward?
That's the question here.
When the collapse is caused by knowledge
of mortality and self caught and the
emergence of self consciousness and
knowledge of death,
is there any manner in which redemption
can be attained or is that the final
like,
is that finally,
is that.
Does that finally demolished you?
Well,
that's the question and that's that's,
that's it's the answer to that question
that entire civilizations constantly
pursue and the question is,
well,
what is the answer?
And part of the answer is identification
with this spirit that generates order
out of chaos.
Well,
I'll tell you a couple of strange things
that it thinks that I don't really
understand.
The first is when we've done the
analysis of the effects of the future
authoring program,
it has had a different differential
impact on men and it's had a
particularly differential impact on what
I would call it excluded men and so that
would be non western ethic minority men
or or what majority of men who aren't
doing very well.
So for example,
at Mohawk College,
the future authoring program had a
particularly robust effect on Mohawk
college who are men who
hadn't done very well in high school and
who hadn't picked a major that had a
destination,
a career destination edits,
and so you can imagine those people are.
They have an ambiguous relationship with
the idea of education and they're not
oriented specifically towards a goal.
They're not very motivated.
Now why did it have a differential
effect on men?
That's a good question.
Well,
first of all,
the women are doing better,
so it might just be a matter of the fact
that it does better for people who
aren't doing as well and at the moment
most of them are men.
I don't believe.
I think that might be part of it,
but I don't believe that's all of it.
I think that part of the reason that
women are doing better is because
they're agreeable and so if a system
sets out a structure and says,
here's a pathway to attainment,
the women won't rebel against that.
They'll go along with it and that's
working very well for them at the
moment.
The men,
especially the men on the disagreeable
end of the distribution and there's way
more men on the district disagreeable
end of the distribution.
Then there are women,
right?
That's what you get from.
If you look at overlapping normal
distributions.
So there's the male district,
female distribution for agreeableness,
mail distribution for agreeableness.
Tremendous overlap.
Okay.
Women are higher.
All the really agreeable people are
women.
All the really disagreeable people are
meant and maybe the real differences
occur at the extremes,
right?
So,
so,
and it's,
it's a very interesting side effect of
overlapping distributions so people can
be mostly the same,
but that can still produce radical
differences.
Disagreeable men won't do anything they
don't want to do.
They just say,
up yours,
I'll go home and play video games with
you.
I'm not listening to your stupid classes
and why should I work for you?
I'll just go have fun.
I'll do my own thing.
I don't think they're motivated.
And so then if you take the men who are
like that and you say,
okay,
what do you want?
You can have what you want,
but you have figured out what it is.
So then they write down what they want
and they think,
oh hey,
well that might be worth having.
So maybe I'll put some effort into it.
That's what it looks like to me.
Now,
you know,
that's weak evidence and this is a weak
argument,
but I'm trying to stretch out my
understanding to account for this,
but I'll tell you something else that's
really weird.
I don't understand this either.
So more than 90 percent of the people
who watch my videos on youtube are men.
Now that's weird because now about 80
percent of psychology students are
women,
so that is not what you would expect,
right?
You would expect that the majority of
them would be women and you might say,
well,
it's because of the political stance
I've taken and I thought,
well that's possible.
So I went and looked at the demographic
data because I have that.
Well before I did any of the political
videos,
85 percent of my viewers were men,
so it's actually increased a bit.
It's increased by six percent and that's
not trivial,
but it was still overwhelmingly men.
So that was interesting.
I thought,
what the hell,
why is that?
Exactly.
And then now I've been watching crowds
when I've been talking to them and the
crowds that have come to see me in
person.
This happened at the University of
Toronto Free Speech Debate and I
actually noticed it and commented on it
before the debate took place because I
was talking about intrinsic differences
between men and women and I looked
around the room and I thought,
hey,
80 percent of the people in this room
are men.
So I had all the men,
women and women stand up and then all
the men stand up.
I said,
look like here's a natural experiment.
For some reason,
80 percent of the people who showed up
to this are men now.
Everybody thought I was kinda cracked to
to do that and it was a risk,
but I thought,
no,
there's something going on here.
And then what's interesting now is that
every public appearance that I've made
that's related to the sort of topics
that we're discussing is overwhelmingly
men.
It's like it's like 85 to 90 percent.
And so I thought,
wow,
that's weird.
Like what the Hell's going on here?
Exactly.
And then the other thing I've noticed is
that I've been talking a lot to the
crowds that I've been talking to,
not about rights but about
responsibility,
right?
Because you can't have the bloody
converse.
What are you doing?
You can't have the conversation about
rights without the conversation about
responsibility because your rights are
my responsibility.
That's what they are technically.
So you just can't have only half of that
discussion and we're only having half
that discussion.
The question is,
well,
what the hell are you leaving out?
If you only have that half of the
discussion and the answer is,
well,
you're leaving out responsibility and
then the question is,
well,
what are you leaving out?
If you're leaving out responsibility and
that answer might be,
well,
maybe you're leaving out the meaning of
life.
That's what it looks like to me.
It's like,
here you are suffering away.
What makes it worthwhile?
Rights.
You know you're completely,
oh,
you're completely.
You have no idea what you're you.
It's almost impossible to describe how
bad an idea that is.
Responsibility.
That's what gives life meaning.
It's like lift a load.
Then you can tolerate yourself,
right?
Because look at your useless,
easily hurt,
easily killed.
Why should you have any self respect?
That's the story of the fall.
Pick something up and carry it.
Pick.
Make it heavy enough so that you can
think,
yeah,
well useless as I am.
At least I could move that from there to
there.
Well,
what's really cool about that is that
when I talk to these crowds about this,
the man's eyes light up and that's very
like I've seen that phenomena because
I've been talking about this
mythological material for a long time
and I can see what I'm watching.
Crowds people you know,
their eyebrows lift,
their eyes light up because I put
something together for them,
not what mythological stories do,
so I'm not taking responsibility for
that.
That's what the stories do.
So I say this story to people,
go click,
click,
click.
You know when their eyes light up,
but this responsibility thing that's a
whole new order of this is that young
men are so hungry for that.
It is unbelievable.
And one of the things I've been talking
to some of the people who've been
running for the conservative leadership
in Canada and I've been talking to them
about,
well,
if the difficulties they have
communicating with young people because
conservatives,
what the hell are they going to sell to
young people,
right?
Because being conservative is something
that happens when you're older.
They can sell responsibility.
No one's selling it.
And the thing is,
for men,
there's nothing but responsibility.
You know,
I was watching the simpsons the other
day.
I watched the simpsons episode and I
deconstructed it,
and so it's really interesting.
So what happens in the first Simpson
episode is that it's Christmas and homer
and marge are going to buy some
Christmas presents,
but homer doesn't get his Christmas
bonus.
And so it was absolutely crushed by
that.
And that actually is a recurring theme
in the simpsons where homer loses his
job or something like that or can't make
enough money.
He's completely crushed even though he's
kind of useless,
bumbling,
laughing,
full of a guy,
you know?
The thing that gives that show its soul
is that he still oriented towards his
family.
That's what makes them honorable,
is that foolish as he is.
He's decided to adopt responsibility for
his family and to try to bear that.
And so he's not.
He's a holy fool.
He's not a complete fool.
And so interesting watching the story
because he suffers dreadfully as a
consequence of not being able to fulfill
this responsibility.
Well,
that's for men.
Women have their sets of
responsibilities.
They're not the same,
right,
because they're complicated because
women of course have to take primary
responsibility for,
for having infants at least,
but then also for caring for them,
they're.
They're structured differently than men
for biological necessity,
even if it's not a psychological issue
and it's also partly a psychological
issue.
Women know what they have to do.
Men have to figure out what they have to
do and if they have nothing worth living
for them,
they stay Peter Pan and why the hell not
because the alternative to valued
responsibility is
impulsive,
low class pleasure,
and you saw that in the Pinocchio Story,
right?
That's pleasure island.
It's like,
well,
why lift the load if there's nothing in
it for you?
That's another thing that we're doing to
men.
That's a very bad idea and two boys,
so like your pathological and
oppressive.
It's like,
fine.
Then why the hell am I going to play if
that's the.
If that's the situation.
If I get no credit for bearing
responsibility,
you can bloody well be sure I'm not
going to bear it,
but then you know your life is useless
and meaningless and you have your full
of self contempt,
denialism and,
and that's not good.
And so that's why I think that's what I
think is going on at a deeper level with
regards to men needing this direction.
A man has to decide that he's going to
do something.
He has to decide that,
yeah,
well,
you know partly what you're trying to do
in the future authoring process to say,
okay,
well what's your highest value?
Right?
It's the star.
It's like,
okay,
what are you aiming for?
You can decide man,
but you know there is some criteria.
It should be good for you.
It should be good for you in a way that
facilitates your moving forward.
Maybe it should be good for you in a way
that's also good for the family and the
community.
It should cover the,
the domain of life mean there's
constraints on what you should regard as
a value,
but you.
But within those constraints,
you have the choice.
You have choice.
Well,
the thing is is that people will carry a
heavy load if they get to pick the god
damn load so and they think,
well,
I won't carry any load.
It's like,
okay,
fine,
but then you're like the sled dog that
doesn't have a sled.
Depaul,
you're just gonna.
You're in a terror pieces out of your
own legs because you're bored,
you know you need.
People are pack animals.
They need,
they need to pull against a weight and
that's not true for everyone.
It's not true.
Particularly say for low conscientious
people.
I mean maybe they're open and creative
are extroverted and some other things,
but for the,
for the typical person,
they,
they'll eat themselves,
they'll eat themselves up unless they
have a load.
This is why there's such an opiod
epidemic among a dispossessed white,
middle aged guys who are unemployed in
the US.
So like they lose their job,
they're done right?
They despise themselves,
they develop chronic pain syndromes and
depression and the chronic pain is
treated with opiates.
That's what we're doing.
So yeah,
that's what it looks like to me is you
have to.
And it's so interesting to watch the
young men when you talk to them about
responsibility.
There is a God damn thrilled about it.
It just blows me away.
It's like,
really?
That's what's.
That's the counterculture.
Grow the hell up and do something
useful.
Really.
I could do that.
Oh,
I'm so excited by that idea.
No one ever mentioned that before.
It's like rights,
rights,
Jesus.
It's,
it's,
it's appalling.
It's an end.
And I feel that that's deeply felt by
the people who are,
who are coming out to to listen to these
sorts of things,
to there.
They've had enough of that so.
And they better have because it's a non
productive motive being responsibility,
man.
That's where the meaning in life is.
So
the most fundamental element,
creativity is actually conceptualized as
a biological trait.
Different personalities.
We all know our terminology for
describing those personalities is broad
and somewhat difficult to categorize,
but psychologists progress
in the last 40 years pretty from the
strictest scientific perspective.
And they know that people differ in
extroversion,
extroverted,
gregarious,
and enthusiastic and assert.
And so they seem to wind their way
through the world by utilizing social
capital and social networks.
Extroverts don't necessarily like you
and creative people.
Extroverts,
well create creative people is slightly
tilted towards extroversion,
but that's not the fundamental dimension
of introverted.
People like to spend time alone and
there's plenty creative introverted
people,
um,
that another personality dimension is
known as neuroticism,
somewhat unflatteringly,
and it's,
it's an index of sensitivity to negative
emotion so that if people,
if you know people who are volatile,
you know they're touchy and they tend to
fly off the handle,
or they're a or they're sad or morose or
anxious,
or tend to avoid stressful situations,
then they tend to be higher in trait
neuroticism.
And that's specifically a negative
emotion dimension.
Extroversion is an index of positive
emotion.
And so people,
they're separate biological systems,
positive and negative from them trying
to get back to creativity or the third.
The third category is agreeableness.
Agreeable people are compassionate and
they basically live for,
for close,
intimate,
personal relationships.
There's conscientious people who are due
to full.
And then there are open people and the
open people,
it's the dimension is called openness to
experience.
There are people who are fundamentally
interested in ideas,
so if you're talking to an open person,
they will immediately move the
conversation to to the discussion of
ideas.
So most of the people in the audience
tonight,
for those who aren't here for political
curiosity are here because they're open
people,
they want to,
they want to hear an intellectual
discussion and and so open people are
interested in ideas.
That's the intellect component of
openness and then they're also
interested in aesthetics and that would
be where the artists really intellect
and aesthetics is where the artists come
out and that was the thing that's
important to know about that and it's
why I went through all five traits.
These are fundamentally,
these are attributes and ways of looking
at the world,
ways of behaving that are fundamentally
rooted in biology.
They're very,
very deep.
It's not a surface trait by any stretch
of the imagination and creative people
also tend to be a higher in,
in,
in trade intelligence,
technically speaking,
and that's the ability to manipulate
abstractions rapidly.
So is creativity is sort of second
level.
Then comes the,
the,
uh,
the traits that you've just described,
don't include them.
Where are they in that group?
While creativity,
creativity loads very highly with
openness.
It,
it's getting idiot create creativity and
openness are probably synonymous more or
less,
although it isn't obvious that interest
in ideas per se is the same as
creativity,
but there's very few people who are
artistic who aren't very interested in
ideas.
So they,
they move along the same path very
tightly.
So let's unpack this notion because you
know,
it's axiomatic that creativity and art
are a indistinguishable.
Is that true from the point of view of a
psychologist?
I would say it's,
it's,
it's a pretty decent,
it's a pretty decent truth.
It's open.
People are the ones that are interested
in aesthetics.
So you know,
there are lots of people who are in some
sense blind too,
but it's actually one of the things that
distinguishes,
strangely enough,
it distinguishes conservatives and
liberals roughly speaking because
liberal liberal people tend to be high
in openness.
They tend to be creative,
but they're low in trait
conscientiousness.
So they're not very beautiful.
They're not orderly,
they're not particularly industrious,
not,
not compared to conservatives,
liberals,
yes and well,
it's partly because you see this is one
of the paradoxes.
Conservatives are high in
conscientiousness,
especially orderliness and they're low
in openness.
And I think the reason for that in part
is that it's not that easy to be
creative if you're too industrious or
orderly.
Because imagine,
imagine you want to be a musician and
you're 18,
19 years old or worse,
25 years old,
you know?
Well,
the thing is is that it's an insane
thing to do if you,
if you're someone who's dutiful and
career oriented and practical because
the probability that you're going to
monetize your creativity is so low that
it's futile to even attempt it in many
situations.
And so if you're too concerned with
convention and,
and productivity,
then that's going to undercut your
ability to,
to,
to manifest adherence to your creative
vision,
which also takes you and all sorts of
directions,
none of which are necessarily practical.
So one of the ways of thinking about
creativity is that it's,
it's a gambling strategy and,
and conservatives make low risk,
low return,
but certain bets really.
And whereas the more liberal types and
the more creative types,
they make high risk,
high return bits.
And so almost all of them fail,
but those who succeed succeed
dramatically.
And they also changed the world.
And so although it's very foolish to be
creative,
it's creative people who,
who lead the vanguard for forward into
the unknown and transform the world.
So foolish as it is,
it's absolutely necessary.
Foolish because risky.
Yes,
because risky.
I mean it's risk.
It's foolish in the same way that a high
risk,
high return bet is foolish.
There's a high probability that you'll
lose.
And so if you're a conservative person,
you're very concerned about hedging your
bets.
You don't want to lose being creative as
a very bad game to play,
but you won't play it anyways because
you're conservative so it isn't going to
matter.
So you are a,
an open,
a late teen and you have conservative
parents and you say,
mom,
Dad,
I'm,
I think I've decided that I'm going to
be an artist and they think what's wrong
with that kid that the death.
A complicated conversation,
isn't it?
Yes,
yes,
it's,
it's like discussing color with someone
who's colorblind and,
and I mean that like it's actually a
perverse things about perverse thing
about conservatives in some sense
because the data on the economic utility
of artists is really,
really strong.
I mean artists,
artists and entrepreneurs are the same
people and of course entrepreneurs are
the people who provide all of the vision
for the entire capitalist system.
They're absolutely necessary,
but conservatives tend to be so blind to
art that they can't even see that the
artists are the people who drive the who
drive the economy forward.
But you make them sound so bad.
No,
there you lord.
So here's,
here's another way of thinking about it
as we're talking about political,
conservative political liberals,
yes,
they're also talking about trait,
like personality traits,
determined voting patterns to a great
degree.
So people vote their temperaments and
this is something that's useful to
understand when you're engaged in a
political discussion is that the person
across the table from you who holds
viewpoints other than yours is not doing
it because they're stupid or ill
informed.
They're doing it because they are not
the same sort of person you are.
And the the funny thing about about
creative people versus conservative
people say are liberal people versus
conservative people is that liberal
start companies and conservatives run
them.
So and I'm really glad to know you need
to conserve their managers like
conscientious people make good managers
and good administrators.
It's and they tend to do better in
school too because diligence and due to
fullness is an excellent predictor of
academic performance.
So if you want something,
if you want something that's already
been invented,
implemented,
and then turned into a machine,
you don't get someone creative to do
that.
They're off to do the next thing.
They're not even interested in that
you'll bore them to death.
So,
uh,
so let's say you're an employer and you
need some creative people.
They're a psychometric test to find out
if someone's actually creative and
they're going to be useful.
Well,
Iq tests work.
I mean,
not,
not everyone with a high Iq is creative.
Lots of lawyers have high Iq and they
tend not to be creative at all.
Well,
you think to think about why that is a.
because lawyers are bound by precedent
and,
and rules and so that isn't the same as
being creative.
And you don't,
you want a creative accountant?
No,
not really.
Not,
not unless you're looking for a jail
sentence.
So they don't like that word at all.
No,
no.
Absolutely.
Yeah,
that's right.
My creative accountant wake.
Wake right.
It's so,
so,
so.
I mean,
I tested,
I tested psychometrically tested 100
most creative lawyers in Canada as,
as a project about 15 years ago with a
magazine called expert,
which was a high prestige magazine among
lawyers.
We had lawyers from across the country
be nominated for their by their firms,
for creativity and and so we got some
really like these were outstanding
lawyers,
so and we tested them psychometrically
very,
very high and intelligence,
but I'm not creative at all.
The first,
the first trait was conscientious due to
full,
hardworking,
diligent,
industrious,
orderly,
because you know,
you're working 70 hours a week and you
better bloody well work if you're in a
position like that too.
So it's nose to the grindstone stuff
very low in neuroticism because it's
very stressful.
So they didn't experience a bunch of
negative emotion,
very disagreeable people while their
letter get litigated.
And so they would,
they want to win.
They're not compassionate and they're
not polite and only after that where
they opened.
So they weren't creative at all,
but they were extraordinarily
intelligent.
So do employers look for creative
people?
No.
No,
not generally.
Well,
it's a real.
It's a real conundrum.
So one of the things that's happening
right now is that in most businesses,
the noncreative people are increasingly
being replaced by machines,
right?
Because anything that's creative can
really be turned into an algorithm and
that you can run as a machine,
but anything that isn't creative can be
and so there's increasing demand
incorporations for creative people,
but the problem with being creative is
that you're useless at the bottom of the
dominance hierarchy because at the
bottom of the dominance hierarchy,
so a power hierarchy,
you should do what you're told to do.
You're not there to think outside the
box.
You're there to learn what you're
supposed to do and implement it and
creative people are like,
that's.
That is what they do.
Now what happens though to companies is
that because they filter all the
creative people out at the bottom and
then people start to rise up to the top.
You really need creative people at the
top because they are the entrepreneurial
types and they're the ones.
For example,
in law firms,
even though lawyers aren't very
creative,
the more entrepreneurial ones are the
ones that bring in all the business.
There's like great lawyers who can,
who can implement,
who can,
who can write well and communicate well.
Are there not a diamond dozen,
but they're relatively common,
but the ones who are entrepreneurial who
can go out there and drum up new
business?
Man,
those people are super hyper valuable
and they're very rare,
but they are,
but it's also very difficult to nurse
them within any system because systems
do not nurture creativity.
There are the antithesis of creativity
because the artist is always the person
who stands outside the structure and so
or maybe builds his or her own
structure,
which is also why it's hard to evaluate
creative people.
You can't really because if they're
operating within the confines of a
system that has an evaluative structure,
they're not creative.
We're having a conversation.
I'm deciding I'm going to listen to you.
Right?
That's different than how people
generally communicate because usually
when they communicate,
they're doing something like,
okay,
we're going to have a conversation and
I'm going to tell you why I'm right and
all win.
If you agree or maybe you're having a
conversation where I don't know what
you're trying to do,
maybe you're trying to impress the
person you're talking to so you're not
listening to them at all.
You're just thinking about what you're
gonna.
Say Next.
Okay,
so that's not this.
This is.
You might have something to tell me and
so I'm going to listen on the off chance
that you'll tell me something that would
really be useful for me to know and so
you can take about it as an,
as an extension of the Piagetian.
Piaget talked about the fundamental,
the fundamentally important element of
knowledge being to describe how
knowledge is sought,
the process by which knowledge is
generated.
Well,
if you agree with me and I find that
out,
I know nothing more than I knew before.
I just know what I knew before and maybe
unhappy about that because it didn't get
challenged,
but I'm no smarter than I was before,
but maybe you're different than me and
so while I'm listening to you'll tell me
something I wouldn't.
I don't like.
Maybe it's something I find contemptible
or difficult,
whatever.
Maybe you'll find you'll tell me
something I don't know and then I won't
be quite as stupid and then maybe I
won't run painfully into quite as many
things and that's a really useful thing.
Know,
especially if you live with someone and
you're trying to make longterm piece
with them as they are not the same as
you and they're away.
They look at the world and the facts
that they pull out of the world aren't
the same as your facts and even though
you're going to be overwhelmed with the
proclivity to demonstrate that you're
right,
it is the case that two brains are
better than one and so maybe nine of the
10 things they tell you are dispensable
or maybe even 49 out of 50,
but one thing all you need to get out of
the damn conversation is one thing you
don't know.
And one of the things that's very cool
about a good psychotherapeutic session
is that the whole conversation is like
that.
All you're doing is trying to express
the truth of the situation as clearly as
possible.
That's it.
And so now rogers' proposition,
and I'll tell you why he derived it,
was that if you have a conversation like
that with someone,
it will make both of you better.
It will make both of you psychologically
healthier.
So there's an implicit presupposition
that the exchange of truth is curative.
Well,
that's a very cool idea.
I mean,
it's a very deep idea.
Uh,
I think it's the most profound idea.
It's the,
it's the idea upon western civil upon
which Western civilization,
although not only Western civilization,
is actually predicated the idea that
truth produces health.
But for Rogers,
that was the entire purpose of the
psycho therapeutic alliance.
You come to see me because you want to
be better.
You don't even know what that means
necessarily.
Neither do I.
we're going to figure that out together.
But you come and you say,
look,
things are not acceptable to me and
maybe there's something I could do about
that.
So that's the minimal precondition to
engage in therapy.
Something's wrong.
You're willing to talk about it
truthfully,
and you want it to be better.
Without that,
the therapeutic relationship does not
get off the ground.
And so then you might ask,
well,
what relationships are therapeutic?
And the answer that would be if you have
a real relationship,
it's therapeutic.
If it isn't,
what you have is not a relationship.
God only knows what you have.
You're a slave,
they're a tyrant,
you know,
you're both butting heads with one
another.
It's a primate dominance hierarchy
dispute.
Oh,
I don't know.
You're like two cats in a barrel or two
people with their hands around each
other's throats.
But what you have is not a relationship.
So alright,
we may say that the greater the
communicated congruence of experience,
awareness and behavior on the part of
one individual,
that's,
that's a reference to the same idea that
I was describing with regards to yoke.
So let's say you come and talk to me and
you want things to go,
well,
well I'm going to have to more or less
be one thing.
Because if I'm all over the place,
you can't trust any continuity in what I
say.
There's no.
And there's no reason for you to believe
that I'm capable of actually telling you
I'm capable of expressing anything
that's true.
So the truth is something that emerges
as a consequences of getting yourself
lined up and beating all the,
what would you call
all the impurities out of your,
out of your,
out of your soul for black of a better
word.
You have to be integrated for that to
happen and you do that at least in part
by wanting to tell the truth.
The more the ensuing relationship will
involve a tendency towards reciprocal
communication with the same qualities.
So one of the things that I've been
quite influenced by Rogers,
one of the things I tried to do in my
therapeutic sessions is first of all to
listen to really listen and then,
well,
well I listen,
I watch and while I'm listening things
will happen in my head,
you know,
maybe I'll get a little image of
something or I'll get a thought or a
question will emerge and then I'll just
tell the person what that is.
But it's sort of directionless,
you know?
It's not like I have a goal except that
we're trying to make things better.
I'm on the side of the person.
I'm on the side of the part of the
person that wants things to be better,
not worse,
and so then those parts of us have a
dialogue and the consequences of that
dialogue is that certain things take
place and then I'll just tell the person
what happened and it isn't that I'm
right.
That's not the point.
The point is,
is that they get to have an hour where
someone actually tells them what they
think.
Here's the impact you're having on me.
You know,
this is making me angry.
This is making me happy.
This is really interesting.
This reminds me of something that you
said an hour ago that I don't quite
understand,
and the whole,
the whole point is not for either person
to make the proposition or convince the
other that their position is correct,
but merely to have an exchange of
experience about how things are set up
and it's extraordinarily useful for
people because it's often difficult for
anyone to find anyone to talk to that
will actually listen.
And so another thing that's really
strange about this listening is that if
you listen to people,
they will tell you the weirdest bloody
things so fast,
you just cannot believe it.
So if you're having a conversation with
someone and it's dull,
it's because you're stupid.
That's why you're not listening to them
properly because they're weird.
They're like wombats or albatrosses or
rhinoceroses or something like they're
strange creatures.
And so if you were actually
communicating with them and they were
telling you how weird they really are,
it would be.
It would be anything but boring.
So.
And you can ask questions.
That's a really good way of listening.
But you know one of Roger's points as
well.
You have to be oriented properly in
order to listen.
And the orientation has to be.
Look what I want out of this
conversation is that the place we both
end up is better than the place we left.
That's it.
That's what I'm after.
And if you're not after that,
you've got to think,
why the hell wouldn't you be after that?
What could you possibly be after that
would be better than that?
You walk away smarter and more well
equipped for the world than you were
before you had the conversation,
and so does the other person.
Well,
maybe if you're bitter and resentful and
angry and anxious and you know,
generally annoyed at the world,
then that isn't what you want.
You want the other person to walk away
worse than Youtube because you're full
of revenge,
but you know you'll get what you want if
you do that,
so we know from our research that such
empathic understanding,
so already defined that I want to hear
you.
I want to hear what you have to say so
we can clarify it and move forward.
I want to have your best interests in
mind and mine as well,
but you know both at the same time and
your families too.
If we could manage that,
we're after making things better.
We know from our research that such
empathic understanding,
understanding with a person,
not about him.
It's such an effective approach that it
can bring about major changes in
personality.
Some of you may be feeling that you
listen well to people and that you have
never seen such results.
The chances are very great that you have
not been listening in the manner that
I've described.
Fortunately,
I can suggest a little experiment that
you can do to test the quality of your
understanding.
The next time you get into an argument
with your wife or your friend or a small
group of friends,
stop the discussion for a moment and for
an experiment institute this rule.
Each person can speak up for himself
only after he has first restated the
ideas and feelings of the previous
speaker accurately.
What accurately means is they have to
agree with your restatement.
Now,
that's an annoying thing to do because
if someone is talking to you and you
disagree with them,
the first thing you want to do is take
their argument,
make the stupidest possible thing out of
it that you can.
That's the straw man,
and then demolish it.
It's like so then you can walk away
feeling good about it,
and primate diamonds dominated them
really nicely.
So,
but that isn't what you do.
You say,
okay,
well I'm going to take what you told me
and maybe I'm even going to make your
argument stronger than the one you made.
That's useful if you're dealing with
someone that you have to live with
because maybe they can't bloody well
express themselves very well,
but they have something to say so you
make their argument strong.
Alright,
then you see what this would mean.
It would mean that before presenting
your own point of view,
it'd be necessary for you to really
achieve the other speakers frame of
reference to understand his thoughts and
feelings so well that you could
summarize them for him.
Sounds simple,
doesn't it?
But if you'll try it,
you'll find that it's the most difficult
thing that you've ever done.
Okay,
good.
We'll leave it at that and then we'll
see you on Tuesday.
What's my advice to young men seeking a
woman for marriage and family?
Yeah.
Well,
okay,
fine.
That's the same quest.
Second question.
That's,
that's pretty straightforward man.
I mean,
you can't eliminate the necessity of
being attracted to one another.
That's important.
And that's mysterious,
you know?
Um,
so for example,
here's a funny thing,
if you,
one of the things know that attracts
people to one another is bilateral
symmetry.
And so if you take men and you ranked
them by the cemetery of their faces and
then you give the asymmetrical men tee
shirts to wear clean t shirts for a day
and the symmetrical men clean t shirts
to wear for a day and then you give the
t shirts to women and you have them rate
the,
the older,
the women rate the odor of the
symmetrical men as more attractive than
the odor of the asymmetrical man.
And then,
and there were other,
uh,
factors that determine sexual
attractiveness that are based on
biological factors that are so deeply
embedded in terms of smell,
for example.
So a women also tend to not be sexually
attracted to the,
to the scent of men whose,
who have,
if I remember correctly,
it's rh factors that would make for
potential trouble in childbirth.
And the often,
the reason that the women give for not
preferring the scent of those men is
that they smell too much like their
brother.
Something like that.
So there was weird,
mysterious things that determine whether
or not people are sexually and
physically attracted to each other.
And I think it's very important that
that's part of a marital relationship.
The next most important thing is trust.
Man.
It's like there's no marriage that's
successful without trust you guys.
You got to tell each other the truth.
And one of the reasons that you'll
believe that marriage as a,
an oath and Carl young as a bond was
necessary.
It's really wise.
It's like,
you know,
telling the truth to someone is no
simple thing because there's a bunch of
things about all of us that are terrible
and weak and reprehensible and shameful
and all of those things.
And they kind of have to be brought out
into the open and dealt with.
And you're not going to tell the truth
about yourself to someone who can run
away screaming when you reveal who you
are.
And so the marriage bond is something
like,
okay,
here's the deal.
I'm going to handcuff myself to you and
you're going to handcuff yourself to me
and then we're going to tell each other
the truth.
And neither of us are going to get to
run away,
and so our,
once we know the truth,
then we're either going to live together
in mutual torment or we're going to try
to deal with that truth and straighten
ourselves out and straighten ourselves
out jointly.
And that's going to make us more
powerful and more resilient and more and
deeper and wiser as we progress together
through life.
And,
and I think that's absolutely brilliant
because if you leave a backdoor open
man,
you're going to use it,
that's for sure.
And the oath is there.
And this was [inaudible] commentary on
the spiritualization of,
of the human parable.
And by Christian marriage,
for example,
which emphasized,
uh,
the,
what would you call it,
the subordination of both members of the
marital union to a higher order,
a personality that was embodied in the
figure,
the logos.
So the idea is that in,
in,
in the Christian marriage,
for example,
the man isn't the boss and the woman
isn't the boss,
the boss is the mutual personality
composed by the seeking of truth in both
of them.
And that's conceptualized as their,
their joint subjugation to the logos and
that is absolutely dead on,
man.
It's like the ruler of your marital life
should be your vowed to tell each other
the truth because like in hard times
during your life,
when you've done something stupid and
idiotic,
that might take you down and you don't
have anybody that you can turn to,
you know,
if you have a partner that you can
trust,
you can go say,
hey,
you know,
I made a big financial mistake man and
it's really torturing me and I feel like
a complete idiot and it's really
dangerous.
And the person there,
it's going to help you figure out what
to do about it.
And they're going to know that when they
make a stupid mistake and they're bloody
well going to,
that they can come and talk to you and
that you guys are going to work your way
through it.
And that's a big deal.
And there's a couple of things our
culture gets really wrong.
And one is it devalues marriage.
That's really a very bad idea because
marriages,
marriages like a third of your life.
And maybe more and kids are a third of
your life and your,
your,
your life outside of marriage and kids
is a third of your life,
you know,
approximately speaking and to miss any
of that is a massive,
massive mistake.
Now,
having said that,
I will also say that for some people
missing one or more of those is
necessary because they have a reason.
You know,
maybe they're brilliantly creative
artists and they need to devote
themselves entirely to their career or
they're outstanding in some way and so
they need,
they can justify the sacrifice of one
part of that triad,
of being to another part,
but for.
But generally speaking,
it's a very dangerous thing and,
and it,
it,
it shouldn't be done.
And also kids get an absolutely terrible
rap,
you know,
because kids are delightful if they're
well behaved.
One of the chapters in my new book is
called don't let your children do
anything that makes you dislike them.
And you can do that,
especially if you discuss it thoroughly
with your spouse.
You're the person that's helping you
discipline the kids and children are the
best company because they're really
enthusiastic about everything they love
doing new things.
They really love you,
so they're happy that you're around.
All you have to do is make sure they're
not too hot and they're not too cold and
they've had something to eat and they're
not too tired and you don't expect them
to stay engaged in something for longer
than they can manage because we used to
take our kids when they were little out
to restaurants for example.
And they could sit there no problem and
behave really nicely when they were two
and three,
but they couldn't do it for more than
about 45 minutes.
He can't push your luck.
But I also noticed with little kids is
that they got antsy and unreasonable
about five to 10 minutes before the
adults did too.
It's just the adults were too stupid to
notice.
The kids would notice right away.
So,
um,
so back to marriage,
while you look for someone you're
attracted to,
that you love,
and then you look for someone that you
can bloody well trust.
And then you tell them the truth and
that way maybe you can get through life
and you can have someone to weave the
rope of your being with and together to
make to make your joint ropes stronger
and you can have some continuity in your
narrative and you can have children and
then you can have grandchildren and like
you can have a life man and there is
nothing.
You are so fortunate if you can manage
that.
And so.
Okay,
so there's that one.
So what's my advice to young men seeking
a woman for marriage and family?
Yeah.
Well,
and also,
you know,
marry someone you think would be a good
mother and that has enough sense
generally speaking,
to know that she wants children.
Now some women don't want children and
fair enough and some women perhaps
shouldn't have children.
That's also possible.
But the general rule of thumb is,
especially once a woman's,
you know,
in her mid twenties,
if she doesn't know that she wants
children or wounded,
met it,
unless she has a viciously important
reason,
then she's not oriented properly.
Psychologically she,
she,
she isn't.
She doesn't know what's important in
life.
Now,
that might also be the case with you and
it probably is,
but as a rule of thumb,
that's a really good one.
How do men and women differ in the way
they evaluate mates?
Well,
here's the study.
More than a thousand respondents,
primarily female.
What they looked at was how much each
person,
how much prestige each person had in
their occupation,
so kind of where they were situated in
the dominance hierarchy,
what their income was under education,
so there are all markers.
They're all pretty decent markers of
socio economic status or they're pretty
decent markers of status,
so and then they looked at how many
partners each person had number of
lifetime partners and number of
preceding year sexual partners,
lifetime occurrence of simultaneous
partner.
So that was someone who was in a
relationship,
a sexual relationship with more than one
person at the same time and lifetime
frequency of simultaneous partners from
one very seldom or never to five.
Very often,
here's their assumption,
the number of partners,
a member of sex.
A acquires is an index of how often this
individual is chosen.
By the other sex,
it's just a definition,
it's an indication of reproductive
fitness as judged by members of the
opposite sex
results,
male criteria
for women,
the correlation between their fertility
rates and the number of partners in the
previous year was point nine four,
so that's basically markers of
biological youth and also markers of
biological health like symmetry or waist
to hip ratio,
which actually tends to be correlated
with reproductive
fitness because women with lower waist
to hip ratios are generally healthier
because especially in youth,
the acquisition of abdominal fat is
often an indicator of subpar physical
health.
The correlation between the fertility
rate and the number of partners in the
previous year is point nine Ford.
That's all of it,
right?
You never see a correlation to point
nine for anywhere ever.
Males choose fertility indicators,
beauty waist to hip ratio,
youthful appearance,
neotenous facial features,
and monotonous means like a infant.
So one of the.
One of the markers of feminine beauty is
a face that has small childlike
features,
female criteria all respondents.
The correlation between socioeconomic
status and frequency of simultaneous
partners.
For men it's point five,
so the higher the status of the man man,
the more likely yes simultaneous sexual
partners,
so it means he's going out with someone
sexually at the same time.
For men,
it's point four,
nine.
For Women it's zero age 30 and over
correlation between socioeconomic status
and frequency of simultaneous partners.
For men it's point eight.
For Women it's zero
age 30 to 39.
The correlation between socioeconomic
status for women and frequency of
simultaneous partners.
For men point nine two.
That's a very small end though.
For Women,
it's point one,
one
female criteria.
For men,
it might reflect a tendency on the part
of females to choose high status
partners during their own reproductive
years.
This might account,
especially for this strong relationship
founded men between the age of 30 and 39
women who typically prefer men three to
eight years older than they are,
would then be in their mid to late
twenties,
a time when accountability and that
sensitivity to male resources is at its
peak
supporting evidence.
I don't believe that,
by the way,
I don't think that women pick man for
the socioeconomic status.
I think that women pick men for the
ability to climb the status hierarchy
because we forced women in an experiment
that we never published to choose
between those two things.
Wealth versus ability.
The women overwhelmingly chose ability.
They just use wealth as a marker of
ability.
Yep.
It was an honors thesis and often honors
thesis,
even if they're publishable,
drift into the thing all do next month
and then they stay there forever.
So because it's a heart,
it's actually quite hard to turn an
honors thesis into a publishable paper
and if there isn't some single person
driving that forward,
it's it's not going to happen.
So that that was the only reason.
Okay,
so trevor's parental investment model
contends that women are more likely than
men to seek a mate who possesses
nonphysical characteristics that
maximize the survival or reproductive
prospects of their Osprey,
and we're examining in a Meta analysis
of meat selection research as predicted,
women accorded more weight than men to
socioeconomic status of ambitiousness
character and intelligence and the
larger differences.
Largest Jeff gender differences were
observed for cues to resource
acquistion,
acquisition status and ambitiousness.
I'll also as predicted,
gender preferences were not found in
preferences for characteristics
unrelated to progeny survival,
like sense of humor in general,
personality
were valid,
comparisons could be made.
The findings were generally invariant
across generations,
cultures and research paradigms.
I'll go to this next one.
Yeah.
Okay,
so here's some correlations.
One of them is between how much money
you make and your personality,
so the correlation between neuroticism
and how much money you get paid as
negative point three.
The higher you are in neuroticism,
the less you make,
less you get paid.
Why?
Why do you think that is?
Well,
because you're not confident in your own
abilities.
You have low self esteem,
and if you're not confident in your own
abilities and you're anxious about your
performance,
the probability that you're going to
feel confident and calm about
negotiating for more money or even
asking for a raise is quite low.
Extraversion and money made virtually no
correlation.
Openness,
no correlation.
Agreeableness negative point two.
For now,
you might not think that those
correlations are very large,
but if the correlation between
neuroticism and money made is negative.
Point three,
if you translate that into an effect
size,
because this is called the binomial
effect size distribution,
just the effect of neuroticism will
ensure that 65 percent of men make more
money than average on 35 percent of
women make more money than average.
Just the effect of neuroticism and if
you add neuroticism and agreeableness
together,
I have to do the math because I have to
square.
I take the square root,
two point five,
point five,
I can't do that in front of a class.
Unfortunately it's going to push it up
to about 70 slash 30 or higher than
that.
There's a little bit of a negative
correlation between conscious
conscientiousness and money made
ascendancy.
How well you progress up the rates?
Yes.
I don't know because I didn't look.
I didn't look in detail into the models
they use,
so I was just going to stick to the zero
order correlations,
so ascendancy negative point one for
neuroticism.
Negative point one,
four,
four.
Agreeableness.
The effects are larger if you total
them.
Let's see.
Here's a good one.
This is something to think about.
Job Satisfaction.
The correlation with neuroticism is
negative point four,
two,
that's a big one.
One of the things that's very
interesting about eroticism is it's also
a very good predictor of marital
satisfaction and it's interesting in
that light to note that 70 percent of
divorces are initiated by women.
Now,
one reason for that is that men are
impossible get along with and the other
possibility is that women are too
sensitive to that and there's no way of
sorting that out,
but it's nonetheless interesting to note
that that's still where the gender
difference lies.
Neuroticism,
correlation with job satisfaction,
negative point for two,
correlation with life satisfaction,
correlation with career satisfaction,
negative point four,
one,
so one of the things you want to
remember is that almost all the measures
that purport to measure something like
wellbeing or happiness or satisfaction
are so contaminated with neuroticism,
that it's not even clear that they're
measuring something different.
You see agreeableness.
The correlation with career satisfaction
is negative point two,
if you get men to rate their performance
and you get their bosses to rate their
performance,
men rate their performance pretty much
the same as the boss is rate their
performance or maybe they rate them a
little bit more,
but if women raped their own
performance,
they rate their own performance as worse
than their bosses rating of their
performance consistently,
and the predictor of that seems to be
negative emotionality.
Now you might wonder if negative
emotionality is something that's
associated with lower levels of life
satisfaction across a broad variety of
measures.
What possible use could it be,
but then you have to wonder,
well,
exactly how is the physical environment
different for women and for men and one
clearer fact is that at an individual
level,
at least in relationship to dominance
battles with men,
women are at a disadvantage not least
because of their size.
Here's another,
here's another something worth
considering.
I don't know how important it is,
but it might be really important.
It depends on how important this is.
Something that Carl Young said,
so it depends on how important.
Youngest now,
Freud established the field of
psychoanalysis and with an investigation
I would say rigorous investigation into
the contents,
the unconscious,
a modern psychologists and psychiatrists
like to,
what would you say denigrate Freud,
but uh,
and I think there's a reason for that.
I think that Freud's fundamental
insights were so profound and so
valuable that they got immediately
absorbed into our culture and now they
seem self evident and so that all that's
left of Freud is his errors because we
believe everything else,
we believe all the profound things he
discovered,
we just take them for granted.
And so we don't believe the things that
he said that weren't quite on the money
and that's all we credit with him with
now.
But he was certainly the first person
who brought up the idea of the
unconscious in a rigorous manner and he
was the first person to do a rigorous
examination of dreams because the
interpretation of dreams is a great
book.
It's well worth reading.
And he was the first person to note that
people were in some sense inhabited by
subpersonalities that had a certain
degree of autonomy and independent life.
Brilliant observation,
the cognitive psychologists haven't
caught up with that at all,
yet.
Ewan was profoundly affected by Freud.
Jung was profoundly affected by nature
and by Freud.
Those were his two main intellectual
influences.
I don't think one more than the other.
He split with Freud on the religious
issue.
That was what caused the disruption in
their relationship,
and I think it's an extremely
interesting historical occurrence.
It might be a profound significance.
Freud believed that the fundamental myth
of the human being was the Eda Pole
Myth,
and the myth from a broader perspective
is a failed hero's story.
So the eatable myth is the myth of a man
who develops who grows up but then
accidentally becomes too close to his
mother,
sleeps with her.
He doesn't know who she is,
and as a consequence blinds himself and
there's a,
there's a warning about human
development going wrong in that story.
And I think that Freud put his finger on
it extraordinarily well because human
beings have a very long period of
dependency.
And one of the things that you do see in
clinical practice is that many people's
problems are associated with their
inability to break free of their family,
like they're consumed by the family
drama,
right?
They can't get beyond what happened to
them in their family.
They're stuck in the past.
It's.
And that's,
that's equivalent symbolically speaking,
you might say to the idea of being too
close to your mother of,
of,
of the boundaries being improperly
specified.
And that happens far more often than
anyone would like to think.
As I said,
Freud,
I thought it was a universal,
but you see,
he had a different idea.
And his idea was that it wasn't the
failed hero story.
That was the universal human myth.
It was the successful hero's story.
And that's a difference.
I could seriously a big difference
because the successful hero's story is
remembering sleeping beauty.
You may remember this in the Disney
movie,
the evil queen traps the prince in a
dungeon and she's not going to let them
out till he's old.
Right?
And so there's this comical scene where
she's down in the dungeon,
he's all in chains and she's laughing at
him,
telling him what his future is going to
be like.
She's quite evil and you know,
she,
she paints this wonderful picture of him
being freed in like 80 years and
hobbling out of the castle on his horse
that's so old,
he can barely stand up in him with gray
hair.
And,
and you know,
she recites the story of his eventual
triumphant departure from the castle as
a old and decrepit man.
And she has a great laugh about it.
And it's nice,
you know,
it's a real punchy story.
It's really something wonderful for
children.
That story and
he gets free of the,
of the shackles and the things that free
him.
Our three little female fairies.
It's the positive aspect of the feminine
that frees him from the dungeon.
It's so.
It's very interesting and very accurate
from a psychological perspective.
It's the negative element of the
feminine that encapsulates him in the
dungeon.
And it's the positive element of the
feminine that frees him.
And then he,
he has a queen.
The Evil Queen is not very happy when he
escapes.
You may remember that she stands on top
of her castle tower and starts to spin
off cosmic sparks.
I mean,
she's quite the creature enveloped in
flame and then she turns into a dragon
and she then the prince has to fight
with her in order to make contact with
sleeping beauty and an awakened her from
her comatose existence as her
unconscious existence and
wants a brilliant.
It's a brilliant representation of a
successful hero myth.
He,
he doesn't end up staying in an unholy
relationship with his mother.
Let's say he escapes and then conquers
the worst thing that can be imagined and
is ennobled by that and that as a
consequence,
he's able to wake the slumbering
feminine from its coma and that's a
union story and that's the story that he
juxtaposed against Freud.
Freud thought of religious phenomena as
part of an occult tide.
That would be,
that would drown rationale rationality.
That's why Freud was so valiantly
antireligious and you thought,
no,
it's not the case.
You're throwing the baby out with the
bathwater.
There's something profound and central
to the hero.
Myth and union clinical work is
essentially the awakening of the hero
myth in the in the analysis and in the
client or the patient
to conceptualize yourself as that which
can confront chaos and triumph and that
that's associated with an ennobling of
the Sea of consciousness and the
establishment of proper positive
relationships between male and female.
And you know,
I'm a skeptical person.
I'm a very,
very skeptical person and I've tried
with every trick.
I have to put a lever underneath young
story and lifted up and disrupt it and
I,
I can't do it.
I think he was right in that Freud was
wrong.
I mean,
I have great respect for Freud.
I think he got the progam problem
diagnosed very,
very nicely and in my clinical work,
I see the phenomena that Freud described
emerge continually,
constantly the best.
If you're interested in that,
there's a documentary you should watch.
I may have mentioned it before.
I think it's the best documentary ever
made.
Certainly the best one I've ever seen.
It's called crumb and it's about a
underground cartoonists.
Robert Crumb who who is part of the
hippie movement in,
although he hated hippies,
he was part of the hippie movement in
the sixties in San Francisco,
and started the entire underground
comic,
what culture that that manifested itself
eventually in graphic novels who's quite
a significant figure from the
perspective of popular art and a very,
very intelligent man and also I would
say a hero,
although a very bent and depraved and
warped one,
someone very acutely aware of his own
shadow and the documentary outlines his
attempts to escape from his absolutely
dreadful mother and the failure of his
two brothers to do the same thing.
One of whom ended up as a street beggar
in San Francisco and the other who drank
furniture Polish and died six months
after the documentary was produced.
It's an unbelievably shocking
documentary.
It's the only piece of film that I've
ever seen that captures Friday and
pathology.
I've never seen anything because he
can't see it generally,
unless you're in a clinical situation,
unless you know the details of someone's
lives,
the personal intimate details,
you cannot communicate it.
But the documentary as who made the film
was Robert Zweig off,
if I remember correctly,
was a friend of the crumbs and so he got
access in a way that no one else would
have,
and they're also very forthright and
forthcoming about their situation in
general.
I would highly recommend that it's.
It's a real punch.
If you want to know how a rapist thinks,
like if you actually want to know,
because maybe you don't want to know.
In fact,
you probably don't want to know,
right?
Because do you really want to know that?
Because to understand that means to put
yourself in that position and to
understand it.
If you really want to know how a serial
sexual Predator thinks and why.
If you watch crum and you pay attention,
you'll know and that's only a tiny bit
of what the film has to offer.
It's really
quite remarkable.
Anyways,
young split with Freud on the issue of
the Interpol story as the fundamental
myth of humankind and on the issue of
the validity of the religious viewpoint
and young came down heavily on the side
of the validity of the religious
viewpoint.
And he established that in a book called
symbols of transformation,
which was written in 1914,
and that's the book that broke,
that produced the break permanent split
with Freud and that book,
I would say that books actually been
written three times.
It was written as symbols of trip four
times written as symbols of
transformation,
which young extensively revised when he
was old,
and then it was rewritten in is in a
sense by a student of young's called
Eric Norman,
who is also something someone I would
really recommend.
Eric Norman,
I think is [inaudible] greatest student.
And he wrote two books.
He wrote one called the origins and
history of consciousness,
which is a description of the
development of consciousness out of
unconsciousness,
using the hero myth as a,
as an,
as a,
what would you say as a,
as an interpretive skeleton.
So we Newman viewed the hero myth as the
dramatized story of the emergence of
human consciousness out of the
surrounding unconsciousness in which it
was embedded.
The struggle for consciousness,
the struggle of consciousness upward
towards the light,
like a lotus flower struggles up through
the muck and they and the water to to
lay itself on the surface of the water
and and bloom and reveal the Buddha,
which is of course what the lotus flower
does from a symbolic perspective and
for,
for for Norman.
The hero's story was the story of the
development,
the successful development of
consciousness and the origins of
consciousness.
The origins and history of consciousness
is a great book.
Interestingly,
Camille Paglia row read the origins and
history of consciousness.
She's one of the few mainstream
intellectuals that I've ever encountered
who read that in commented on it,
and she believed that it would be
sufficient antidote to postmodern
denigration of literature.
She thought it was that powerful a work,
and I believe that.
I think it's a remarkable book.
Carl Jung wrote the foreword to that
book and he said in the forward that it
was the book that he wished he would
have written,
so sort of like young.
He wrote,
I don't remember how many volumes,
dozens of very thick,
difficult volumes.
It was like Norman was able to
distill those into a single volume
statement,
and so I would also say if you're
interested in young,
the best book to read is the origins and
history of consciousness.
It's the best intro into into the union
world,
so you.
It's very difficult to,
very difficult to understand.
It requires a real shift of perspective
in order to understand what he's talking
about,
and Norman wrote another book called the
great mother,
which is a little bit more specialized
in some sense,
but it's also extremely interesting
because it flushes out the archetype of
chaos and its representation as feminine
and it's a brilliant book as well and
highly worth,
highly worth reading both those books.
Anyways,
young was a very strange person and a
visionary and and so that's kept them
outside of the academic realm almost
entirely.
I mean,
I was constantly warned as an
undergraduate and then a graduate
student and then a professor against
ever talking about young in any way
whatsoever.
When I went on the job market,
when I was at mcgill,
when I had graduated from mcgill,
I had done my scientific research in
Anelka,
holism,
and I had a fairly lengthy publication
record that was pure empirical research
and really neuro physiological research
into the pharmacology of alcoholism and
I established a reasonably solid dossier
publications,
but at the same time I was writing this
book that became maps of meaning and so
I split my time in graduate student
school between these two endeavors.
One very specifically neurological and
pharmacological and really biologically
based on the other very abstract,
religious,
symbolic,
psychoanalytic,
the complete opposite,
but I could see that the two things
overlapped really nicely and there was a
number of scientists at the time that
we're also drawing the same conclusions.
The same relationship between the
biology and the psychoanalysis.
Jaak Panksepp,
who wrote a book called an affective
neuroscience,
which is a great classic,
is one of those people who who saw the
relationship between the neurobiology of
emotion and motivation and the
psychoanalytic insights never became a
mainstream view.
But I think it's too complex.
I think that bridging the gap between
the biology and the and the symbolic is
too much for people generally speaking,
you know,
it was certainly virtually too much for
me because I got quite ill when I was a
graduate student.
I think for a variety of reasons.
I also would go out and party three
nights a week and so that probably had
something to do with it,
but,
but working on those two things
simultaneously was also rather
exhausting.
Now,
you was a tremendously insightful
clinician and he was a strange person.
Introverted,
visionary,
high and introversion.
Very,
very,
very high in openness.
Like off the charts and also God only
knows what his Iq was.
I mean,
every time I read it's like reading
Nietzsche.
It's terrifying because you know,
he's,
he's so damn smart that he can think up
answers to questions that you don't
even.
It's not like you don't understand the
answers is the,
you never conceptualized the damn
questions.
It's really something to read.
Someone like that,
right?
Who says,
well,
here's a mystery and you think,
wow,
I never thought of that is a mystery,
and here's the solution.
It's like,
okay,
that's.
That's,
that's something you know,
and he could read Greek and he could
read.
He read all the ancient.
He read a very large variety of ancient
languages and was very familiar with the
entire corpus of of astrological thought
and of l chemical thought and of classic
literature and Biblical stories and been
educated in a way that no one is
educated now and so he's very daunting
person to encounter and terrifying,
absolutely terrifying.
His Book Ion,
which is the second volume of the second
volume of volume nine,
which is the archetypes of the
collective unconscious.
That damn book is just absolutely
terrifying because young,
he's one of these visionaries who can
see way underneath the social structures
and look at patterns that are developing
across for you in young's case across
thousands of years and lays them out and
so that's a really.
That's really something to to encounter.
Ion is a terrifying book.
Anyways,
one question might be,
well,
because I read the organ,
I think,
how the hell did he know these things?
How could he figure these things out?
I can't understand how he could possibly
know these things.
Well,
here's a partial answer.
Young was a visionary,
and so what that means as far as I can
tell and like we could do a little quick
survey here.
How many of you think you think in words
can put up your hands,
do you think in words?
Okay,
so it looks like.
What about pictures?
How many of you think in pictures?
Okay,
so that's interesting.
How many of you think that's about half
and half by the way?
Probably a fewer on the word side.
How many of you think in pictures and
words?
Okay,
so all right,
so it was roughly a third in each
category,
but that's also something that I really
haven't encountered any research on from
the neuropsychological perspective.
It's like,
well do you think in pictures or do you
think ad words and and is that actually
a reliable distinction?
I think I think in words most of the
time,
but I can think in pictures like if I'm
trying to build something that I can
think in pictures very almost
instantaneously,
but it isn't my natural mode of
thinking.
I'm hyperverbal and so my natural mode
of thinking is to think everything
through in words,
but I know my wife doesn't like that.
She thinks in images and then it has to
translate them into words and so
anyways,
young was very literate and he could
really think in words,
but he could really think in images.
Also talking to my wife quite
extensively like her,
the intensity of her visualization
vastly exceeds mine.
So for example,
if I close my eyes and then try to
imagine the crowd in front of me,
it's pretty low resolution and vague and
not brilliantly colored and vivid.
You know,
it's,
it's like I'm seeing through a glass
darkly,
let's.
I can't bring images to mind with that
with spectacular clarity,
but my wife is very good at that and you
seem to be absolutely
a genius at that kind of thinking.
And he had a lot of visionaries in his
family history as well,
so I don't know to what degree there is
a hereditary component of that and I
don't know to what degree that's
actually a neurological specialization,
I presume it would be associated with
the trade.
Openness distinguishes itself,
differentiates itself into interest in
ideas and interest in aesthetics.
And my suspicion is that the people who
are more interested in aesthetics are
the visionary types.
The ones that think in images anyways,
young could really think in images and
he could imagine beings.
And I had a client once who was a lucid
dreamer and how many of you have had a
lucid dream so you know you're dreaming
while you're many that that phenomena
wasn't really even even identified as a
phenomena until the end of the 19th
century.
There was a book written about it that
Freud tried to get his hands on but
couldn't because it was a very rare
book.
And then there was a researcher about 30
years ago who started to study lucid
dreams.
But anyways,
I had a client who was a lucid dreamer
and one of the things she could do was
ask her dream characters what
information they were trying to convey
and they would tell her.
So that was very interesting.
And one of the consequences of that was,
I don't have the story completely right
in my memory,
but it's close enough.
She was afraid of a very large number of
things.
And in her dream,
I think it was a gypsy standing by a
wagon,
told her that if she was going to be
successful in university,
that she would have to visit a
slaughterhouse.
And that was something that was way
beyond her capacity to tolerate.
She was a vegetarian,
she couldn't stand the sight of raw meat
even.
And so,
and she was very oppressed and depressed
and anxious because of the slaughter
house nature of existence.
And so her dream focused on that.
And
one of the consequences of that,
because the slaughter house was out of
the question as a clinical intervention,
um,
I took her to an embalming,
right?
Because cause I asked her,
I asked her what,
what,
what might be equivalent to that,
and so she suggested that,
and you know,
exposure therapy is a hallmark of
clinical psychology,
right?
One of the things you do with people as
a clinician is you find out what they're
afraid of and you gradually and
voluntarily expose them to that and that
cures them.
And that's associated with the hero
myth,
right?
It's exactly the same thing.
It's like there's a dragon.
It's stopping you because there's lots
of dragons.
Most of them aren't stopping you.
You can ignore them.
You don't have to just go,
you know,
slash away at randomly.
You're not supposed to be fighting
dragons that aren't in your way,
but if they are in your way,
you can't ignore them.
And then you decompose them into sub
dragons and you have people take them on
and as they take them on,
they dispense with the dragon and they
gained the power of the drag.
It's like a video game.
A video game is like that.
That's why people like the video games.
Well,
that's right,
right?
There's a reason that you absorb power
when you overcome things,
when you play a video game.
It's not like that's intrinsic to the
video game structure.
That's an archetypal idea.
Anyways,
we went and saw an embalming,
which was a very interesting experience
and,
and quite quite useful for her because
she knew what she could tolerate after
that and it was a hell of a lot more
than she thought she could tolerate and
so that's very useful to know.
Back to you.
He's a visionary thinker now.
My client,
I said she could lose a dream and she
could ask her dream characters what they
wanted and what they were trying to
communicate to her.
So that was pretty interesting.
That happened spontaneously.
Had nothing to do with me.
You know,
I'm interested in dreams and one of my
clients are great dreamers,
especially the creative ones because I
think it's a hallmark of creativity to
have vivid dreams and to be able to
remember them.
But that was a faculty that was natural
to her
young.
How did this other client at one time,
at one point,
she had a variety of fears and she had
this dream that she told me she was
walking down a beach and on the side of
the beach up a dune,
small Dune.
There was this old man with a snake,
a big python,
and there's a crowd around him.
And uh,
she was walking by the snake handler and
the snake and the crowd and she didn't
want to have anything to do with them.
He was sort of showing people the snake.
And she told me that dream and I
thought,
well,
you know,
you probably need to go see that snake.
And so I relaxed or quasi hypnotic
technique.
It's very straightforward.
Hypnosis is generally nothing but
pronounced relaxation low.
You have to be susceptible to hypnosis
to actually fall into a hypnotic trance
as a consequence of being relaxed or
just relaxed her.
I had her breathe deeply and pay
attention to different parts of her body
and just relax their muscles one by one
essentially so that she could
concentrate.
And then I told her,
we play with the dream a little bit and
say union technique.
I said,
well,
so called the dream image to mind,
which she could do quite well.
Said,
okay,
so let's,
let's explore it.
So like pretend it's like pretend play
in.
You know,
if you're a kid in your pretend playing,
you don't exactly direct the game,
right you,
you,
you play the game.
So it's partly your direction obviously
because you're the player.
But the thing also happened
spontaneously of its own accord.
And you can think about that as a
dialogue between the conscious mind and
the unconscious mind.
In some sense,
it's developmental dialogue.
It's not a fun game if you just direct
it.
It's only a fun game if you're inviting
and something is welling up as a
consequence.
It's the same thing that happens when
you're,
you're engaged in some kind of artistic
or literary production.
If it's all top down,
you know,
if you're forcing it,
then it's propaganda,
it's empty.
What do you want to sort of put yourself
in a receptive state of mind in an
imaginative state of mind?
And it's sort of half you and half
nature itself,
manifesting itself in your creative
imagination.
And that was the sort of state that we
were striving for.
And she,
I asked her when she was in relaxed,
I said,
well,
what do you think about the snake
handler?
And she said,
well,
he's probably a charlatan and he's just
there trying to impress the crowd and to
show off.
And she was afraid to go up there
because she thought people would push
her towards the snake and she'd have to
touch it.
And so there was a fear of the crowd
issue going on there too.
And I said,
well just look,
go up there,
but do it under these conditions is
that,
you know,
if,
if people get pushy,
what are you going to tell them?
And so we figured out something,
he said,
look,
just tell them that you know,
you want to look at the snake at your
own pace and that you don't need any
encouragement or help.
And it would be good if you were just
left alone.
So that enabled her to defend herself.
So she was afraid that the crowd would
push her to do something that she didn't
want to do.
That was part of the theme of the dream.
So anyways,
she eventually climbed the Dune in her
imagination and went into the crowd and
the crowd turned out to be quite
welcoming and not hostile and not pushy,
which isn't what you'd expect,
right?
Because the,
you'd think the crowd would have reacted
in accordance with their fears since it
was her fantasy.
But that's the thing about fantasies.
They have this autonomous quality,
but the crowd was welcoming and not
hostile and it turned out that the snake
handler wasn't a charlatan.
He was just an old guy who had this
snake and he was out there just showing
it to people because he thought it was a
cool thing and,
and,
and that maybe it was good for people to
come and look at a snake.
And so she got close enough to the snake
to touch it.
And so.
So I'm telling you that because I want
you to understand a bit more about what
union was trying to do.
And so he wrote these books,
notebooks that haven't been published
yet,
called the block books,
and the black books are the
documentation of his experiments with
his imagination
and what he would do is Adrian,
like,
like a child daydreams.
He regained that faculty,
although I think with you.
And it was a faculty that has never
really disappeared and he had figures of
imagination that came to him that he
could speak with.
And he spoke with these figures of
imagination and documented that over a
very long period of time.
And that was originally,
that was eventually
distilled into a book called the Red
Book,
which was published about three or four
years ago.
And it was a book that young regarded as
the
central source from which all his
inspiration emerged.
There was sort of the way it looks to me
is that we embody
a lot of information in our action,
right?
And our action has developed as a
consequence of imitating other people.
And not only the people or the people
around us,
but of course the people around us
imitated the people who came before
them.
And those people in mutated the people
who came before them and so on so far
back that it's as far back as you can
go,
and so you embody these patterns of
behavior that are extremely informative,
that you don't understand,
that are a consequence of collective
imitation across the centuries and
throw.
Then those patterns can become manifest
as figures of the imagination and those
failures of imagination are the
distillations of patterns of behavior
and so as the distillations of patterns
of behavior,
they have content and it's not you that
content.
It's you could even think about it as
content that's evolved.
Although it's culturally transmitted,
it's content that's evolved and so these
figures of the imagination can reveal
the structure of reality to you.
And that's what happened with young and
that's what he described in the red
book.
And that was what permeated his
psychology.
Psychology.
That was based on the presupposition
that the fundamental architectural
structures of religious belief.
We're not pathological,
not deceitful,
not protective in some delusional sense
against the fear of death,
but quite the contrary,
the very stories that enabled us to move
forward as confident human beings in the
face of chaos itself and it's
conceivable,
I think perhaps probable that nothing
more important conceptually happened in
the 20th century than that because it
was the first time post enlightenment
that Ab reproachment between the
intellect and the underlying religious
archetipal substructure occurred.
You have in the capacious intellect of
young and the same thing happened to
some degree with piaget.
The religious domain and the factual
domain were brought back together and
the fact of young's enduring and
increasing popularity and influence,
I would say is a direct consequence of
that.
Now.
Some of his work was spun off into the
new age and and the new age is a very
optimistic and naive movement is
predicated on the idea that you can do
nothing say,
but follow your bliss and that will take
you ever hire to enlightenment.
And that's not the union idea at all.
The union idea is that what you most
need will be found where you least want
to look.
So there's this story.
King Arthur,
there's this story of King Arthur,
the.
They're all in a round table,
right?
King Arthur and his knights,
they're equals.
They're all
super ordinary,
but they're all equals and they go off
to look for the holy Grail,
for the holy grail is the container of
the redemptive substance,
whatever that is might be the cop of the
Christ used at the last supper,
might be jealous that was used to
capture his blood on the cross,
right when he was pierced by a sword.
The stories differ,
but that's the holy grail and the holy
grail is lost.
That's the redemptive substance and the
knights of King Arthur go off to search
for the holy grail and but they don't
know where to look.
So where do you look when you don't know
where to look for something you need
desperately,
but I've lost.
Well,
each of the nights goes into the forest
at the point that looks darkest to him,
and that's union psychoanalysis in a
nutshell.
It's like that which you fear and avoid
that which you hold in contempt,
that which disgusts you and that you
avoid.
That's the gateway to what you need to
know.
There's nothing new agey about that.
That's for sure.
Now,
young,
when he started this endeavor,
he started with this.
This is part of the notebooks from the
black book.
He said,
he wrote my soul,
my soul.
Where are you?
Do you hear me?
I speak.
I call you.
Are you there?
I've returned.
I'm here again.
I've shaken the dust of all the lands
from my feet and I've come to you.
I'm with you.
After long years of long wandering,
I have come to you again
for the unions.
The Hero's journey is a journey within
and I think that that's probably the
bias of introverts to believe that the
hero's journey isn't only an inward
journey.
I think that it can be an outward
journey too because I don't think it
matters where you confront the unknown,
whether it's within or without.
What matters is whether or not you
confront the unknown.
That's what matters,
but he found that what he had ignored
was an undiscovered part of themselves,
so that might be something that was
equivalent to Huxley's notion that there
were tremendous.
There's tremendous potential breadth in
the realm of human conscious
experiences.
Huxley was influenced to some degree by
Yung now Yung knew of Huxley's
experiments and had commented on
psychedelic use and he said something
like,
beware of wisdom you did not earn.
And Don was very good.
It's at stating things very profoundly,
very simply,
and that's a very intelligent piece of
advice.
Beware of wisdom you did not earn.
He wrote a paper if you're interested in
this sort of thing.
He wrote a paper called the relations
between the ego and the unconscious,
which is an absolute work but completely
incomprehensible unless you know what
it,
unless you know what it's about and what
it's about is the danger of what he
called ego inflation.
And so one of the things that can happen
as a consequence of a revelatory
experience is that the division between
the individual ego and and the and what
would you call it?
So hard to come up with a word that
isn't somehow naive or or or cliched,
to erase the relationship,
the boundary between the specific
consciousness of the ego and the more
generalized consciousness and more
generalized consciousness as such is a
dangerous thing to do because you can
start to equate yourself,
your specific self with that more
generalized consciousness as such and
you thought about that,
is it something akin to a psychotic
inflation and the paper relations
between the ego and the unconscious is a
document that tells you how to avoid
that.
If you're
playing in this kind of realm and one of
the injunctions is to keep your feet on
the ground.
He thought that was partly what happened
to Nisha was that Nisha wasn't grounded
enough in life.
He wasn't grounded enough in day to day
rituals and routines and the mundane.
Now you can debate whether or not that's
the case.
Whether or not that's a reasonable
argument,
but that was still what you unbelieved.
Okay,
so why am I telling you all this?
I'll finish with this from December 19,
13 onward.
Young carrier going in the same
procedure,
deliberately evoking a fantasy in a
waking state and then entering into it
as a drama.
These fantasies may be understood as a
type of dramatized thinking in pictorial
form.
In retrospect,
he recalled that his scientific question
was to see what took place when he
switched off consciousness.
The example of dreams indicated the
existence of background activity and he
wanted to give this a possibility of
emerging just as one does when taking
masculine.
These journals are contemporary
contemporaneous clinical ledger to his
most difficult experiment or what he
later describes as a voyage of discovery
to the other pole of the world.
You don't believe that we were dreaming
all the time,
but that during waking life,
that pressure of external images was
such that the unconscious fantasy
imagery was or that the fantasy imagery
was of insufficient magnitude to be
conscious,
but that we were always situated in a
dream in relationship to the world.
If you're hungry,
it's not a deterministic drive.
It's a sub personality that has a goal
and that it has a bunch of action
patterns that are going to work in
reference to that goal.
It has a bunch of perceptions that that
suit that goal and it organizes your
emotional responses around that goal.
And so to think about it as a
personality is a much.
It's a much more intelligent way to look
at it.
One of the thing about skinner's rats,
you know,
skinner could get rats to do almost
everything and he would reward them with
food and so he had a simple rat model,
but his rats were starved down to 75
percent of their normal body weight.
So not only were they not social
gregarious rats,
rats are because they were isolated.
They were genetically altered from wild
rats,
but they also weren't as complex as a
real route because they were starving.
And so,
but you know,
starving rat is a pretty good model of a
rat.
And a rat has a pretty good model of a
person,
but are a lot of our models have simple
behavioral learning were based on
starving isolated rats.
So anyways,
how to think about motivation will think
about it from the hypothalamic
perspective.
So we could say one thing that
motivation does is set goals and we
could say that emotions track progress
towards goals,
and I'm going to use that Schema even
though it's not exactly right.
So you say,
well,
motivation determines where you're going
to aim.
So if you're hungry,
you're going to aim at something to eat
and then that will organize your
perceptions so that you zero out
everything that isn't relevant to that
task,
which is almost everything.
You concentrate on those few things that
are going to facilitate your movement
forward.
When you encounter those things that
produces positive emotion,
as you move through the world towards
your goal and you see that things are
laying themselves out that facilitate
your movement forward,
those things caused positive emotion and
if you encounter anything that gets in
the way,
then that produces negative emotion and
it can be like threat because you're not
supposed to encounter something that
gets in the way.
It can be anger so that you move it
away.
It can be frustration,
disappointment,
grief.
Those would,
if you had a response that serious to an
obstacle,
it would probably punish the little
motivated frame right out of existence,
you know,
so you walked downstairs and I dunno,
they're contracting company instead of
wrecking ball through your kitchen,
it's like that's going to be
disappointing.
You're not going to keep eating the
peanut butter sandwich and the rubble,
that little frame is going to get
punished out of existence and some new
goal is going to pop up and its stead
and you know,
one of the things we're going to try to
sort out is how do you decide when
you've encountered an obstacle that's so
big that you should just quit and go do
something else because that's not
obvious,
you know,
and you can,
you can get into counter productive
persistence pretty easily.
So we don't know how people solve that
problem and it's a really complicated
one.
So anyways,
we're gonna work on that scenario.
Your hypothalamus pops up micro goals
that are directly relevant to biological
survival that produces a frame of
reference.
So it's not a goal,
it's not a drive and it's not a
collection of behaviors.
It's a little personality and the
personality has a viewpoint.
It has thoughts that go along with it.
It has perceptions,
it has action tendencies,
all of that.
You can see this in addiction most
particularly,
so one of the things that you find often
with people who are alcoholic is they
lie all the time and that's because when
they're built a little alcohol dependent
personality inside of themselves or a
big one might.
Maybe it's 90 percent of their
personality and one of that.
One of the things that component
consists of is all the rationalizations
that they've used over the years to
justify their addiction to themselves
and to other people.
And so the addiction has a personality,
you know,
and so when the person is off or maybe
they're addicted to meth or something
like that,
where we know the addiction is more.
It's more short term powerful than I
would say,
than an alcohol addiction and they'll
say anything and the the,
the words are just tools used to get
towards the goal and if they happened to
be deceptive,
whatever,
it doesn't matter.
They're just practical tools to get
towards the goal.
And then when you get towards the goal
and you take a nice shot of meth or
something like that,
you reinforce all those rationales that
you use to get the drug and then the
next time you're even a better deceiver
and liar.
So okay,
so we're going to say motivations one
way of thinking about as they set goals,
but it's not the right way of thinking
about it.
They produce a whole framework of
interpretation.
And so we're going to think about that
framework of interpretation and then
emotions emerging side of that.
So that's it.
So the world is framed.
Motivations,
set goals.
You could say the world has to be
framed.
So motivation sets that frame,
cruise goals,
emotions,
perceptions and actions and inactions
track progress.
So positive emotion says you're moving
forward properly towards your goal.
And if you encounter something you don't
expect,
you stop that anxiety.
It's like,
oh,
we're not where we thought we were.
And so we don't know what to do,
so we should stop because we don't know
where we are,
what we're doing.
Stop frozen.
And then the more powerful negative
emotions like pain they might make you
get out of there.
So motions forward,
stop,
reverse.
That's your emotions within that
motivated frame.
So,
and that's another example of how your
mind is embedded in your body.
Your emotions are in like their,
their offshoots of action tendencies.
That's,
that's the right way to think about it
because action has everything
fundamentally.
So what are some basic motivations are
most of these are regulated by the
Hypothalamus,
by the way,
that that tells you just how important
to control system it is.
The other thing that's useful to know
about the hypothalamus is that it has
projections going up from it that are
like tree trunks and inhibitory
projections coming down there.
They're like grape vines.
So you can kind of control your
hypothalamus as long as it's not on too
much,
but if it's on in any serious way,
it's like it.
It winds.
So partly what you do to stop yourself
from falling under the dominion of your
hypothalamus is to never,
ever be anywhere where it's action is
necessary.
Right?
You don't want to go into a biker bar
because you might find yourself in a
situation where panicked.
Defensive aggression is immediately
necessary.
You probably don't want that.
You don't want to panic.
You don't want the terror.
You don't want the frenzied fight.
You don't want any of that.
You don't want to have to run away in
absolute panic,
so you just don't go there.
And then a huge,
a huge part of how we regulate our
emotions is just by never going anywhere
where we have to experience them and so
that has very little to do with internal
inhibitory control and everything to do
with staying where you belong.
So okay,
so basic motivations,
hunger,
thirst,
pain,
pain is not regulated by the
hypothalamus.
That's a different circuit.
Anger slash aggression,
thermo regulation,
panic and escape,
affiliation and care,
sexual desire,
exploration play,
and you can kind of break those in.
You can kind of break those into the
classic Darwinian categories to and say,
well,
there's a set of motivations that go
along with self maintenance.
That'd be your survival,
ingestive and defensive.
See,
I've sort of coded them there.
So the self maintenance,
there's an adjustive set of basic
motivations that go with self
maintenance.
You'd say that's hunger,
thirst.
There's a set of defensive motivations,
pain,
anger,
thermoregulation paddock and escape.
And then there's,
there's motivations that are associated
with reproduction,
affiliation care and sexual desire.
And then I put exploration in place sort
of outside of that.
Uh,
I would say because those two things
serve both of these approximately
equally,
I think the postmodern objection to
meaning is actually wrong.
While we talked about this earlier,
I do believe that there's a transcendent
ethic and I do believe that it touches
on the metaphysical.
I believe it people experienced that
because people are perfectly capable of
having unalterably profound religious
experiences and the naturalistic
materialists don't know what the hell to
do with that.
They have no idea what to do with that.
Say,
well,
it's delusional.
It's like,
well,
hang on a sec.
People who have those experiences appear
to be more successful and healthier.
So when exactly in what manner is that
delusion,
and if you induce it in the lab with
Psilocybin,
for example,
among people who are dying of cancer,
their fear of death goes away.
It's like that's you're going to just
lay of the lay that out there as
delusional or yo the quit smoking,
85 percent success rate with one
mystical experience on suicide,
but produces 85 percent cessation rate
and smoking completely and with a Mtma
ecstasy.
The three treatments with Mtma,
that's what the current research
indicates,
produces a 72 percent cure rate for
intractable posttraumatic stress
disorder.
It's like those are miracle cures and no
one,
and they have to be accompanied by the
mystical experience.
No one knows how to counsel them.
And so there is a transcender yeah.
So it's a very physical thing.
I mean in the case or any of these
things,
right?
You're eating
something,
you're ingesting saying smoking it,
whatever it is,
it's physical,
it's here and now.
But the experience is metaphysical is
metaphor.
Sure.
That's a place where the biological and
the transcendent touch and we don't know
what to make of that.
Well,
that's why psychedelics through our
culture into such a such a flip this
upside down,
no one knew what to do with them.
No,
I mean the Indians retarded psilocybin
as food of the gods for a reason,
and when people have encountered
psychedelic substances throughout human
history,
that's always how they've been
characterized.
Right.
Food of the gods.
It's like be aware of them,
but there they opened the door to the
transcendent and well,
I think the evidence that they are doing
something that's psychedelic substances
are doing something that we seriously
don't understand at all.
Not a bit is overwhelming.
Rick strassman wrote a book on his
experiences giving Dmt to a whole bunch
of people down in.
He was at in Austin.
I think it's stress.
One's a pretty straight scientists,
you know,
he was interested in measuring
psychophysiological responses to the
drugs.
He gives people dmt and they all came
back with the same story.
I was blasted out of my consciousness.
I went,
I met a whole bunch of alien beings.
They were really surprised.
I was there and then I came back and it
was the most real thing that's ever
happened to me,
and straussman would say,
well,
you know,
you had a union architectural
experience,
or it was a dream and they'd say,
you don't understand,
and he got so distraught because of
these continual reports that he had
stopped doing the research.
Yeah.
I'm not making a claim for him for
anything metaphysical here,
but I'm definitely pointing out that
there are undeniable realms of human
experience that involve religious
experience and a sense of the infinite
transcendent that looked like they're
healthy and that you cannot deny.
So you see on the left hand side there
you see horace,
who is the bird headed god of Egypt,
who I told you about,
who represents the capacity to pay
attention.
Very important concept because the
Egyptians realized in really it's
brilliant.
There's something modern people do not
understand because we tend to make
rationality the highest God.
That's not a good thing.
That's a pathway to totalitarianism.
What the Egyptians knew,
but they only knew it in symbolic form
was it was the capacity to attend to
things that in some sense was the
highest psychological function because
it's the capacity to pay attention that
actually moves you beyond what you only
know and rationality tends to make you
know,
integral systems that are coherent,
that are box like and then claim that
they're absolutely right.
Whereas attention is always looking
beyond what you know and and attention
is an unbelievably powerful force.
You know,
that's why advertisers pay for
it.
That's why people demand it.
That's why children can't live without
it.
That's why it's what you want from your
friends and your family.
You want them to pay attention to you.
It's an unbelievably valuable resource.
And so one of the things I always tell
my clients,
for example,
if they're socially anxious,
I say,
look,
pay more attention to the person you're
talking to.
If you pay,
if you really pay close attention to
them than the thoughts that are making
you anxious will be suppressed.
And because you're paying close
attention to them,
you'll match your movements to theirs
and you'll match your conversation to
them and then there's no reason for you
to be socially anxious because socially
anxious people will go like this when
they're talking,
you know,
they don't want to look at you.
Of course,
how the hell can you engage anyone if
you're not in a little dance with them,
you know,
you can't.
And a lot of it's nonverbal,
it's physical and it's embodied and
without paying attention.
Then you lose people and you see this
with speakers all the time.
Cue there in front of audiences.
They have their paper and they're going
like this.
And usually they're talking like this
too.
And you know,
the logical thing to do in that case is
like,
look at facebook or get the hell out of
there something.
But they're not paying attention to the
audience.
And so there's no power in the.
There's no power in the dynamic
conversation at all.
One of the experiences that I had
when I was a 1985 or thereabouts when I
was working on the first draft of my
book maps of meaning where I was
outlining this idea that the path of the
hero who voluntarily confronts
uncertainty and stands on the border
between chaos and order,
the appropriate target for human
development.
It's,
it's an alternative to the chaos of
nihilism and totalitarianism of rigid
belief.
Yes.
So,
and that's the bearing of responsibility
for being.
I was working all of that out.
It's actually announced it to the post
modern conundrum as far as I can tell as
well.
But,
but anyways,
at the same time I was making this
sculpture,
which is about a foot thick.
It's made out of layers of,
of what's called foam core,
which is styrofoam press between two
pieces of paper.
That's about a quarter of an inch thick.
And so often used for backing on,
on,
uh,
on prints and so on.
If you get them framed,
I made this,
this piece that I called the meaning of
music and it's a Mandela.
So it's a circle inscribed inside of the
square.
Although I tried to make it
multidimensional in a complex way that I
can't really describe at the moment,
but what I was trying to do and I broke
it into pieces of what I was trying to
do was to produce a visual,
a object that flickered and changed when
you looked at it because it was too
complex to process visually.
You know,
like a necker cube.
That's one of those cubes that reversed
is when you look at it.
Yeah.
Well this is like a necker cube on
steroids
because music of course it stays the
same across time,
but also transform across time and it's
full of layered patterns,
you know,
and the patterns interact harmoniously
with one another.
And it had appeared and I was fascinated
by music because it gives people the
direct intimation of meaning.
Even if they're nihilistic punk rockers,
they still can't criticize the
experience of meaning that they,
that they,
that they engage in when they're
listening to their favorite band and it
helps them transcend the denialism of
rationality.
And if you can't argue with it,
it's like arguing with dance beyond
argument.
And so I was making this,
this sculpture,
and I spent like four months on it.
I was thinking about it a lot and I got
it mostly assembled and then I was in my
living room in Montreal and I was
listening to Mozart Symphony,
the Jupiter symphony,
and I was really listening to it and
it's one of these complex Lee multilevel
pattern pattern pieces of auditory
sculpture that I believe represents
being because what being is is multiple
levels of patterned transformation
interact and simultaneously and music is
a representation of that,
which is why people find a meaningful.
Anyways.
I was listening intently to this
symphony and at the same time I was
concentrating on the sculpture that I
have made.
All of a sudden,
everything I'm about to say is a
metaphor because.
Because there's no way of encapsulating
it properly in words,
but it was as if the heavens opened up
above.
I mean I was still in my living room,
but yes,
it reminds me.
Experience is best represented by one of
those early renaissance paintings where
you see God or Christ up in the sky with
an opening in the sky against the clouds
and against the sun,
so it was like that even though I didn't
really see that,
but it felt like that and there was some
visuals that were associated with it and
I felt something descend upon me that it
had a personal nature,
you know,
something like what you were describing
as a higher consciousness that was
actually a being of a sort and it failed
me from the inside out and I had the and
it was.
It was enrapturing,
let's say,
and it was an incredible feeling.
It was a divine feeling,
I suppose is the right way of thinking
about it.
Certainly a religious experience.
I was an it transform me and turned me
into something far more than I than I
normally was and maybe you can take them
out that as an intimation of what you
could become if you worked on it for the
rest of your life.
Sometimes I think hallucinogens
providing people with an image of who
they could be a shared goal,
them,
they're dead wood,
right.
Anyways,
it was as if an offer is being made to
me that I could be like that from now on
permanently.
Well,
I don't know how to do that.
I couldn't walk down the street in this
condition,
in this elevated condition.
I wouldn't belong in the world anymore.
I,
I wouldn't.
I wouldn't know how to function.
I don't know how I could do it and stole
the experience.
This thing say that was communicating
with me was accepted that as an answer,
although I would say with some sort of
it.
And then I went and talked to my waist
and I told her what had happened and I
was shaking a lot and like a tremendous
amount and my pupils were completely
dilated.
Wow.
Yeah.
And that happened to me one other time
in a similar manner,
although it's more like an echo.
It wasn't quite as intense,
but you know,
I was concentrating very much on trying
to understand the meaning,
the central meaning of music and of
course this phenomena of meaning itself
and it seemed like the combination of
that intense concentration and the
visual stimulation and the music all
culminated to produce this
transformation of consciousness.
But that was,
that was its nature.
I haven't either.
Miscarry mushrooms are often buy,
buy mushrooms,
like silicide,
but yes,
those substances are to call them
strange is barely to scrape the surface.
Have you,
have you taken psychedelics?
Yes,
I have.
Um,
and yeah,
so it sounds like it because.
Exactly,
yes.
You're right there.
It's such a,
it's an,
it's this straight.
It's the strangest of things.
And,
and when it comes to identity in the
psychedelics affect on human identity,
uh,
it does create an experience that is
transcendent to the very temporary human
form that we're currently within.
Yes.
Well,
there's a psychiatrist named Rick
Strassman.
Yes.
Was at the University of Texas and he
had been giving his experimental
subjects.
He's one of two groups that have got
permission to start experimenting with
psychedelics.
Again,
the other one was a group at Johns
Hopkins who have been recording,
um,
the consequences of giving experimental
subjects a suicide than yes,
in a,
in its chemical form they report,
they've reported,
um,
permanent personality transformations on
the part of their,
of the people who took the psilocybin
mushrooms who had a experience.
And so what's happened to them apart
from the fact that they regarded the
experience as one of the top two or
three experiences of their life in terms
of transformation,
is that when you give them personality
tests a year later,
these are five factor personality tests
and they test extroversion,
neuroticism,
agreeableness,
conscientiousness and openness and
openness is a creativity dimension,
an aesthetic experience,
creativity,
dimension,
and their scores on openness increased
substantially approximately the
equivalent from the 50th percentile to
the 85th percentile,
which is one standard deviation.
They increase and stay that way up to
one year later.
So these,
these,
these chemicals,
these strange chemicals produced very
long lasting effects on people's
perception and they do produce
intimations of mystical experience.
Now,
strassman actually got scared away from
his DMT research.
Um,
he was a pretty,
I would say,
conservative scientist and was
administering dmt intravenously because
it has a very short half life if you
take it any other way.
It only lasts about 10 minutes and his
people every and who were very carefully
screened to begin with for sanity and so
forth.
Although they have some experience with
psychedelic drugs because they didn't
want to introduce naive people to,
to anything like that.
They all reported being shot out of
their body and encountering alien
beings,
all of them.
And they,
you know,
when straussman attempted to explain
that away as a,
well,
let's call it a hallucination.
Although technically if you're
hallucinating,
you know that you're hallucinating and
you know what's real.
So these were far deeper than
hallucination,
right?
Or that they were something like young
Ian Archetypes,
but his subjects insisted that including
people who knew quite a bit about
archetipal psychology insisted that that
was not correct,
that they were in fact shot out of their
bodies into other spaces and dimensions
and that they encountered beings of all
sorts of different types.
Some of whom were surprised to see them.
Some of whom were happy they were there,
some of whom engaged them in
conversation.
Um,
I mean it makes very strange reading it
and it,
it.
There's no straightforward may way of
making sense of it and there's no
straightforward way of making sense of
the shamanic experiences to Eliana
thought that,
that those,
those rituals have been if,
if they were induced by drugs,
that that was a corrupt form of the
original ritual,
but I think later scholarship is
indicated that that's profoundly wrong
and that's the basis of these
experiences is in fact hallucinogenic
experience of the sort say that the
aztecs induced with siliciden mushrooms
or masculine.
The first thing I'll do is tell you a
story about
female neurologist whose name escapes me
at the moment.
She wrote a book called my stroke of
insight.
Jill bolty I think is her name and she
was a harvard trained.
She was,
she had,
she had medical training from Harvard in
neuropsychological function and knew a
lot about hemispheric specialization.
We talked a little bit about hemispheric
specialization before and one of the
ways of conceptualizing the difference
between the two hemispheres is that the
left hemisphere operates in known
territory and the right hemisphere
operates in unknown territory.
That's one way of thinking about or the
left hemisphere operates in the orderly
domain.
In the right hemisphere,
operates in the chaotic domain or the
left hemisphere operates in the domain
of detail,
and the right hemisphere operates in the
domain of the large picture.
It's something like that.
Now people differ in their neurological
wiring,
so those are over generalizations,
but that's okay.
We're.
We'll live with that for the time being.
It's certainly not an overgeneralization
to point out that you do in fact have
two hemispheres and that their
structures differ and if the connections
between the market,
which could happen,
for example,
if you had surgery for intractable
epilepsy,
that each hemisphere would be capable of
housing its own consciousness that's
been well documented by a neuro neuro
neurologist named Monica who did and
Sperry who did split brain experiments
must be 30 years ago now.
So,
and we know that the right and the left
hemisphere are specialized for different
functions.
The Right Hemisphere,
for example,
seems to be more involved in
degeneration of negative emotion and the
left hemisphere more involved in the
generation of positive emotion and
approach.
So the right hemisphere stops you in the
left hemisphere,
moves you forward.
Anyways,
Jill Bolty,
I hope I've got that right,
had a stroke and maintained
consciousness during the stroke and
analyzed it while it was happening and
she was able.
Well,
it was happening to hypothesize about
what part of her brain was being
destroyed and so she had a congenital
blood vessel malformation and had an
aneurysm and it just about killed her,
but she said that it effected her left
hemisphere and she said that she
experienced a sense of divine unity as a
consequence of the stroke because the
left hemisphere function was disrupted
and destroyed and so she became a right
hemisphere dominant and her experience
of that was the dissolution of the
specific ego into the,
into absolute consciousness,
something like that.
Now that's only a case study and you
don't want to make too much of studies,
but there is an overwhelming amount of
evidence that those two kinds of
consciousness exist.
One being your consciousness of you as a
localized and specified being and the
other being this capacity to experience
oceanic disillusion and the sense of the
cosmos being one.
Now why we have those capacities for
different conscious experiences is very
difficult to understand.
I mean,
part of me thinks that maybe we have a
generic human brain that's the brain of
the species and allied with that we have
a specific individual brain and one is
the left hemisphere and the other is the
right hemisphere,
the left hemisphere of being the
specific individual brain and usually
it's on and working because you
obviously have to take care of yourself
as a specific entity and not as a
generalized cosmic phenomena.
It's hard to dice salary when you're a
generalized cosmic phenomena,
right?
So you have to be more pointed than
that,
but,
but look,
let's make no mistake about it.
The fact that those different states of
consciousness exist is not disputable.
They can be elicited in all sorts of
ways,
and so I'm going to read you something
that Elvis Huxley wrote about this back,
I think in 1956.
This was after he
started his experimentation with
masculine because the psychedelics were
introduced into Western culture in the
19 fifties and a whole bunch of
different ways.
So as I've been mushrooms,
LSD was discovered right after the end
of World War II was discovered by
accident,
actually laboratory sandow was labs.
The guy who discovered it,
Albert Hoffman had spilled some on his
hands.
You can absorb it through your skin,
and he was biking home and had the
world's first LSD trip,
which was somewhat of a shock to him and
then to the entire world.
Huxley,
who was a great literary figure,
a real genius,
experimented with Mescaline in the late
fifties and he wrote a book called the
doors of perception,
which had a huge impact on the emerging
psychedelic culture,
both on the east coast,
it at Harvard and on the West Coast with
Ken Keasy and is Mary Pranksters.
The people who popularized lsd.
That's all documented in a book called
the electric koolaid acid test,
which I would highly recommend.
It's Tom Wolfe.
It's brilliant book.
I'm on the east coast.
It was timothy leary.
I had timothy leary's old job at
Harvard,
so that was kind of cool,
you know,
warped way,
so I met people there who knew him,
who didn't think much of them also,
but who did know him,
but Huxley had this masculine experience
and it transported him to this
alternative consciousness and he said
that during his masculine experience,
the entire world glowed from within.
Like if there was an inner light like a
paradise inner light,
and then everything was deeply
meaningful and symbolically suggestive
and overwhelming and beautiful and
timeless,
so he had an experience of divine
eternity,
I suppose is the most straightforward
way to to put that,
and we know perfectly well that the
psychedelic drugs that all share the
same chemical structure,
they interact with the brain chemical
called Serotonin,
which is a very,
very fundamental neurotransmitter.
They all have approximately the same
range of effects,
although those effects are very.
There's a very large multitude of
effects that sort of exist underneath
that umbrella.
Huxley was
staggered by his masculine experience.
He,
he didn't really know what to make of it
and I think that that's the common
experience of people who have
exceptionally profound psychedelic
experiences,
and I'll,
I'll,
I'll tell you some documentation about
that in a moment,
but he spent quite a long time trying to
come to grips with what this might mean
from an intellectual perspective and in
Huxley had a great brain.
I mean,
if someone was going to wrestle with a
problem like that,
he was a good candidate.
He must've had a verbal Iq of 180.
I mean he's.
His books are incredibly literate,
incredible credible,
mastery of language and complexity of
characterization and intellectual
discourse.
Really remarkable.
So this is what Huxley actually had to
say after his masculine experience.
He talked about heaven and hell and he
talked about that in reference to bad
trips,
essentially because it was known by that
point that a psychedelic experience
could transport you to an ecstatic
domain of divine revelation,
but could take you to the worst
imaginable place as well,
and Huxley was very interested in why
you would even have the capacity for
experiences like that and which I think
is a very good question and it's
completely unanswered question.
I mean,
we don't know much about consciousness
and we know even less about
psychedelics.
I would say they are an absolute
mystery.
I don't think we understand them in the
least.
Huxley did a good job of starting to at
least map out the mysteries of the
terrain.
He said like the earth of 100 years ago,
our minds still has its darkest
Africa's.
It's unmapped,
Borneo and Amazonian Basin in relation
to the fauna of these regions.
We are not yet zoologists.
We are mere naturalists and collectors
of specimens.
The fact is unfortunate,
but we have to accept it.
We have to make the best of it.
However,
lowly the work of the collector must be
done before we can proceed to the higher
scientific tasks of classification,
analysis,
experiment and theory making like the
giraffe and the duck billed.
Platypus.
The creatures inhabiting these remoter
regions of the mind are exceedingly
improbable.
Nevertheless,
they exist.
They're facts of observation,
and as such,
they cannot be ignored by anyone who was
honestly trying to understand the world
in which he lives.
When psychiatrist started to study lsd
that was mostly in the late fifties and
running forward from that,
they thought about the drug as a
psychotomimetic,
which was a chemical substance that
would induce psychosis,
but that turned out to not be true,
not with the psychedelics because
schizophrenia were given lsd and the
schizophrenia reported that while the
experience experience was certainly
extraordinarily strange,
it wasn't like being schizophrenia and
then it was found later that if you gave
schizophrenia amphetamines,
that made them worse.
In fact,
you can induce a paranoid psychosis in a
normal person by overdosing them with
amphetamines,
so whatever the hallucinogens or
psychedelics are doing,
it's not the same thing as mania and
it's not the same thing as
schizophrenia,
not at all,
so,
so you can't just write the experience
off as an induced psychosis,
whatever it is,
independent of its utility or lack
thereof.
It's not that
now it can be induced by drugs can be
induced by deprivation,
right?
I mean there are accounts throughout
history of people putting themselves in
extreme physiological situations in
order to induce transformations of
consciousness.
Fasting is one of the routes to doing
that.
Dancing is another root.
Isolation.
Prolonged periods of isolation will also
do it.
Now you could say that exposing yourself
to any of those in excess produces a
state that's in distinguishable from
illness and that there's no reason to
assume that the phenomena that are
associated with illness have any utility
whatsoever.
Although it's interesting to me that
a disrupted consciousness can produce
coherent experiences.
It's not exactly what you expected was
just an illness.
You know,
if you develop,
say,
a high fever,
your experience isn't transcendent and
coherent.
It's fragmented and pathologized and and
the difference I think is quite
distinct,
although we don't only have to only
speculate about that because there's
been enough experimental work done now
with with hallucinogens psychedelics to
indicate that the notion that what they
produce is something that's only akin to
pathology is wrong because it's not a
matter of opinion at this point in the
sequence of scientific and historical
investigation.
In fact,
there was a large scale study done 10
years ago,
five years ago,
of 200,000 people who had experimented
with psychedelics and they were mentally
and physically healthier than people who
hadn't on virtually every parameter.
They examined,
in fact the rate of flashbacks.
You've heard of LSD flashbacks,
that mostly a hypothetical phenomena,
but the rate of self reported flashbacks
was higher among the non psychedelic
users that among the psychedelic users,
so that was very interesting.
It was a huge study.
Now,
it might be,
you could say that those who had
experimented with psychedelics were
prone to be healthier to begin with,
but that still contradicts the pathology
argument,
so it doesn't matter either way.
The pathology argument is contradicted
now.
Oh,
I did put that in.
It was Dr Jill,
Jill Bolte Taylor.
This is what she said about her stroke.
I remember that first day of the stroke
with terrific,
bitter sweetness in the absence of the
normal functioning of my left
Orientation Association area.
My perception of my physical boundaries
was no longer limited to where my skin
met air.
I felt like a genie liberated from its
bottle.
It's a good metaphor.
The energy of my spirits seemed to flow
like a great whale gliding through a sea
of silent euphoria.
The absence of physical boundary was one
of glorious bliss.
Recently is Dr Roland Griffith.
I met him once at a conference in San
Francisco.
Surprise,
surprise,
a conference on awe,
and this was just when he was embarking
on his experiments with Psilocybin,
which were the first experiments on
hallucinogens that were permitted by the
National Institute of Mental Health in
some three,
four decades.
He,
he had to be very careful to lay out the
scientific protocols so that the ethics
committees would approve the experiments
and so that the federal funding agencies
would also allow the experiments to go
through.
He started to experiment with psilocybin
and he's found a number of published,
a number of very interesting results.
One was that a single siliciden trip and
I specified trip because sometimes when
people take psilocybin out,
the doses that griffith uses,
they don't have a psychedelic
experience.
Most people who take the dose do but not
everyone.
Those who take the dos and don't have
the mystical experience don't experience
the consequences of taking the drug and
the consequences can be quite profound.
So one consequence is that if you have
the mystical experience that's
associated with suicide and ingestion,
you're liable to represent that to
others and yourself.
One of the two or three most important
experiences of your entire life,
so that would be at the same level as
the birth of your child or your
marriage,
let's say assuming that those were
transcendent experiences,
but,
but that's.
But that's how people describe them.
So that's very interesting in and of
itself.
Then the next thing that griffith,
another thing that Griffith report,
it was that one year after a silicide
been dose a single psilocybin dose
profound enough to induce a mystical
experience.
That trait openness of the participants
had increased one standard deviation,
which is a tremendous amount,
and so it looked like one dose produced
a permanent neurological and
psychological transformation.
Now I'm not saying that that's a good
thing.
I'm not saying that because I don't
think that openness is a n
troubled blessing,
but it's certainly a testament to the
unbelievable potency of the,
of the drugs.
There's about a 10 percent chance,
by the way,
with suicide ingestion of a trip to
hell.
And so that's certainly something very
much worth considering when you're
thinking about the potential effects of,
of this kind of experience.
So the mystical experience produced by
Psilocybin is rated by people as the
most profound,
among the most profound experience of
their life as life changing.
It produces permanent personality
transformations.
80 five percent success in smoking
cessation with a single dose,
right?
That's another thing that griffiths
demonstrated.
Now that is mind boggling because there
are chemical treatments for smoking
cessation.
Buproprion is one.
It reduces craving to some degree,
but it's success rate is nowhere near 85
percent,
certainly not with a single dose,
and so we don't understand how it can be
that that occurs,
but it's nicely documented by Griffith
team in this experiment he gave suicide,
been to people who are dying of cancer.
Cancer patients often develop chronic
clinically significant symptoms of
depression and anxiety.
Previous study suggested Siliciden may
decrease depression and anxiety and
cancer patients.
Aldous Huxley took Lsd on his death bed
by the way.
So the idea that there was something
about psychedelic substances that could
buffer people against the catastrophes
of mortality is an idea that's as old as
experimentation with the drug itself.
The effects of Psilocybin were studied
in 51 cancer patients with life
threatening diagnosis and symptoms of
depression and slash or anxiety.
Unsurprisingly,
I don't really know if it's reasonable
to describe the emotional state of
people diagnosed with cancer of
uncertain prognosis or mortal
significance as depression.
Precisely.
You know,
you know what I mean is that if you go
to the doctor and he tells you that you
have intractable fatal cancer,
the normative response is to be rather
upset and anxious about that and so it.
One of the things that bothers me about
clinical psychiatry and clinical
psychology is the automatic
presupposition that even overwhelming
states of negative emotion are properly
categorized as depression because I
don't think you're depressed when you
get a cancer diagnosis.
I don't think that's the right way to
think about it.
I think that you have a big problem and
it's not surprising that you're
overwhelmed by negative emotion and to
think about that as a psychiatric
malfunction is a major error,
but anyways,
it's a side issue.
With regards to this study.
The effects of Psilocybin were studied
in 51 cancer patients with life
threatening diagnosis and symptoms of
depression and slash or anxiety.
I cannot imagine how they got this
through an ethics committee.
It's just we're going to take people who
have uncertain diagnosis of cancer that
are potentially life threatening and
we're going to give them psychedelics.
It's like,
but they did it.
They did it and I think it's a testament
to griffiths stature as a researcher
that that that was allowable.
This was a randomized double blind
crossover trial,
very carefully designed clinical
investigation.
People were assigned to the treatment
group or the drug group or the non drug
group randomly blindly and investigated
the effects of the drug also with
different doses,
which is another hallmark of a well
designed pharmacological study,
very low placebo like dos one or three
milligrams per 70 kilograms of body
weight versus a high dose 22 or 30
milligrams per 70 kilograms of of
psilocybin chemical suicide,
but administered in counterbalance
sequence with five weeks between
sessions in a six month followup.
Instruction to participants and staff
minimized the effects of expectancy
participants,
staff,
and community observers.
Rated participant moods,
attitudes and behaviors throughout the
study,
and it's also the hallmark of a well
designed study because they didn't rely
on a single source of information for
the outcome data,
right?
They got self-reports,
that's fine,
but they had relatively objective
observers also gather data at the same
time,
high dose psilocybin produced large
decreases in clinician and self related
measures of depressed mood and anxiety
along with increases in quality of life,
life meaning and optimism and decreases
in death,
anxiety,
and that's an interesting.
It's a subtle and scientifically spar
statement,
but it's a very interesting one.
It was the.
There's A.
There's an intimation of a causal
relationship,
increases in quality of life,
life meaning and decreases in death,
anxiety.
I mean the intimation there is that one
of the ways of decreasing your anxiety
about death is to increase the felt
meaning in your life and the psilocybin
dose just potentiate that,
but it's a good thing to know in a
general manner if it happens to be a
generalizable truth,
right?
If you're terrified of mortality,
terrified of vulnerability,
there's always the possibility that the
life path that you're following isn't
rich enough to buffer you against the
negative element of existence.
It's a reasonable hypothesis and an
optimistic one.
I think although a difficult one at six
month followup,
these changes were sustained with about
80 percent of participants continuing to
show clinically significant decreases in
depressed mood and anxiety.
Stephen Ross commenting about this,
he was a co investigator,
said it is simply unprecedented in
psychiatry that a single dose of a
medicine produces these kinds of
dramatic and enduring results,
right?
Which means we have no idea why this
happens.
Participants in attributed improvements
and attitudes about life slash self,
mood,
relationships,
and spirituality to the high dose
experience with more than 80 percent
endorsing moderately or greater,
increased wellbeing and life
satisfaction.
Community observers showed corresponding
changes.
Mystical type Silas psilocybin
experience on session day mediated the
effect of Psilocybin dose on therapeutic
outcomes.
What that means is that,
well,
when researchers were trying to look at
a causal relationship between drug
ingestion and the positive outcome,
the causal relationship was drug
ingestion,
mystical experience,
positive outcome.
It wasn't drug ingestion,
There had to be the experience produced
by the pharmaceutical agent in order for
the pharmaceutical agent to have had its
effect.
Now we don't.
Again,
we don't know why that is either.
Maybe some people needed a higher dose.
Who knows because people vary
tremendously in their sensitivity to
pharmaceutical substances.
Now,
why am I telling you all this?
Well,
I'm telling you for a variety of
reasons.
One is the first is make no mistake
about it.
Human beings have the capacity for forms
of consciousness that are radically
unlike our normative forms of
consciousness and the evidence that
those alternative forms of consciousness
are purely pathological,
which is the simplest explanation,
right?
You perturb the system,
produces pathology that's negative.
That is the simplest explanation.
The evidence for that is weak at best,
leaving out the bad trip issue,
which which is non trivial.
The empirical evidence as it accrues in
fact seems to suggest that the
consequence of mystical,
positive mystical associated with
psychedelic intake is overwhelmingly
positive.
Even in extreme situations and you
really can't find a more extreme
situation than uncertain cancer
diagnosis with concomitant time and
depression and anxiety.
Like.
I mean that's not as bad as it gets,
but it gets kind of in the ballpark.
And so the fact that even under
circumstances like that,
there was the overwhelming probability
that the experience would be positive
because that's another thing you
wouldn't expect.
You know,
even from some of the earlier earliest
discussions about psychedelic use that
were put forth by people,
including Timothy leary describing the
importance of sat right so that the
early experimenters noted that if you
had a psychedelic experience and you
were in a bad state or in a bad place,
that that was one of the precursors to a
bad trip.
That the negative emotion that you
entered the experience with could be
magnified tremendously by the,
by the chemical substances.
So that it was necessary to be somewhere
safe to be around people that you trust,
to be in a familiar environment,
to get all the variables that you could
control under control,
but here's the situation where that
isn't what's happening at all because
people have this cancer diagnosis of
cancer diagnosis of unspecified outcome,
and they still,
the vast majority of them had a positive
experience and the positive experience
experience had long lasting positive
consequences.
So,
so the case that the transcendent
experience is not real,
that's wrong.
It's real.
Now we don't know what that means
because it actually challenges to some
degree our concepts of what constitutes
real,
but it's certainly well within the realm
of normative human experience.
So it's part of the human capacity.
And you know,
there there's been other neurological
experiments to.
There's,
there's a researcher,
Canadian researcher,
if I remember correctly,
who invented something.
He called the God helmet and it used
electromagnetic stimulation,
brain stimulation to induce mystical
experiences.
Now,
I don't remember what part of the brain
he was shutting off or activating with
that particular gadget,
but
and you know there's,
there's,
there's all,
there's all sorts of other indications
of this sort of thing that have cropped
up in other domains of the neurological
literature.
For example.
It's very common for people who are
epileptic to have religious experiences
as part of the prodromal to the actual
seizure.
That was the case with Dostoevsky,
for example,
who had incredibly intense religious
experiences that would culminate in
epileptic seizure and he said that they
were of sufficient quality that he would
give up his whole life to have had the.
And the funny thing too is that in my
reading of Dostoevsky at least is that I
think that epileptic seizures and the
associated mystical were part of what
made him a transcendently brilliant
author.
I don't think that he would have broken
through into the domains of insight that
he possessed without those strange
neurological experiences.
And it was certainly not the case that
his epilepsy or the experiences that
were associated with it produced.
What you might describe as an impairment
in his cognitive function is quite the
contrary.
At least that's how it looks to me.
This is a critical issue with regards to
the harmonic transformation,
is that people go through these
terrible,
terrible experiences,
often drug induced by the way,
with regards to the Sharman,
they usually use psychedelic chemicals
of one form or another,
often mushrooms,
but what they've come up with some very
strange concoctions like Iowasca down in
the Amazon and Iowasca has an amazing
substance.
It's made out of the bark of one thing
and another plant whose name I don't
remember that hardly even grow in the
same place and that has to be cooked
together in a special way and no one has
any idea how the damn Amazonians figured
that out.
It looks impossible.
And if you ask them,
they say,
well,
the plants told us how to do it,
which was western people don't find very
helpful,
but the shamans are perfectly healthy,
happy with that description.
And IOWASCA takes them apart.
And it does that in part because it
affects the serotonergic system very,
very powerfully,
like all psychedelics do and it
transports them to another world and
that's how they interpreted and,
and,
and what we know about psychedelics,
you could put in a thimble and then
throw the thimble away.
We know nothing about psychedelics.
There's new experiments going on at
Johns Hopkins,
for example,
with silicide button,
which is part of this active chemical in
magic mushrooms.
Same structure basically as LSD and
masculine and all the real psychedelics
have basically the same structure except
the one that's derived from am Anita
must scarier,
which is called muscular acid.
And it's a,
it's its own weird thing that no one
knows anything about.
Anyways,
they have profound neurochemical effects
in very small doses.
And I'm the research group at Johns
Hopkins has given Psilocybin to research
subjects,
you know,
purified psilocybin because they started
the new experimentation with
psychedelics in that's been banned for
like 40 years because psychedelics were
so terrifying to our culture that we
just put them away.
And it's like,
oh no,
we're not going there.
And so even from a research perspective,
and even though some of the psychedelics
look very promising for the treatment of
disorders like alcoholism,
they recently used silicide going to
help people stop smoking down at Johns
Hopkins and I think they had an 80
percent success rate,
which is just like,
that's just absolutely mind boggling and
so.
But if you give people psilocybin and
they have a mystical experience,
which is very common among people who
take these sorts of chemicals,
then their personality transforms
permanently such that one year later
they're one standard higher in openness
and openness is the creativity
dimension.
And that seems to be a permanent
transformation.
And so that's really remarkable.
And about 80 percent of the people who
undergo the Johns Hopkins Experiments
report that the experience is like one
of the two or three most important
things they've ever.
That's never ever happened to them.
And so.
Well that's,
that's something,
you know,
it's like.
And then there's this guy named Rick
strassman down at,
I think he was at the University of
Texas and he did experimentation with
DMT,
dmt,
dimethyltryptamine I remember,
if I remember correctly,
is the active ingredient in Iowasca and
you produce it in your brain and it's in
plants.
It's a very common chemical.
But DMT is a weird hallucinogen because
it has an extraordinary short mechanism
of action.
It's like,
and people who take it report that
they're blasted out of their body,
like out of a cannon.
And then they go out somewhere and
encounter beings of various sorts.
And then 10 minutes later they're back
and virtually everyone reports that,
which is really strange.
And,
and so straussman was giving people dmt
intravenously so that the trip would
last longer.
He get,
this was all,
all,
you know,
nih funded,
uh,
experimentation all cleared with the
relevant ethics boards all conducted
within the last 10 years.
He basically quit doing it because he
was a pretty straight scientists,
you know,
he was measuring heart rate and pulse
and all that sort of thing.
Trying to look at the physiology and
then the people he was giving these
chemicals to kept coming back and
telling him these,
these crazy stories.
And uh,
well I just,
it was too much for them,
you know,
and no wonder,
because they all said the same thing.
And he'd say,
well,
that was a dream.
And they'd say no.
And it was the most real thing that ever
happened to me.
And he'd say,
well,
you know,
it's an archetypal experience.
And they'd say,
no,
that was no archetipal experience.
I went somewhere else and I saw things
and I'm back and I don't care what you
think and like,
who the hell knows,
right?
Because it's all subjective.
But,
but the weird thing about it is that
everyone's reporting the same thing.
How the hell do you account for that?
And then the shaman,
you know,
when they take these psychedelic
chemicals,
they basically say the same thing.
They say,
well first of all,
it more or less killed me.
That's this.
No,
I dissolved to skeleton.
And then I climbed a tree that Unites
Heaven and earth and I went into the
realm of the gods and they gave me some
information and I'm back.
It's like,
okay,
well,
you know,
we don't really know what to make of
that.
And we certainly,
that's what len describes when he
describes the shamanic is traumatic
procession,
not the shamanic initiation and you
know,
there's dissolution to a skeleton first
and then like a death,
the symbolic death or experienced as an
actual death and then bang up into the
realm of the gods and then they come
back.
It's a very old idea.
And that's a medieval representation.
The tunnel that people travel through at
the end of their life to,
you know,
to find the light,
which is a very common near death
experience report.
And people don't have any idea what the
hell to do with those reports except
say,
well,
it's the paroxysms of the dying brain,
which you'd expect to be a hell of a lot
more random in my opinion.
And the idea is there's a rebirth after
that.
And you know,
here,
this is the Scandinavian representation
of that tree that unites Earth with
heaven.
And so there's the Scandinavian
representation.
It has a snake snakes down here eating
it.
And then that's the Amazonian
representation.
It's like,
how the hell do you account for that?
We know those pictures are so similar
that it's just,
it's beyond belief.
Well,
you know,
we lived in trees for a long time,
a long,
long,
long time,
millions of years,
and there were lots of snakes around
them.
And so the idea that reality is a tree
that's surrounded by a snake that's in
us,
man,
it's down there,
it's deep.
And there's something about it that's
true,
not true,
like we normally think of truth,
but truth true in an entirely different
manner.
So and all that's pretty damn strange.
We'll stop with this.
My son drew this when he was seven years
old.
Blew me away,
man.
I thought it was so cool.
So I had it laminated.
And so here is what it is on the right
hand side,
that's the order.
It's like the Yin Yang thing that's
order left side chaos,
right?
And those are all mushroom houses,
which I thought was amazing.
And then there's this river that runs
right down the middle,
like the line for order and chaos.
And then there's this tree that goes up
to heaven and that's having up there.
It's like their St Peter.
There's the pearly gates,
there's the cloud.
It's like he never went to church,
you know,
it's like what the hell?
And then there's a little bug there that
goes up and down from heaven to earth.
And that was him.
And I thought he had a very organized
psyche.
That kid.
He was very,
very stable kid.
And still listen who drew that?
And I thought,
Jesus,
that's just bloody well unbelievable.
And I still think that when I look at
it,
and that's a great example of an
archetype.
And so we'll see you Tuesday.
Sure.
I'm going to read something wrote
in the first part beyond good and evil,
which is a section called the prejudices
of philosophers.
And it's a really good example of the
density of this book.
One of the ways of conceptualizing
beyond good and evil.
And I think this is true for most great
works of
it's true most works is that
the
author of the work
collects unconsciously collect patterns
from his or her interaction with the
world and then gives them initial
formulation
and the patterns can be deep and
multilevel and the initial formulation
translates them into not so much ideas
as into the seeds of future ideas and
the more poetically arthur happens to be
the more the case that his or her
ratings contained within it.
The seeds of future ideas and where the
romantic philosophers are.
Authors and I think Nietzsche and
Dostoevsky or or in some sense foremost
among them are particularly notable.
Further ability to do exactly that.
Now in this particular paragraph,
just particular paragraph not only
serves as an example of that,
but it also serves as a self conscious
reflection on that because Nietzsche is
writing a paragraph here that is full of
the seeds of ideas that will actually
bloom flower to a great degree in the
20th century.
But while he's simultaneously revealing
these,
those ideas,
he's also telling you exactly how he's
doing it and how it is that philosophers
do it.
So it source.
It's a spectacular accomplishment.
I'm going to read it,
probably phrase by phrase and then take
it apart because it's so dance and
beyond good and evil is like that.
It's neat.
You,
when Nisha was writing beyond good and
evil,
he wasn't very well.
And because of that he had to spend a
lot of time thinking and not very much
time writing.
And because he was also brilliant beyond
comprehension,
his ability to distill what he was
thinking into incredibly rich phrases
this.
And I think at some sense it's beyond
parallel.
Mean often if I'm reading a book,
if it has any utility at all market,
usually I fold over the top of the page
or sometimes put a yellow sticky note I
want to do.
If I find a place where there's an idea
that's worth returning to,
that that's,
um,
that's particularly worth understanding.
And you can't do that with a book like
beyond good and evil because what ends
up happening is you have to mark every
sentence and obviously marketing every
sentence isn't any better than not
marking any sentences at all.
So
I guess I also might as well tell you
why it is worth bothering with a book
like this at all because it's a very
difficult book and it's also the sort of
book that will rattle you up,
so need you is is very interested in the
problem of my value and the problem of
value is not the problem of what is the
world made out or even how does the
world function,
which are more in some sense more
specifically scientific questions,
but how is it that you should conduct
yourself in the world?
How should you act?
And people act towards aims in a sense.
Because we're active creatures and we're
moving from one point to another.
We're moving towards things that we want
and that means that we're guided by our
desires and we're not only guided by
desires in so far as we have individual
desires were guided by the structure
that consists of how those desires are
related to one another.
So for example,
if you have a room full of people,
say a room full of children,
they're active and they're each pursuing
their individual desires,
but at some point they may choose to
organize themselves into a game and if
they organize themselves into a game,
what they're doing for all intents and
purposes,
is producing a little society,
little micro society within that micro
society.
They're deciding what desires will be
currently expressed and how they'll
exist in relationship to one another,
and that means that they can cooperate
without too much conflict and that they
can jointly moved towards a joint ame
without
and and,
and gather all the benefits that might
be associated with that.
And that might be the accomplishment of
the Ame,
whatever it is,
but it also might be just the enjoyment
that's to be had in the pursuit of that
activity.
Now people do that
socially because we have to do that in
order to get along with other people
because our desires have to be melded
with those of other people,
but we also do it psychologically and
those two things exist in a dance
because as I'm interacting with other
people,
the demands of the fact that we're
interacting make require each of us to
arrange our desires in a way that's
acceptable to everyone else,
but at the same time,
while we're doing that,
we're also observing the process by
which those desires are ordered and then
we internalize that process and use that
to order our own desires.
And so there's a constant
mutually informative dance between the
individual and the group and the
culmination of that is the organization
of society and the simultaneous
organization of the psyche and it's that
process that Nietzsche is talking about
in these paragraphs.
Now you might ask yourself,
well,
what's the utility of articulating such
things and them and understanding them,
and the answer in some ways is
straightforward.
If you don't want to run a foul of your
own desires,
you have to organize them.
Because some of them are short term and
some of them are medium term and some of
them are long term and some of the main
this and some of the main that,
and it isn't necessarily the case that
those desires allow for mutual
fulfillment.
So for example,
maybe you're very interested in pursuing
a sexual relationship with someone,
but you're also very interested in
having a family and some stability in
your life or maybe you're interested in
pursuing a sexual relationship with a
whole sequence of people,
but you're also interested in having a
family of stabilizing your life.
It's not obvious that those desires can
exist in the same universe without
producing what you might think about as
a war and some of that might be a
psychological war,
but some of it's also going to be a war
that actually occurs in existence.
Well,
you're fighting through the
contradictory consequences of wanting to
pursue many people and formulate a
stable relationship with one person.
Now,
part of the reason that you want to
think about these sorts of things is
because if you think about them and get
your thoughts and your value system
intelligently and coherently cogently
laid out,
then when you act out that value system
in the world,
you're going to run into less conflict
and less uncertainty and less misery and
you're going to have a higher
probability of getting what it is that
you want,
but you're also going to have a higher
probability of getting what you want in
a way that allows you to cooperate with
other people without entering into too
much conflict with them.
And so in some sense the purpose that
you think,
the reason that you think are the
purpose of thinking is so that you can
sort out how you're going to move
forward in the world without having to
directly run headlong into all the
obstacles that you might run into.
If you were doing such a thing blindly.
And so then you might ask yourself,
well,
why would you bother reading philosophy
or the philosophy written by someone
who's great?
And the answer to that is this.
That they can help you think these
things through in a manner that you
would not be capable of doing on your
own.
You know,
because Nisha,
I mean it's,
it's difficult to estimate how
intelligent Nietzsche it was,
but I suspect he was perhaps one in a
billion,
which would put him far beyond the 99
point nine 99th percentile and there's a
massive difference between the ability
of people to think as you move farther
and farther out into the extremes
intelligence and when you have the
writings of someone who's one in a
billion,
then you can interact with those
writings in a way that enables you,
if you'll put the time into
benefit from the spectacular fact of
that intelligence.
Nisha was a full professor by the time
he was 24 at a time when he didn't even
have to write a dissertation.
They just made him a full professor at a
time where that was.
That never happened.
So this is what he has to say and the
prejudice is a philosopher is just the
first chapter of the book.
Beyond good and evil.
It is gradually become clear to me what
every Greek philosophy up until now has
consisted of namely the confession of
its originator and the species of
involuntary and unconscious
autobiography.
Well,
that's deceptive.
That's a deceptively simple sentence.
Even though it's not a particularly
simple sentence because it.
It stands on its head.
What people generally assume about the
process of thinking.
You generally think that when you're
thinking,
you're thinking about,
as I mentioned before,
the structure of the objective world
need shoes,
is making an entirely different point
here and what he's fundamentally doing
is treating the philosopher not as a
rational being,
but as a living being,
and there's a big difference between
being a rational being and being a
living being.
Because if you're living being your
primary goal is to do whatever it is
that furthers your life and if you're a
rational being,
then your primary goal is to do whatever
it is that a rational being might do.
And you could say that a living being
should first and foremost be a rational
being and in some sense that's the
message of the of the Western
enlightenment.
But it's by no means self evident that
that's the case and it's certainly not
something that Nietzsche,
Nietzsche,
he doesn't believe that people are
rational beings,
certainly not primarily,
and more importantly,
he isn't exactly convinced that they
should be so.
So for example,
one of niches,
most famous maximums is that truth
serves life and that's a very difficult
different idea.
Then the purpose of truth say the
accurate representation of the objective
world.
Those aren't the same thing at all.
Now you could ask,
well,
what does it mean for truth to serve
life?
And if you construe truth that way,
what would truth look like?
And you know the mere statement,
the truths should serve life doesn't
offer you the answers to those
questions,
but
but it,
it's the beginning of a different
metaphysics.
And in some sense of metaphysics,
which is say the universe within which a
philosopher might operate a metaphysics
is the initial structure of
presuppositions within which a view of
the world is organized.
One presupposition might be human beings
are rational and that we're attempting
to formulate and improve our sense of
the objective world,
our formulation of the objective world,
and another would be that you would be.
These aren't rational or irrational and
that we're.
What we're motivated to do is to live
whatever that means and that the purpose
of our thinking and our philosophy
should be to facilitate our living and
that's neat use.
That's one of the foundation
blocks of niches philosophy.
So He's a moral philosopher
fundamentally because morality is about
values and the values essentially values
are
you could say values are what you aim
for,
but it's more complicated than that.
Values actually constitute the lens
through which you view the world.
So it's partly what you're aiming at,
but it's also partly your conception of
who you are now and where you are.
And it's also part that your conception
of how you're going to get to where it
is that you want to be.
And it's also partly the psychological
system that you use to parse up the
world so that it reveals to you the
pathway that you could take to get to
what you want to value values,
all of that,
and then it's more than that because you
could say that you have added value
which contains all of that,
but then you can say that you have a set
of values which is the arrangement of
all about.
And then you can say that you have a set
of values that's the arrangement of all
that,
that you have to arrange with other
people and then you could say that you
have all that and you have to arrange it
with other people and you have to
arrange it across different spans of
time because what you want today and
what you want next week and what you
want next month are not necessarily the
same thing and one does not necessarily
lead into the other.
So to be a moral philosopher is to
examine how that,
what that system is and how it operates
and how it came about.
Now,
one of the things that nature says is it
has gradually become clear to me what
every Greek philosophy up until now is
consisted of namely the confession of
its originator and the species of
involuntary and unconscious
autobiography.
So his claim fundamentally is that no
matter what the philosopher thinks he's
doing well,
he's reading philosophy.
What he's actually doing is revealing
and articulating his being,
and then you might say,
well,
where did that be income from?
And the answer to that is,
well,
partly it's you could consider it a
biological function in so far as that we
have value structures that are built
into us that are in the process.
We would say the process of a very long
evolutionary history,
but because you're also a cultural
phenomena and because the manner in
which you've arranged your values and
your desires has been conditioned to the
degree by the process of enculturation
that you were subjected to when you
confessed and an autobiographical manner
and articulate that what you're also
doing is really capitulating the entire
structure of your culture.
It's in you and you might say,
well,
where is it in you?
And that,
and what does it,
you mean,
part of it means is that you act out a
pattern of behavior and that pattern of
behavior is like a dance that someone is
manifesting to a symphonic score.
It's unbelievably complicated and it has
its psychological elements and some of
those are conscious and some of them
aren't.
Some of them are just implicit in bedded
in the way you act,
in the way you perceive.
And what the philosopher is attempting
to do is to reveal those to himself and
to articulate them so that the entire
structure can be analyzed.
Well.
So niches,
first proposition is that when a
philosopher is thinking that what he's
doing is not thinking,
it's revealing himself in an
autobiographical sense,
under the guise of rational thinking.
And so then it becomes something more
like a story.
Um,
well,
any governors all about in the first two
phrases.
So that gives you some example,
some indication of what this book is
like,
a species of involuntary unconscious
autobiography.
Well,
that's a more complicated idea too
because you might say,
well,
why would someone be driven in an
involuntary way,
in an unconscious way to describe their
autobiography,
and
that's a very complicated question.
It might be that one of the reasons that
people valued one another is because we
engaged in the process of sharing deeply
autobiographical information.
You tell me your story and I tell you my
story,
and you might say,
well,
why?
Why do we even bother with such things?
And the answer to that as well.
If you can tell me about the pain and
tragedy that you've encountered,
then that gives me a better way of that
gives me a better vision of the dangers
of the world without actually having to
expose myself to those dangerous except
in simulation.
I might feel sorry for you.
I might feel bad about your tragic
experiences,
but I'm not bleeding for them.
And then there's always the possibility
that you'll also tell me how you solved
your problem.
In which case I can either avoid that
problem entirely or if I do encounter a
consultant without having to go through.
Maybe it took you decades to formulate
your solution to that problem and you
can tell me your story and then I have
the information,
and so that's part of what human beings
are always trading.
That's why we talk to each other.
That's why we can communicate,
and so Nietzsche would say,
well,
it's.
It's involuntary unconscious,
involuntary unconscious.
He's alluding to the fact that that
proclivity is so deeply embedded in
people.
The desire to make an autobiographical
recounting that
it serves as a kind of motivation that
we don't question for doing almost
everything that we do.
So you know,
I mean,
people do such things as a 10 movies and
plays and they usually do that happily,
especially if the movie or the play is a
high quality.
And the same thing happens when people
are reading novels.
They're attracted to such things.
They have a built in value and it's very
rarely the case that people will ever
question why it is that they're doing
such things.
In fact,
you see this quite commonly with
students who were first introduced to
the study of literature.
The introduction of the idea that you
should analyze what it is that you're
engaged in when you're reading actually
comes as unwelcome news to most people
who are inclined towards fiction because
they don't want to interfere with the
process of engagement,
you know,
automatic unconscious engagement with
the material by detaching themselves and
having to think about what they're
doing.
So that's why it's an involuntary
unconscious.
It's,
it's,
it's one of the things within which
thoughts operates rather than one of the
things on which thought operates.
Then he says,
the moral or immoral purpose in which
every philosophy has constituted.
Sorry,
the moral or immoral purpose in every
philosophy has constituted the true
vital germ out of which the entire plant
has always grown.
Well.
That's a hell of a thing to say too,
because what niche is alluding to there
in some senses that
the philosopher Kant help and that would
be in some sense also the person who was
recounting their autobiography can't
help but tell you what they're up to.
Even though they might not know,
and this is something that you own
because you almost carl,
you'll know the cyclist psychoanalyst
was a great student of nature and you
came to believe that we all inhabited
stories.
The stories were stories we didn't have
in the garage with the structures of
value within which we live and that
those stories essentially had an ethic
or a moral and then you you can start
thinking about what the ethics and the
morals might be and you kind of have
some sense of that because there's.
There's comedic stories and tragic
stories and there's evil characters in
good and characters and so forth.
Those are architected characters,
but part of the point that niches
attempting to make here is that the
philosopher is in fact aiming at
something with his life,
with all of his actions.
He might not even know what it is,
but partly what he's doing in his
attempt to philosophize is to articulate
that in reveal it to himself and to
other people.
So then the question becomes,
well,
what is it that the person is off to
you?
And I would say in some sense that's the
ultimate question and so neat you here
in this paragraph,
it is also dealing with the,
with the ultimate question in life,
which might be well to what is your life
aimed?
And you might say,
well it's not entered anything into.
I don't know.
I don't seem to have any coherent set of
beliefs.
I don't know what I believe.
I don't believe in anything even.
But that's not the case because if you
didn't believe in anything you couldn't
see.
You have to believe in something to be
able to see because you point your eyes
and things and you can organize your
vision without having an aim.
And so the very act of interacting with
the world presupposes an ethic.
And then all those micro ethics that you
contain within you are organized into
some sort of structure either badly or
well.
And that structure roughly has an aim
and you might know it and you might not.
But that doesn't mean that this
therapist.
So,
so one other thing that needs he is
alluding to is that you believe things
whether or not you think you believed
them,
in fairness,
believing them,
unknowing,
you believed them,
aren't even the same thing,
and so the people believe all sorts of
things that they don't know about and
that partly what they're doing when
they're doing philosophy is to try and
figure out what those things are.
When you know,
when you can also ask yourself,
well where did they come from?
Well,
they partly came from you,
but you,
you're an old thing.
Your physical form is three and a half
billion years old and you're the process
of all that.
All of the death and struggling that
went along the entire course of that
three and a half billion years is you
carry that with you and then on top of
that inside you is the consequence of
the entire cultural history of complex
life.
That's all inside youtube.
And then on top of that,
some of that's articulated more or less,
some it's acted out,
dramatized,
represented infection and that sort of
thing.
And then some of it's articulated,
but there's way more at the bottom.
Then it is fully articulate and so god
only knows what you're up to.
And then you might say,
well,
who cares?
Well,
the problem with that is that you care
because first of all,
that's the definition of caring and
second of all that determines the the
way that you'll move through your life
and everything that happens to you
that's good or evil or good or bad is
going to be a consequence of the
manifestation of that ethic in the
world.
So and now,
Nina is saying something else too.
When he says the moral or immoral
purpose in whichever in the moral or
immoral purpose in every philosophy as
constituted the true vital germ out of
which the entire plant is always
growing.
He's saying that the philosopher can't
help but reveal his age and his writings
and then he's saying something else
which is that he might be malevolent and
you know,
modern people are very comfortable with
ideas like malevolence because
malevolence is an idea that's related to
evil and modern people think of
themselves as beyond good and evil to
some degree.
They don't believe in the reality of
those concepts.
And of course in this book is also
questioning our,
at least our a priori presuppositions
about what do they need the lore,
but that doesn't mean that he doesn't
believe that they don't exist.
That doesn't mean that he doesn't
Yes,
I guess that's.
I guess that's right.
You know,
this is one of the things I've thought
about when I was thinking about when
I've thought about how Hitler guide,
no,
Hitler died.
Hitler committed suicide in the bunker
underneath Berlin when Europe was in
flames.
And so one
conclusion that a psychoanalytically
minded historian could derive from that
is that's what he wanted.
Right?
And then that opens up an entire vast
nest of snakes because one of the things
that you might ask is,
well,
how is it that someone would desire
that?
First of all,
could that even be desired?
Is that actually something that anyone
could even desire?
Then you might ask,
well why is it that someone would design
that?
And then the next thing you might ask is
if a human being could desire that and
hit there was a human being then exactly
what does that say about you?
And you might say,
well,
I could never desire such a thing,
but following the long,
the train of the argument that we've
been laying out,
just like what makes you think you're a
reliable judge of what it is that you're
up to.
So,
okay,
so now we've unpack three sentences and
we'll continue on with the same
paragraph.
Indeed to understand how the most
abstract metaphysical assertions of a
philosopher have been arrived at.
It is always well.
And why is to first ask oneself what
morality do they or does he aim at?
So what the question is,
what's the personality?
Well,
there's an entire narrative snakes
underneath that sentence,
that sequence of propositions as well,
and one of them is,
well,
what does it mean that people are up to
something?
What does it mean that the rating itself
accordingly,
I do not believe that an impulse to
knowledge is the father of philosophy,
but that another impulse here as
elsewhere has only made use of knowledge
and mistaken knowledge as an
but whoever considers the fundamental
impulses of man with a view to
determining how far are be up here after
this inspiring.
No,
this is partly why this is going to
require editing so complicated to go
through
accordingly.
I do not believe that an impulse
technologist,
the part of philosophy,
but then another impulse here is
elsewhere,
has only made use of knowledge and
mistaken knowledge as an instrument.
All right,
so let's take that apart accordingly.
I do not believe that an impulse to
knowledge is the father of philosophy.
So one of the claims,
I suppose this would be an enlightenment
claim is that people do have a drive to
knowledge and that that drive is in fact
what underlies the production of such
things as philosophy but need to
questions that because he's trying to
bring us back to consideration of the
fact that you can't separate the
philosophers mind from the philosophers
Ba.
He's first and foremost a living
creature and that he's up to something
and the question is what is it that he's
up to?
And so you can see the earliest
manifestations in a paragraph like this
of what later developed into
deconstructionist thought and that that
was mostly French continental
philosophers who pursued that particular
line of reasoning and it.
It is derived exactly from this kind of
statement by nature.
So for example,
someone like Garrett,
I would say
it doesn't matter what the content of
the text is.
What matters is that the text can be
used as a tool for power and then
whether the person who wrote the text
knew it or not,
that's what they were doing and they
were doing it in a way to privilege
themselves above other people and that's
really,
I would say,
the fundamental deconstructionist claim
and it's a powerful claimants and
utterly corrupt claim,
but it's a really powerful claim and
it's related directly to the sorts of
things that need you was referring to in
this paragraph.
What is it that the person is truly up
to?
Now,
the problem with the deconstructionist
claim,
Ms Dot,
it's an.
It's an open invitation to cynicism to
thoughtless citizens.
I can just make the presupposition that
whatever it is that you're telling me,
you're you,
you're telling me merely to dominate
regardless of what it is that you claim
to be doing.
Well.
The problem with that approach is that
it's predicated on the implicit
assumption that the only value that
people actually have is the value to is
the desire to dominate.
And of course that's a purely like that
could be the case.
And I also think that it's even
reasonable to posit that to some degree
that it is the case,
but to take that from a contributing
factor and to make that the highest God
because that's essentially what the
deconstructionists are doing.
Those are entirely different things and
you have to be aware of people who
take a single causal element and
elevated to the stature of single
comprehensive cause.
You know,
it's more reasonable to assume that
people are complex in their motivations
and that many different strands of
biological and cultural motivation are
in some sense primary.
And then what happens is that they come
together to weave a tapestry rather than
to make the automatic assumption that
you can reduce the entire set of human
motivations to a single principle like
that power.
Now you know,
I would say niche is also responsible to
some degree for the deconstructionists
claim,
that it's power because one of his most
famous other instance was that the
fundamental motivating force in life is
the will to power.
But he wasn't so much because nature is
a subtle thinker.
He wasn't so much attempting to reduce
human motivation to power.
He was attempting to redefine what it
was that we conceptualized as power,
whereas that isn't what the
deconstruction certainly get all because
fundamentally they're Marxists and they
believe that,
you know,
will they just ensconced themselves
within an economic viewpoint where
within a philosophical viewpoint where
economics is paramount and where all
that matters is power construed as
socioeconomic domination,
fundamental,
you know,
and that's in turn is embedded in
metaphysics.
That's even deeper,
which is the metaphysics of presumed
that people are fundamentally
materialist and all of those things are
quick.
You know,
all of those things are highly
questionable.
So I'm going to skip ahead a little bit
with the paragraph when it talks about
the motivations of you might consider
them
people who were working in the middle
ranks of bureaucracies,
whether they're scientific or otherwise,
so they're in some sense acting as
columns in a particular machine.
And so that's what he's describing here.
He says,
in the case of scholars,
or in the case of really scientific men,
it may be there may really be such a
thing as an impulse,
didn't punch some kind of small
independent clockwork,
which when well wound up works away
industriously to that end without the
rest of the scholarly impulses taking
any material part there in the actual
interests of the scholar,
therefore are generally and quite
another direction.
It is the family or moneymaking or in
politics.
It is in fact almost indifferent at what
point of research his little machine is
placed and whether the hopefully you
don't worker becomes a good fit.
Ologist someone who's studied the origin
of words,
a mushroom specialist for a chemist.
He's not characterize becoming this by
this.
He's not characterized by becoming this
or that
niches point.
They're fundamentally is that even when
you do analyze people who in whom
the will to knowledge might actually be
offered it even though he wouldn't be
willing to grant it.
The status of highest motivating power
that even in those people were that
Wilton always does exist.
The probability that that is in turn
subordinated to some other principle
that's higher in the value hierarchy is
very,
very high and it's hard to tell exactly
what that additional principle might be,
but he points out such things as well.
Maybe they're primarily interested in
serving the interests of their family or
they're,
I'm really interested in making money or
maybe they're primarily interested in
status and maybe they're interested in
status status becomes a because it makes
them more sexually attractive and that
sort of thing.
So,
but the,
the,
the question of what is it that's
lurking in the background is always
paramount,
so
not there.
Detour in this particular paragraph,
whoever considers the fundamental
impulses of man with a view to
determining how far they may have here
acted as inspiring Jenai
or his demons will find that they have
all practice philosophy at one time or
another and then each of them would have
been only too glad to look upon itself
as the ultimate end of existence and the
legitimate lord over all of the other
impulses.
That's another like the beyond good and
evil to think of it as a book is a
really foolish
framework.
You don't [inaudible] this is what a
book is when people think about a book.
No,
it's like a material entity say eight
inches high and six inches wide and two
inches thick and weighs a pound and it's
made of paper and it's between two to
two covers you and that's a materialist.
That's the eight priority sort of
axiomatic book niches beyond good and
evil isn't a book at all.
It's a series of bombs at each sentence
is a ball and each sentence blows things
up that people don't even know exist.
And so one of the things with this
sentence,
for example,
here's how he's conceptualizing being so
the first thing he talks about is that
the.
There are fundamental impulses that you
would be.
Okay.
So that begs the questions.
What?
What do you mean by impulse and what do
you mean by fundamental?
And both of those are extraordinarily
complicated problems.
So an impulse you can take it to the
impulses that drive.
You can think about it as a biological
instinct.
He could think about it as an aim or a
goal.
You can think about it as an act of
will.
Like there's,
there's endless questions that hang off
that question,
but we could start with the idea that we
perhaps can't define it,
but we are willing to go with the
proposition that people do have the
impulses and I think maybe that's
manifest to you more.
Most particularly when you're attempting
to do something voluntarily and
something in voluntarily interferes with
that.
You know,
so maybe you're sitting down to to try
to get some work done in the work is not
of any particular intrinsic interest,
but you regarded it as necessary.
You know,
necessary element in some higher order
scheme.
And so you're attempting to organize
yourself so you will in fact concentrate
on that particular relatively mundane
activity.
But what you find when you sit down to
actually engage in that is you can't do
it.
You have to go do the dishes or you have
to clean under the bed or you have to
have a sexual fantasy or you or.
Or there's some other thing that you
could do that's useful.
But that you wouldn't normally do that
you'll go do instead or that you fall
asleep or that you get hungry or like
there's an endless number of that's
called them impulses that might arise to
interfere with your conscious movement
forward.
Well,
exactly what are those things?
nature certainly conceptualizes the
human being as a place where those
things live and he does mean live too
because it wouldn't refer to the Ms Dot
d dot demons or or gs without
introducing the metaphoric conception of
something that lives.
And so partly what nature reveals in
those sentences that he conceptualized
as a human being,
as the dwelling place of spirits.
And some of them are genie.
Let's say that's the root word of
genius.
That's the terribly powerful thing that
exists in the terribly small
compartment,
right,
that you have to call forth.
And some of them are demons and demons
are things that have their own
autonomous will and the generally aren't
aiming for the good.
So then,
so those are all things need.
She just lays out as implicit parts of
the sentence.
So we activates all those ideas,
whether you know it or not,
in your mind,
to the degree that you processed the
sentence and those things start to take
on a life of virtue of their own,
those ideas,
and so
then he adds another dimension of
complexity to that by saying,
well,
you're full of demons in
and and,
and gds and
they're all doing their own thing,
whatever that happens to be,
but each of them,
if left to their own devices,
would attempt to remake the entire world
in there
form.
And so I,
I,
I thought this from a,
from a narrative point of view or from a
symbolic point of view,
in,
in old stories and folktales and
fairytales,
you often have a
cyclops
one I giants,
and there's a sexual connotation to that
which is,
which is apropos that the psychoanalysts
would,
would certainly point out.
But the one idea is that this thing is
gigantic wants one thing.
And so that's another way that Nietzsche
is conceptualizing the fundamental
structure of the human psyche.
It's a dwelling place full of one I
giants.
And they're constantly.
Well,
one thing,
one way of looking at is they're
constantly at war.
One of them wants to be the largest one.
I giant and dominate everything else.
Then one of the things that so Nietzsche
thinks that argument further and he
says,
not only is this always happening in
human beings,
but then if you look at philosophy,
what it is is it's a continual
revelation of the attempt of some
singular minded psychic monster
psychological monster to dominate the
entire psychological structure that are
for the entire cultural structure and
therefore the entire world,
and then you can.
You can see in that the entire religious
structure struggle of mankind to take
this vast polytheistic vision of reality
and to organize it into some sort of
monotheistic,
an integrated structure which you could
also consider indistinguishable from the
civilizing.
The impulse that operates in human
beings to become civilized.
Because on the one hand it might be a
terrible thing that one,
one monster emerges to attempt to
dominate all the others.
But then on the other hand,
there's no difference between that and
organizing something.
Because to organize something is to
bring it all into a hierarchical
structure with some sort of singular
value at the forefront,
and then the question might be,
well,
what should that singular value be?
And then niche you would that pis at the
whole argument back into the first
sentences that he wrote at the beginning
of the paragraph,
which is,
well,
what is it that the philosophers up to?
What is the force that he surfing?
What is the unifying impulse?
That's another way of looking at it.
If there's a unifying impulse and he's
not only fallen prey to some internal
demon,
if there's a unifying impulse to bring
all of this together into some sort of
functional structure,
what exactly might that look like?
For every impulse is imperious and as
such attempts to philosophize.
That's part of that sort of niches,
idea of will to power in its nascent
form.
All of these unconscious entities that
inhabit the human psyche are all alive
and they're trying to live.
They're trying to.
They're trying to climb up the dominance
hierarchy and dominate because of
course,
that's partly what life does because
let's say from an evolutionary
perspective,
and this is probably more true for males
because they are less
effective in their attempts to replicate
the distinction between climbing up a
dominance hierarchy.
Whatever that might happen to be and
success is.
There may be no distinction at all,
and then you might say,
well,
that just shows that there's nothing but
we'll
power,
but
that still doesn't answer.
One of the most fundamental questions is
that power in relationship to what?
Because that's the question.